THE SENATE BUDGET. SUB-COMMITTEE
NUMBER THREE ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES, ALONG WITH NUMBER FIVE
ON CORRECTIONS, PUBLIC SAFETY,
JUDICIARY, LABOR AND
TRANSPORTATION WILL COME TO AN
ORDER. AND WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMUNITY HERE ON BUILDING A
1021 Ó STREET. I ASKED THE REST
OF THE REST OF THE MEM. I ASKED
THE REST OF THE MEM. COME
TRICKLING DOWN. SO TODAY WE HAVE
A WONDERFUL HEARING IN
COLLABORATION WITH MY SENATOR
WITH MY CO-CHAIR SENATOR DRAZI,
WHO WILL BE JOINING US SHORTLY,
HOLDING AN OVERSIGHT HEARING ON
JUVENILE JUSTICE, REALIGNMENT.
IN THE 2020 BUDGET ACT. THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
INITIATIVE PLAN TO PERMANENTLY
CLOSE DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE AND REALIGN THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE CARE AND
SUPERVISION OF ALL JUSTICE
INVOLVED YOUTH TO THE COUNTIES.
HOWEVER WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
REALIGNMENT OF JURISDICTION,
LET'S LET'S NOT FORGET THE CLOSE
TO A BILLION DOLLARS THAT THE
STATE CONTINUES TO BRING DOWN TO
THE COUNTIES, UM AND ENSURING ON
OUR PART THE ACCOUNTABILITY OF
HOW THOSE DOLLARS ARE BEING
UTILIZED TO ADEQUATELY SERVE THE
NEEDS OF THE YOUTH. AS PART OF
THIS TRANSITION, THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE CREATED THE
OFFICE OF YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION OR MOVING FORWARD,
WOULD BE KNOWN AS Ó Y èC R IN
THIS HEARING TO PROVIDE
STATEWIDE ASSISTANCE,
CO-ORDINATION AND OVERSIGHT OF
THE REALIGNED SYSTEM. THE RECENT
CLOSURE ULTIMATE RECENT CLOSURE
OF Dð JJ ON JUNE 30TH 2023
MARKED A MAJOR MILESTONE IN
REALIGNMENT. COUNTIES WITH THE
SUPPORT OF THE STATE ARE IN THE
MIDDLE OF IMPLEMENTING
REALIGNMENT. TODAY WE WILL HEAR
ABOUT THE PROGRESS AND KEY
CHALLENGES IN THE SYSTEM IN MY
FIRST YEAR LAST YEAR OF SUB
THREE CHAIR WE STARTED, UH,
TALKING ABOUT, UM, THE PROGRESS
UP TO THAT POINT, UM, THE
EMBALMING OF Ó Y èC R AND SO
FORTH. UH, SINCE THEN, I'VE GONE
ON A TOUR AROUND THE STATE OF
SEVERAL JUVENILE FACILITIES,
STARTING WITH THE ONE IN MY
BACKYARD. IN MY VERY OWN
DISTRICT. UM, THE BARRY JJ NAOR
JUVENILE HALL. I HAVE ALSO
VISITED, UM, THE PINE GROVE FIRE
CAMP. UM, ABOUT A COUPLE HOURS
AWAY FROM HERE, AND I'VE ALSO
VISITED CAMP KILPATRICK. I WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THESE TOURS. I'VE
SAT DOWN WITH ADVOCATES LEADERS
IN THE SPACE SPACE BOTH IN UH L,
A COUNTY AND ACROSS THE STATE
DIVING FURTHER IN THROUGH MY
LEADERS THROUGH MY CHAIRSHIP OF
SUB THREE AND ENSURING THAT
WE'RE REALLY ALIGNING THE
DOLLARS WITH WHAT OUR INTENTION
WERE WAS COUPLE YEARS AGO WITH
THE CLOSURE OF Dð JJ. TODAY AS
WE CELEBRATE A VALENTINE'S DAY
OR AS YOU, WE THOSE WHO DON'T
CELEBRATE VALENTINE'S DAY. UM
LOVE PERHAPS, IS A THEME THAT
WILL BE BROUGHT UP THROUGHOUT
THIS WHOLE DAY. AND AS WE HAVE
THIS HEARING, I THOUGHT IT WAS
APPROPRIATE THAT WE THINK ABOUT
WHAT LOVE AND CARE WE'RE
PROVIDING TO THE YOUTH ACROSS
THESE JUVENILE HALLS, THESE FIRE
CAMPS AND SO FORTH.
UNFORTUNATELY IT HASN'T BEEN
FULL OF LOVE FOR A LOT OF THESE
YOUTH. PREDOMINANTLY IN L. A
COUNTY. UM, WE'RE GONNA HAVE
ANOTHER, UH, SUB PANEL FOCUSED
DIRECTLY ON L A COUNTY JUST
BECAUSE OF THE HORRENDOUS
STORIES THAT WE'VE HEARD COMING
OUT OF THAT COUNTY.
UNFORTUNATELY WE DID INVITE L A
PROBATION TO JOIN US IN THIS
CONVERSATION, AND THEY DECLINED.
UM I THINK IT'S UM I THINK IT'S
TO BE HONEST AND FOR A
TRANSPARENT UM, A SLAP IN THE
FACE TO NOT COME HERE AND
RESPOND TO THE QUESTIONS OF ME
AND MY COLLEAGUES REGARDING WHAT
IS HAPPENING IN L, A COUNTY AND
HOW WE CAN WORK TOGETHER. IF
YOU'RE AT THE TABLE. WE'RE NOT
GETTING YOUR INPUT. IT'S A ONE
SIDED STORY, AND I HOPE IN THE
FUTURE WE HAVE A PUBLIC
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT'S GOING
ON IN L, A COUNTY AND NOT
PRIVATE CONVERSATIONS AS THEY
DID IN MEETING ME AND MY
COLLEAGUES BEHIND CLOSED DOORS
AND NOT RESPONDING TO THE PUBLIC
IN THIS OVERSIGHT. UM WE WILL BE
LOOKING IN THIS YEAR REGARDING
THE MONEY AND THE GRANTS THAT
ARE GONNA BE DISTRIBUTED TO OUR
COUNTIES TO ADDRESS OUR JUVENILE
HALLS IN LAST YEAR'S, UM, BUDGET
. WE ESTIMATED APPROXIMATELY
$990 MILLION TO COME DOWN ON A
GROUP OF GRANTS TO OUR COUNTIES
TO JUSTICE, REALIGNMENT AND THIS
PROPOSED BUDGET. IT'S
APPROXIMATELY A LITTLE OVER 1
BILLION PROPOSED DOLLARS TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF OUR YOUTH.
WE WANNA MAKE SURE LIKE I
MENTIONED THOSE DOLLARS ARE
GOING DOWN TO WHAT THE NEEDS THE
SPECIFIC NEEDS OF OUR YOUTH. 75%
OF THE KIDS IN OUR FACILITIES
ARE BLACK AND BROWN KIDS.
MAJORITY OF THEM ARE MALE. AND
THE FIRST TIME THEY ENTER OUR
SYSTEM. THEY'RE THE AGES OF 15
TO 16 YEARS OLD. THEY'RE IN
SITUATIONS THAT IS NÓ FAULT OF
THEIR OWN. WHAT FAMILIES THEY
WERE BORN INTO WHAT HOMES. THEY
LIVE IN. WHAT COMMUNITY AND ZIP
CODES THAT WERE GROWING UP IN
BECAUSE US AS SOCIETY DID NOT
INVEST IN THEM ON THEIR EARLY
AGE FROM THEIR FIRST BREATH TO
ENSURE THAT WE AVOIDED THE
SITUATION OF THEM GETTING
INVOLVED WITH THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT. TOGETHER I HOPE WE
WORK BOTH ON THE PREVENTATIVE
SIDE, BUT ALSO WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
WE DO WHEN SOME KIDS FALL
THROUGH THE GAPS, AND THEY FALL
INTO THE JUVENILE JUSTICE. IT IS
OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO RESTORE
THEM BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT LOST
SOULS. UM, I BELIEVE THAT THE
YOUTH, UM EVERY SINGLE YOUTH
DESERVES A 2ND 3RD 4TH 1000
CHANCE TO, UM COME BACK WITH
FULL RESTORATION. WITH THAT. I
WOULD LIKE TO KICK IT OVER.
MADAM CO. AND IF YOU HAVE
ANYTHING ELSE YOU WANT TO ADD TO
OPENING STATEMENTS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
UH, MADAM CHAIR. UM. I AGREE. OF
COURSE, WITH EVERYTHING THAT
YOU'VE SAID AND HOW YOU'VE LAID
THIS OUT. UM THESE YOUTH ARE IN
OUR CUSTODY, AND, UH, WE HAVE
FAILED. WE'RE FILLED IN MANY
WAYS. HOPEFULLY THERE IS
SUCCESSES AS WELL THAT WE COULD
IDENTIFY AS TO HOW TO MAKE THE
CHANGES. UM THESE KIDS I DON'T
THINK EVER HAD EVEN THE FIRST
CHANCE. BECAUSE OF UM. WHERE
THEY WERE BORN AND HOW THEY WERE
BORN AND UM ALL OF THEIR THEIR
LIVES, SO I ACTUALLY THINK THAT
THEY'RE QUITE HEROIC FOR TAKING
UP. UH, THE CHALLENGES, UH, TO
GET THAT FIRST CHANCE THAT THEY
NEVER GOT SO I SEE THEM AS A
VERY STRONG INDIVIDUALS. UH WE
JUST HAVE TO GIVE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY. SO, UM, YOU KNOW
THE COMPLETE REALIGNMENT OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE WAS A MAJOR
UNDERTAKING MAJOR CHALLENGES FOR
EVERYBODY AT EVERY LEVEL NEVER
BEEN DONE BEFORE. AND OF COURSE,
IT ENDED, UH, INITIATED OVER
THREE YEARS AGO. SO NOW IS THE
TIME FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THE REALIGNMENT
HAS ACTUALLY PLAYED OUT. UM WHAT
IS AND ISN'T WORKING AND HOW THE
STATE CAN SUPPORT THE COUNTY AND
THE YOUNG PEOPLE INVOLVED IN THE
SYSTEM. IN PARTICULAR, MY COUNTY
OF L A HAS THE LARGEST JUVENILE
SYSTEM IN THE STATE. AND WITH
THAT COMES A MORE IN DIFFERENT
CHALLENGES. I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO HEARING FROM ALL THE
PANELISTS TODAY, WORKING WITH MY
COLLEAGUES, UM IN SUB THREE
HEALTH AND SERVICES SO WE COULD
SHED LIGHT AND MOVE FORWARD IN A
STRONGER WAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. SO THE PLAN TODAY IS TO
START WITH AN OVERVIEW OF THE
ALIGNMENT SERVER PERSPECTIVES ON
HAND REALIGNMENT IS ROLLING OUT
ACROSS THE STATE WOULD THEN MOVE
TO A PANEL FOCUSED ON JUST L, A
COUNTY AND JUVENILE JUSTICE
THERE AND WE'LL CLOSE BY HEARING
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS FOR OUR
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM MOVING
FORWARD. WE WILL HEAR PUBLIC
COMMENT IN PERSON AT THE END OF
THE HEARING. WITH THAT. LET'S
START WITH OUR FIRST PANEL. WE
WILL START WITH AN OVERVIEW FROM
L A Ó. THANK YOU. SUB COMMITTEE
CHAIRS AND SENATOR. UH, MY NAME
IS ORLANDO SANCHEZ WITH THE L A
Ó. I'VE BEEN ASKED BY YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW ON THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
AND COUNTY FUNDING PROVIDED
THROUGH THE STATE. IF YOU'RE
FOLLOWING ALONG, I PREPARED A
HANDOUT. UM THAT'S ALSO
AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE. UH, IF
YOU TURN A PAGE ONE THAT I'LL
START OFF, GIVING THE SOME OF
THE OVERVIEW ON HOW A JUVENILE
ENTERS THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM, SO THEY ENTER PRIMARILY
AT THROUGH AN ARREST, AND
FOLLOWING THAT ARREST, YOUTHS
ARE GENERALLY TURNED OVER TO
COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENTS
WHERE PROBATION DEPARTMENTS THEN
DETERMINE WHETHER TO REFER THE
YOUTH TO THE JUVENILE COURTS. IF
THE JUVENILE COURT DETERMINES
THAT YOU DID, IN FACT, COMMIT
THE CRIME AND THEN DETERMINES
WHERE TO PLACE THE USE BASED ON
STATE INPUT FROM THE DEFENSE,
PROSECUTORS AND FACTORS SUCH AS
YOUTHS, PREVIOUS CRIMINAL
HISTORY. MOST YOUTH BY THE
PLACED BY THE JUVENILE COURTS
AND WITH THEIR FAMILIES UNDER
THE SUPERVISION OF PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS, BUT SOME ARE PLACED
IN FACILITIES. THESE INCLUDE
JUVENILE HALLS, CAMPS AND
RANCHES. PRIOR TO THE
LEGISLATION ENACTED IN 2020,
STARTING IN 2021, A SMALL NUMBER
WERE REPLACED IN STATE JUVENILE
FACILITIES RUN BY THE DIVISION
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE, WHICH ARE
REFERRED TO AS Dð JJ. AND YOU
ARE RELEASED FROM THE COUNTY
JUVENILE FACILITIES WHEN THE
JUVENILE COURT DETERMINES THAT
THEY'RE READY, OR THEY REACH THE
MAXIMUM AGE. UH LAST YEAR, 41 OF
58 COUNTIES HAD JUVENILE
FACILITIES AND THE STATEWIDE
AVERAGE DAILY POPULATION WAS
OVER 2700, WITH INDIVIDUAL
COUNTIES HAVING LESS THAN ONE
YOUTH TO OVER 500 YOUTHS
CONTINUING ON PAGE TWO, A SMALL
NUMBER OF YOUTHS CAN BE REFERRED
TO THE ADULT COURT AND TYPICALLY
HAPPENS IN THE MOST SEVERE CASES
, UH IN 2022 12 YOUTHS WERE
REMANDED TO ADULT COURT
STATEWIDE. AND THEN ON PAGE
THREE, I'LL COVER THE MOST
RECENT REALIGNMENTS AND THE
CLOSURE OF Dð JJ. THIS IS PART
OF A LONG TERM SHIFT, UH, FROM
MOVING YOUTHS FROM THE STATE
FACILITIES TO COUNTY FACILITIES
AT ITS PEAK IN 1996, NEARLY
20,400 YOUTHS WERE IN A JUVENILE
FACILITY AND HALF OF THOSE WERE
IN STATE RUN FACILITIES. SINCE
THAT TIME, THE STATE HAS TAKEN
VARIOUS STEPS TO REALIGN THIS
POPULATION TO COUNTY RESPON. UM
AND ONE OF THOSE INCLUDES
INCREASING THE COST CHARGED TO
COUNTIES IN 1997, LIMITING THE
TYPES OF USE THAT COULD BE SENT
TO STATE FACILITIES IN 2007 AND
REQUIRING COUNTIES TO SUPERVISE
YOUTHS LEAVING Dð JJ IN 2011.
BUT OVER THIS TIME PERIOD, WE'VE
ALSO SEEN THE NUMBER OF YOUTHS
IN BOTH THE STATE AND THE COUNTY
FACILITIES DECLINE. UM AND THIS
IS PARTLY THIS IS MOSTLY DRIVEN
BY REDUCTION IN JUVENILE
ARRESTS. UNDER THE LEGISLATION
ADOPTED MOST RECENTLY IN 2020
RESPONSIBILITY FOR Dð JJ YOUTHS
HAS BEEN FULLY REALIGNED, WITH
INTAKE, GENERALLY STOPPING TO
STATE FACILITIES AS OF JULY, 1ST
OF 2021. UM CONTINUING WITH THE
TIMELINE ON PAGE FOUR. THE R Dð
JJ FACILITIES HAVE NOW CLOSED AS
OF JUNE 30TH OF LAST YEAR, AND
THE YOUTH THAT WERE STILL HOUSED
AT THOSE FACILITIES WERE
TRANSFERRED TO COUNTIES WITH
INDIVIDUALIZED TRANSITION PLANS.
AND AT THE TIME OF THE
REALIGNMENT, IT WAS EXPECTED
THAT ABOUT OVER 900 YOUTHS WERE
PROJECTED TO BE SHIFTED AT FULL
IMPLEMENTATION, WHICH WOULD HAVE
BEEN 2425. THIS WOULD HAVE
REPRESENTED A 26% INCREASE OVER
THE 2019 PRE REALIGNMENT LEVELS
TO THE COUNTIES. BUT IN 2020
THREE, THE AVERAGE DAILY
POPULATION WAS 880 YOUTHS LOWER
THAN THOSE 2019 PRE REALIGNMENT
LEVELS AT THIS TIME. IT'S
UNCLEAR WHAT'S DRIVING SOME OF
THOSE LOWER AND IT'S SOME OF IT
IS FROM THE JUVENILE. UM LOWER
JUVENILE ARRESTS, BUT OR IT
COULD BE INDICATIVE OF THE COVID
THE EFFECTS OF COVID-19. UH, BUT
RIGHT NOW, IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER
THIS IS A TEMPORARY, UH LOWER
NUMBER OR IT'S INDICATIVE OF A
DOWNWARD TREND. AND THEN
CONTINUING ON PAGE FIVE. I
DIRECT YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
TABLE THERE THAT PROVIDES SOME
OF THE MAJOR SOURCES OF FUNDING
PROVIDED TO COUNTIES THROUGH THE
STATE. THE TOP SECTION OF THAT
COVERS THE FUNDING PROVIDED FOR
THE REALIGNED POPULATIONS THAT I
MENTIONED EARLIER, THEN THE
SECOND PART COVERS, UH, FUNDING
THAT THE STATE PROVIDES FOR
OTHER JUVENILE JUSTICE
ACTIVITIES. NOW I'LL PROVIDE A
BRIEF DESCRIPTION OF EACH OF
THOSE THE YOUTHFUL OFFENDER
BLOCK. GRANT SUPPORTS THE
REALIGNED POPULATION IN 2007.
THIS IS DUE TO LIMITING WHAT
YOUTH COULD ENTER THE Dð JJ
FACILITIES. UH, THE NEXT ONE IS
THE JUVENILE REENTRY GRANT,
WHICH SUPPORTS THE REALIGNED
POPULATION BEING DISCHARGED FROM
Dð JJ THAT HAPPENED IN 2010 11,
AND THESE FUNDS GENERALLY GROW
FROM YEAR TO YEAR AS SHOWN ON
THE ON THE TABLE. AND THE MOST
RECENT JUVENILE JUSTICE
REALIGNMENT BLOCK. GRANT
PROVIDES ANNUAL FUNDING DUE TO
THE CLOSURE OF Dð JJ. AND THEN
ONE OTHER NOTE I'D LIKE TO
MENTION IS THAT AS PART OF THE
REALIGNMENT THE THERE WAS A
TEMPORARY ALLOCATION FORMULA OF
THIS BLOCK GRANT. UM THAT WAS
SET TO EXPIRE ON JAN. JANUARY
10TH AND THE GOVERNOR IS
PROPOSING STATUTORY CHANGES TO
KEEP THAT CURRENT FORMULA IN
ADDITIONAL YEAR, UH, TO GIVE
MORE TIME FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
TO ENGAGE WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND STAKEHOLDERS ON WHAT A
PERMANENT FORMULA WOULD LOOK
LIKE. AND CAN CONTINUING ON THE
FINAL PAGE. THE STATE ALSO
PROVIDED SINCE 2007/400 MILLION
IN ONE TIME FUNDING. UH FOR
COUNTIES TO RENOVATE THEIR
JUVENILE FACILITIES OR CONSTRUCT
JUVENILE FACILITIES. AND SOME OF
THE ADDITIONAL PORTION OF THE
FUNDING THAT THAT'S ON. THAT
SECOND PORTION OF THE TABLE
INCLUDES TOTALS OVER 500 MILLION
ANNUALLY, AND THIS COVERS THE
JUVENILE PROBATION ACTIVITIES.
GRANT WHICH PROVIDES FUNDING, UH
FOR YOUTHS UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THE JUVENILE
COURT THAT THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
CRIME PREVENTION ACT, WHICH
PROVIDES FUNDING FOR SERVICES
TARGETED TO USE IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. THEIR FAMILIES
ARE AT RISK OF BEING IN IT. THEN
THE THIRD ONE IS A JUVENILE
PROBATION FUNDING GRANT, WHICH
PROVIDES FUNDING TO COUNTIES
THAT OPERATE CAMP AND RANCHES.
THANK YOU, AND I'M HERE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE, UH, MS CAITLIN
O'NEAL. AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD YOUR
QUESTIONS UNTIL AFTER THE ENTIRE
SUB PANEL. ONE IS DONE. UM,
PANELISTS, WE HAVE SO MANY
PEOPLE, WONDERFUL PEOPLE TO HEAR
FROM IF WE COULD KEEP OUR
REMARKS TO UNDER FIVE MINUTES,
PLEASE. THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. OUR PURPOSE IS TO
PROVIDE STATEWIDE LEADERSHIP AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN KEY
YOUTH JUSTICE POLICY AREAS TO
ALL JUVENILE JUSTICE PARTNERS,
GOVERNMENT AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS. WE DO NOT HAVE
DIRECT OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY OVER
THE CONDITIONS OF THE COUNTY
JUVENILE HALLS WHILE OUR OMBUDS
PERSON CAN RESPOND TO INDIVIDUAL
COMPLAINTS. WE HAVE NÓ OVERSIGHT
FACILITY INSPECTION AUTHORITY.
WE DO ANALYZE THE COUNTY PLANS
RE RECEIVE THE COUNTY PLANS AND
WE ARE AWARE OF THE COUNTY
PROGRAMS, ACCESS TO PROGRAMS,
HEALTH CARE, BEHAVIORAL HEALTH,
TREATMENT AND EDUCATION ARE THE
CENTRAL TENET OF THE Tð THAT Ó
YR PROVIDES TO COUNTIES AND
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE
STATE TO DATE Ó I èC R HAS
PROVIDED OVER 100 INSTANCES OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE, INCLUDING
BRIEFS CONNECTING SYSTEM,
PARTNERS TO RESOURCES AND
PROVIDING INFORMATION AND
GUIDANCE ON SPECIFIC TOPICS. WE
HAVE CONDUCTED A SERIES OF
WEBINARS TO HELP COUNTIES
UNDERSTAND PROMISING AND
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES THAT
KEEP HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES,
PRIORITIES AND VISION FOREFRONT.
WE HAVE TRAINED OVER 700
PARTNERS SPECIFIC TO CAL. AIM WE
ARE WORKING WITH èC B S¼ WITH
LIVED EXPERIENCE STAFF TO
CONTRACT WITH MANAGED CARE PLANS
TO PROVIDE M SERVICES TO BOTH
PRE RELEASE AND DETENTION AND
AFTER STEP DOWN TO LESS
RESTRICTIVE PROGRAMS IN 2020,
THREE WE CONDUCTED 41 SITE VISIT
VISITS MET WITH 78 èC B S¼ AND
ATTENDED 147 PUBLIC COUNTY
MEETINGS. WE HAVE COMMITTED
$14.1 MILLION FOR CBO CAPACITY
BUILDING. WE ENSURE THAT
DIVERSION KEEPING YOUTH IN THE
MOST RESTRICTIVE SETTINGS FOR
THE LEAST AMOUNT OF TIME AND
THAT YOUTH REMAIN IN THE
JUVENILE COURT SYSTEMS. BY DOING
THE FOLLOWING. WE PUBLISHED Tð A
DOCUMENTS THAT FOCUS ON RESEARCH
THAT PROMOTES POSITIVE YOUTH
JUSTICE AND ITS RELATIONSHIP TO
PUBLIC SAFETY. WE PROVIDE
TRAINING IN SUCH TOPICS AS
POSITIVE YOUTH JUSTICE, THE USE
OF CREDIBLE MESSENGERS AND OUR
WORK ON ENDING THE INCARCERATION
OF GIRLS AND GENDER EXPANSIVE
YOUTH. WE HAVE ALLOCATED $15
MILLION IN LESS RESTRICTIVE
PROGRAM GRANTS TO 11 COUNTIES TO
RUN PILOT SITES ON STEPPING
YOUTH BACK INTO COMMUNITIES WITH
HIGH TECH MODELS THAT INVOLVE
ECONOMIC SUPPORT TO SUSTAIN
EMERGING ADULTS AND WE ARE
FUNDING A STAKEHOLDER.
INITIATIVE TO PROMOTE TO PROMOTE
COLLABORATIVE JUSTICE COURT
MODELS FOR YOU SENT TO S¼ Y Tð
S¼ IN 2022. IT LOOKED LIKE THERE
WERE TWO YOUTH UH, 2021 2022 2.
YOU STEP DOWN TO LESS RESTRICTED
PROGRAMS AND IN 2022 2020 THREE
100 YOUTH WERE REPORTED TO HAVE
STEPPED DOWN TO LESS RESTRICTIVE
PROGRAMS. Ó Y èC R HAS
IDENTIFIED 94 LESS RESTRICTED
PROGRAMS WITH THE ASSISTANCE OF
èC. WE ALSO TRACK COUNTIES
WHICH ALLOW DAY FURLOUGHS TO
COLLEGE AND WORK. AND WE HAVE
NOW COUNTED EIGHT COUNTIES THAT
ALLOW THE YOUTH TO LEAVE DURING
THE DAY WE ATTRACT. WE TRACK THE
ABOVE INFORMATION THROUGH A
DIVERSE APPROACH THAT INCLUDES
VARIOUS PUBLIC DATA SOURCES AND
ENGAGEMENT STRATEGIES THAT
INCLUDES CONDUCTING SITE VISITS
PARTICIPATING IN COUNTY MEETINGS
. LEVERAGING DATA FROM OUR
OMBUDS DIVISION, REVIEWING THE
COUNTY PLANS AND ANALYZING THE A
B 102 DATA DIRECTLY FROM THE
COUNTIES. OUR FOCUS ON IS
IMPROVING THE FRAMEWORK THAT
CENTERS, RACIAL AND ETHNIC,
ETHNIC EQUITY. GUIDING US TO
REVIEW DATA DISAGGREGATED BY
RACE, ETHNICITY, GENDER,
GEOGRAPHY AND SEXUAL ORIENTATION
, GENDER IDENTITY AND EXPRESSION
. THIS ALLOWS US TO CREATE
TAILORED STRATEGIES LIKE OUR
CAMPAIGN TO END THE
INCARCERATION OF GIRLS AND
GENDER, EXPANSIVE YOUTH AND TO
FOCUS ON THE EARLY
IDENTIFICATION OF NATIVE
AMERICAN YOUTH IN THE JJ SYSTEM,
BOTH Kò THROUGH 12 AND HIGHER
EDUCATION ACCESS ARE WAYS THAT
WE ARE CREATING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR EQUITY FOR OUR YOUTH. REACH
AN EQUAL OUTCOME AS THEIR
PRIMARY CULTURE PEERS. WE HAVE
ASSISTED COUNTIES IN GETTING
COLLEGE PREP COURSES, COLLEGE
COURSES AND COLLEGE COURSES INTO
THEIR FACILITIES. WE HAVE
PROVIDED Tð A TO PARTNERS WHO
NEED INFORMATION ON LITERACY
PROGRAMS, AND WE HAVE PROVIDED
TO YOU TO JUDGES ABOUT WHAT
OTHER JUDGES ARE DOING THAT
ALLOWS, UH, YOUTH TO ATTEND
COLLEGE OUTSIDE OF THE
FACILITIES. WE ARE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH RISING SCHOLARS AND
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION IN WHICH WE ARE
WORKING TO RELEASE $30 MILLION
OVER THREE YEARS TO 10 COUNTIES.
BUILD A PROBATION WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FOR YOUTH. WHAT IS
WORKING APPROACHING THE REFORM
WORK ACROSS STAKEHOLDER SPECTRUM
, ENGAGING COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION, PROBATION. BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH JUDGES, DS VICTIM
ADVOCATES, DEFENDERS, SOCIAL
SERVICES, YOUTH ADVOCATES, YOUTH
AND THEIR FAMILIES. THIS HAS
BEEN OUR FOCUS TO BUILD THESE
BRIDGES AND PARTNERSHIPS AND TO
WORK TOGETHER AS YOUTH IN
CUSTODY ARE PARENTED BY ALL OF
THESE ENTITIES. WE ALSO ARE
BUILDING STATE LEVEL REFORM
AGENDAS WITH OUR SISTER AGENCIES
LIKE Dð Ó R Dð S¼ S¼ HÌ Kò èC
YB HÌ I AND Dð HÌ THAT INCLUDES
OUR JUVENILE JUSTICE. POPULATION
KEY CHALLENGES ARE DEVELOPING
SUSTAINABLE SOLUTIONS FOR YOUTH
WITH COMPLEX MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
AND THE LACK OF UNIFORMITY
AROUND TREATMENT. INTERVENTIONS
FOR YOUTH WHO OFFEND SEXUALLY,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT RIGHT ON
THE MONEY DIRECTOR. OK, NEXT UP.
KAREN PINK FROM UH CÁC. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR THE
INVITATION TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY. MY NAME IS KAREN PINK. I
HAVE THE HONOR OF SERVING AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA. I KNOW YOU HAVE A
PACKED AGENDA HARD TO DESCRIBE
THE ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF WORK
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN DONE. UM AND
TO TRY TO HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE
SUCCESSES OF THIS REFORM AND NOT
BECAUSE CHALLENGES DON'T EXIST,
AND I CERTAINLY WOULD BE HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT
. BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO LOOK AT
SOME OF THE SUCCESS AND
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THAT SO THAT
IT MAY PAVE THE WAY TO THE
POSSIBILITIES THAT I THINK, UM,
SENATOR MANAR SPOKE OF AT THE
OUTSET OF THIS COMMITTEE
HEARING. UM IT'S YOU KNOW,
SOMETIMES THE REAL STORY CAN GET
LOST IN DATA OR PROGRAM
DESCRIPTIONS, AND ALL OF THOSE
ITEMS ARE ARE VERY IMPORTANT
PART TO THE STORY AND HELP GUIDE
US TO DEVELOP NEW POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS. HOWEVER IT DOESN'T
TELL THE WHOLE STORY. UM SO I
WANTED TO START WITH A FEW OF
THOSE SUCCESS STORIES THAT WERE
PUT INTO MOTION BY YOUR SUPPORT.
UM SO THAT YOU HAVE A SENSE OF
NOT JUST HOW OR THE WHAT
PROBATION DOES BUT THE WHY YOUTH
ENTERED A YOUTH WHO HAVE BEEN
ENTRENCHED IN GANGS FOR YEARS.
UH, WE NOW SEE HOLDING THE THREE
0.8 GB GPA AND ATTENDING THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THAT, UM, THAT
WAS JUST CITED IN THE EARLIER
TESTIMONY SET TO GRADUATE IN
JUNE. THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO
SEE. MORE OF. HE BECAME A MENTOR
TO OTHER YOUTH IN HIS FACILITY
AND ACTIVELY PARTICIPATED IN
PARENTING CLASSES AT THAT
FACILITY AND WILL AID UM,
EVENTUALLY HIS REUNIFICATION
EFFORTS. HIS OWN CHILDREN. A
YOUTH THAT WAS ATTENDING
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WITHIN A
LOCALS, TF WAS RECRUITED FOR A
PAID INTERNSHIP WITH FINANCE
SOFTWARE COMPANY IN INTO IT. ONE
COUNTY HAD EIGHT GRADUATES OF
THE MULTICORE CRAFT CURRICULUM,
WHICH IS A CONSTRUCTION TRADE
PROGRAM JUST LAST YEAR. AND
AFTER BEING BOUNCED AROUND FROM
SCHOOL TO SCHOOL, ANOTHER YOUTH
OBTAINED THEIR AA DEGREE IN
BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY ENROLLING IN THE
NATIONAL ACADEMY OF SPORTS
MEDICINE WITH DREAMS TO OPEN HIS
OWN PERSONAL TRAINING BUSINESS.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO SEE. MORE
OF. THAT'S WHAT WE'RE STRIVING
TO GET TO SO TO CONTINUE DOWN
THIS PATH AND SUPPORT THE LOCAL
OPTIONS. THERE ARE ADDITIONAL
THINGS THAT THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WANT TO LOOK AT TO HELP ADDRESS
SOME OF THE REMAINING CHALLENGES
THAT EXIST. UM I WANNA FOCUS IN
ON THE VOCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
AS A DIRECTOR LUCERO HAS HAS
TALKED ABOUT. THERE'S BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF FOCUS ON
THE POST EDUCATIONAL AND WE ARE
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THAT. BUT
VOCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES REMAIN
AT THE VERY TOP OF THE LIST OF
THE FOR THE YOUTH. THE YOUTH ARE
ASKING FOR. VOCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES. AND SO WHILE WE
HAD THINGS LIKE CULINARY AND
CONSTRUCTION, UH, TRADES ALREADY
EMBEDDED IN OUR PROGRAMMING, UH
S¼ B 23 HAS SUPPORTED NEW
PROGRAMS SUCH AS AN AGRICULTURAL
PROGRAM WITHIN THE FACILITY, SO
THERE'S FARMING AND LIVESTOCK
INSIDE THE FACILITY THAT THE
YOUTH ARE WORKING ON AND FULL
AUTO SHOP WITH A FULL CAR LIFT
ON SITE. I WON'T LIE TO YOU. I
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THAT
MEANS. BUT I'VE BEEN TOLD IS
VERY, UH FOR TRAINING PURPOSES,
A MUSIC STUDIO DOG RESCUE
THERAPY PROGRAMS WHERE THE DOGS
ACTUALLY LIVE ON THE UNIT. BUT
WE NEED MORE. THEREFORE CPAC IS
HOPING TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE STATE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH Ó èC R
TO LOOK AT ALL THE STATE
PROGRAMS AND INVESTMENTS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN PUT IN PLACE
OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS TO
DEVELOP A REPOSITORY FOR
COUNTIES TO REQUEST ASSISTANCE
IN DEVELOPING THOSE FURTHER
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES. WE
THINK THAT WILL BE VIÆT. FOR
THEIR SUCCESS. AS WE ALL KNOW,
UM, AS WE HAVE TOGETHER, WORKED
TO DECREASE THE DETENTION
FOOTPRINT. THOSE LEFT IN
DETENTION OFTEN FIND THEMSELVES
HAVING THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
NEEDS IN OUR FACILITIES. AND
WHILE WE DID OBSERVE AN INCREASE
IN SUBSTANCE USE WITH YOUNG
ADULTS THAT RETURN TO LOCAL
CUSTODY FROM G JJ AT THE TIME OF
CLOSURE AND A GENERAL UPTICK IN
DRUG USAGE, SOME OF THAT IMPACT
IS SLOWLY DISSIPATING DUE TO
QUICKLY STANDING UP INTERDICTION
EFFORTS BALANCE WITH
INDIVIDUALIZED TREATMENT. WHILE
THERE'S ALWAYS MORE NEED FOR
RESOURCES IN THIS SPACE, UM, ONE
OF THE THINGS WE THINK AS A
POTENTIAL OPPORTUNITY IS TO
ENHANCE AND LEVERAGE. THE
JUSTICE INVOLVED CAL A WORK SO
WE'RE DOING A LOT OF WORK IN
THAT SPACE TO TRY TO DO JUST
THAT, AND WE ARE PROPOSING TO
EMBED DEDICATED STAFF WITHIN
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS TO
SPECIFICALLY FOCUS ON ALIGNING
THOSE COURT ORDERED PLANS AND
PROBATION. REENTRY WORK WITH THE
CAL ELIGIBLE FUNDING SUPPORTS.
NOW A BIT ON THE FACILITIES
WHILE MANY OF YOU HAD COME TO
VISIT, AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT AND INVITE YOU ALL TO DO,
UM, TO DO MORE OF THAT, WHILE
FACILITY IMPROVEMENT IS PROBABLY
AN ITEM THAT TAKES THE LONGEST
TO ADDRESS WE ARE SEEING SOME
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT
LATER ON, AND, UM, YOU WOULD
LIKE, BUT ONE OF THE BEST
STORIES I'VE HEARD THAT
SHOWCASES THE SPIRIT OF WHAT WE
BELIEVE 823 IS ALL ABOUT IS HOW
DEPARTMENTS ARE REALLY ENGAGING
THE YOUTH TO DEVELOP WHAT THOSE
FACILITIES SHOULD LOOK LIKE. AND
HELP INFORM THE DESIGN AND BE A
PART OF EVEN THE BUREAUCRATIC
PROCESS. RIGHT WE HAVE THE
MEETING WITH ARCHITECTS AND
DESIGNERS AND DESCRIBING TO
THEIR JUVENILE JUSTICE
SUBCOMMITTEES WHAT THEIR VISION
IS. SO I THOUGHT THAT WAS AN
AMAZING STORY IN ONE OF OUR, UH,
DEPARTMENTS. WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
WRAP UP A LITTLE BIT. OK UH, I
KNEW I WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO MAKE
IT ALL THE WAY THROUGH. SO UM,
UH, ONE OF THE THINGS THOUGH,
BEYOND FACILITIES THAT WE ARE
SUGGESTING THE LEGISLATURE TRY
TO ADDRESS, UM, IS ESTABLISH A
JUVENILE JUSTICE SUPPORTIVE
LIVING PROGRAM WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO
PROVIDE GRANTS TO THE YOUTH
DIRECTLY TO SUPPORT THEIR
TRANSITIONAL LIVING AFTER THEY
LEAVE US. AND IN CONCLUSION, I
WOULD BE REMISS IF I DID NOT
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO QUICKLY
NOTE THE WORK OF OUR DEDICATED
STAFF SERVING OUR YOUTH. WE MUST
SUPPORT THOSE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THOSE WHO ARE SUPPORTING THE
SUCCESS FOR THEIR YOUTH.
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE DEALING
WITH STAFFING SHORTAGES. AND
WHILE THE YOUTH AND EMERGING
ADULTS IN OUR FACILITIES ARE
BECOMING MORE COMPLEX, MUCH MORE
DISCUSSION IS NEEDED IN THIS
SPACE, HOWEVER, TO SUPPORT THE
FUTURE OF, UH, THE PROFESSION,
WE HAVE BEEN PURSUING A PROPOSAL
TO DEVELOP A BACHELOR. DEGREE
PROGRAM THAT REFLECTS THE
MULTIDISCIPLINARY ACADEMIC
APPROACH THAT UNIQUELY SUPPORTS
THE WORK OF THE COUNTY PROBATION
DEPARTMENT AND SPECIFICALLY
MODERNIZING OUR APPROACH TO HOW
WE SUPPORT THOSE IN THE FIELD
WILL NOT ONLY BETTER PREPARE THE
WORKFORCE IN THE SPIRIT OF A 23,
BUT WILL ALSO INFORM THE NEXT
GENERATION OF THE OPPORTUNITIES
WITHIN THE PROFESSION. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NOW WE'LL TURN OVER TO SOME
ADVOCATES, UM, JASMINE AND, UH,
BROOKE. THE FIRST. YEAH. I I'LL
START MY. ALL RIGHT. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR. UH, SET OF
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS JASMINE
DEAO. FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU
FOR GROUNDING AND SETTING THIS
HEARING IN LOVE IN THE SPIRIT OF
LOVE, AND I HOPE THAT YOU, UH,
RECEIVE THIS TESTIMONY IN THAT
SPIRIT AND NOTHING ELSE
CENTERING THE YOUNG PEOPLE. MY
NAME IS JASMINE. DELA FOS. I'M A
YOUTH ADVOCATE, A MEMBER OF THE
ALLIANCE, CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY JUSTICE, AS
WELL AS A MEMBER OF NUMEROUS
YOUTH JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS. UM
FOR OVER THE LAST DECADE, I'VE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
YOUNG PEOPLE, UM AND ENSURING
THAT THEY ACCESS TO RESOURCES
AND THE SUPPORT THEY NEED TO BE
ABLE TO THRIVE AND HEAL. UM I'VE
BEEN ASKED TODAY TO SHARE WITH
A, UH SHARE ABOUT SOME OF THE
STORIES WE HEARD FROM ADVOCATES
AND YOUNG PEOPLE AND
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
ABOUT THE CHANGES IN PROGRESS.
UM THAT HAVE BEEN MADE TOWARDS
THIS CONTINUUM. UM TODAY I'M
HERE, UM, AS A YOUTH ADVOCATE
AGAIN, WHO HAS HAD PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE WITHIN, UH, FACILITIES
BOLT FORMALLY AT Dð JJ, AS WELL
AS CURRENT JUVENILE HALL
FACILITIES HERE. I'VE ALSO HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO, UH, JUST BEEN
DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY THE
CRIMINAL. SYSTEM UM SO HAD
FIRSTHAND, UM, RECOGNIZING AND
SEEING THE HARSH REALITIES OF
FIRST HAND DIRECTLY FROM YOUNG
PEOPLE, HEARING IT FROM YOUNG
PEOPLE. AND ALSO SEEING IT, UM
I'VE ALSO TRAVELED UP AND DOWN
THE STATE FROM MANY FACILITIES
UP AND DOWN THE STATE, UM,
HEARING AND SUPPORTING YOUNG
PEOPLE AS THEY RETURNED BACK
FROM Dð JJ INTO LOCAL JUVENILE
HALL FACILITIES. UM AS WELL AS
SUPPORTING THEM, UM, IN THEIR
CURRENT, UH, TRANSITION PLANS
AND SUPPORTED SERVICES AFTER, UM
I WORKED WITH, UH, YOUNG PEOPLE
IN COUNTIES ALL THE WAY FROM SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY TO L, A COUNTY,
ORANGE COUNTY, KERN COUNTY,
SACRAMENTO COUNTY, TULARE COUNTY
, KINGS COUNTY, MONTEREY,
ALAINA, MERCED, SANTA CLARA AND
MORE TO NAME A FEW, UH,
TRANSITIONS HAVE CONTINUED TO BE
DIFFICULT. THEY BEEN MANY
FIRSTHAND STORIES THAT HAVE
EXPRESSED FRUSTRATION AND
CONCERNS AROUND THE LACK OF
PROGRAMMING AND FACILITIES. AND
I WANTED TO NAME THAT THE
CONSIDERATION FOR LESSER
RESTRICTIONS CONTINUE TO BE, UM,
IN SOME COUNTIES, UH, NON
EXISTENT, THE EXTENT OF THE
TRAUMATIC STORIES FROM YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT I HEAR CONTINUE TO
BE DEVASTATING AND CAN TAKE LIKE
I SAID SEVERAL HOURS TO SHARE
SOME OF THESE STORIES, BUT WHAT
I WILL SHARE IS THAT, UM, WHAT
WE ARE HEARING FROM YOUNG PEOPLE
IS THAT S¼ Y Tð F S¼, UM
UNDERSTANDING THAT S¼ TFS AGAIN
WERE NEVER CREATED FOR LONG TERM
STAYS. UM AND 11 OF THE THINGS
THAT WE CONTINUE TO SEE IS
SOMETIMES THE, UM THE LACK OF,
UM, THOUGHT AROUND WHAT IT WOULD
LOOK LIKE POST THIS JUVENILE
HALLS AND THESE FACILITIES, UM,
LOCK SOME OF THE MOBILITY FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE WE HEAR FROM YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT IT LACKS THE FREEDOM
OF MOVEMENT. IT LACKS THE
FREEDOM OF OUTSIDE ENGAGEMENT IN
SOME COUNTIES. WE HEAR THAT SOME
YOUNG PEOPLE DON'T EVEN GET TO
GO OUTSIDE. UM I IF THEY DO,
IT'S ONCE A WEEK OR SOMETHING.
UM, THERE ARE COUNTIES THAT YOU
NEED TO LACK COMMUNITY ACCESS
FOR S¼ Y Tð F, SO WE NEED TO
ALLOW MORE ORGANIZATIONS AND
ORGANIZATION PROVIDERS TO
RECEIVE ACCESS. WE CONTINUE TO
HEAR THE STRUGGLES AND, UM AND
THE LACK OF COMMITMENT TO WORK
WITH GROUPS AND ORGANIZATIONS
WHO ARE ALREADY DOING THIS WORK
WHO HAVE DONE DECADES OF WORK
SERVING YOUNG PEOPLE WHO HAVE
EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAMMING YET
STILL CONTINUE TO BE, UM, NOT
INCLUDED AS POTENTIAL AS
POTENTIAL AS A RESTRICTIVE, UM,
FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION. WE ALSO HEARD SOME
ABOUT SOME THINGS. ON EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES HERE, BUT I KNOW
DIRECTLY FROM YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
SHARED WITH ME THEIR CONCERN
AROUND TAKING AND HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE HIGHER ED
EDU. UH UM, OPPORTUNITIES, BUT
THEY'RE ONLY GIVEN ONE COURSE.
UM, AND MOST OF THOSE TIMES
THOSE COURSES ARE ALWAYS, UM,
ELECTIVE COURSES. I NEVER GO
TOWARDS THEIR GENERAL ED. AND SO
WE HEAR FRUSTRATION FROM YOUNG
PEOPLE SAYING I COULD TAKE MORE,
UM, EDUCATION PROGRAMS, BUT
OFTENTIMES THEY AREN'T. UM,
THOSE YOUTH WHO ARE NOT IN, UM,
DEALS YOUTH WHO ARE OVER 18, WHO
ARE NOT TAKING HIGH SCHOOL
CREDITS. UM ARE BASICALLY
SPENDING TIME WITHIN THEIR
WINDOW FOR SEVERAL HOURS, UM,
KNOWING THAT THEY CAN BE ABLE TO
TAKE MORE ADVANTAGE OF TIME. OH,
MY GOD. TIME IS GOING FAST. UM
WE HAVEN'T SEEN UNIFORMITY
AROUND THE YOUTH, UH, REVIEW
BOARD HEARINGS IN COUNTIES. I'VE
SAT IN SEVERAL TRANSITION
HEARINGS. UM I HAVE SEEN THE
LACK OF, UM, CONSIDERATION FOR
STEPS DOWN AS IT'S BEING
CONSIDERED BEFORE THE BOARD.
HOPEFULLY BURKE CAN TALK MORE
ABOUT THAT. UM WE BELIEVE THAT
IT CONTINUES TO BE UNACCEPTABLE
THAT, UM, THAT THERE ARE NOT
CONSIDERATIONS FOR THAT, AS IT
GOES FOR THE REALIGNMENT. UM
THERE WAS A MARK TO SHIFT. UM
FUNDING. WE ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
YET TO SEE SOME OF THOSE
INVESTMENTS GO BACK INTO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
AS YOU PROBABLY DO AN ANALYSIS
AND RECOMMEND THAT THE BOARD
HERE DO AN ANALYSIS ON HOW
COUNTIES ARE SPENDING MONEY AND
HOW MUCH IS GOING TOWARDS, UM
PROBATION AND NOT NECESSARILY
ORGANIZATIONS DIRECTLY. UM, IF
THEY ARE, IT'S REALLY LESS THAN
1% IN MANY COUNTIES, AND THAT
WE'VE SEEN THAT IN TERMS OF
COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT. UM, WE
ARE ASKING THAT, UM WE WORK WITH
THAT PROBATION, CONTINUE TO WORK
MORE AND NOT SERVE ALWAYS AS A
GATEKEEPER IN CONTROLLING THE
INPUT THAT PEOPLE HAVE IN
PARTICIPATION. UM AND WE HOPE
THAT THIS CONTINUED TO LEAD
ORGANIZATION, UH, LEAD PARTNERS
TO THINK ABOUT THAT, UM, WE LAID
OUT A LOT. I KNOW I TALKED A
LOT. I HAVE MORE TO ADD. SO IF
WE HAVE QUESTIONS, I'D LOVE TO
GET TO IT. UM AND WE JUST
CONTINUE TO ASK THAT WE CONTINUE
TO OPEN MORE, UM, RESOURCES FOR
PARTNERS AND ORGANIZATIONS AND
ENSURE THAT FUNDING THAT WE MAKE
A COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE TO FUND
THE REALIGNMENT BECAUSE IT'S
GOING TO TAKE DEEPER INVESTMENTS
. AND I KNOW THAT THE STATE IS
IN, UM IN IN SOME SORT OF, UH
UH, DEFICIT, BUT I'M HOPING THAT
WE JUST A LITTLE JUST A LITTLE,
BUT WE GOT ENOUGH SAVINGS, AND I
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
MAKE THIS STRONG INVESTMENT FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE AND MAKE SURE THAT
THE GOVERNOR AND THE THIS
LEGISLATOR CONTINUES TO DO THAT
FOR PARTNERS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
JASMINE BROOKE. GOOD MORNING
SUBCOMMITTEES. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK BEFORE YOU
TODAY. MY NAME IS BROOKE HARRIS.
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE PACIFIC JUVENILE DEFENDERS
CENTER, AN ORGANIZATION THAT
SUPPORTS AND TRAINS JUVENILE
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. WITH THE MEMBERSHIP
OF OVER 2000 LAWYERS, SOCIAL
WORKERS AND POLICY ADVOCATES ARE
ORGANIZATION PROVIDES CONSISTENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DEFENDERS FROM
COUNTIES ALL OVER THE STATE TO
DISCUSS PRESSING REALIGNMENT
RELATED ISSUES. DEFENDERS ARE
FIGHTING EVERY DAY IN COURT TO
FULFILL THE VISION OF S¼ B 820
THREE ARMED WITH CLEAR STATUTORY
LANGUAGE. THEY FIGHT TO ENSURE
THAT EVERY OTHER OPTION IS
EXHAUSTED BEFORE A CLIENT IS
COMMITTED TO AN S¼ Y Tð F. THEY
ADVOCATE FOR INDIVIDUAL
REHABILITATION PLANS THAT
PROVIDE THE PROGRAMMING AND
SUPPORT THAT EACH YOUTH IN AN S¼
Y Tð F NEEDS TO SUCCESSFULLY
TRANSITION BACK TO THE COMMUNITY
, AND THEY FIGHT AGAINST THE
TRANSFER OF YOUTH TO THE ADULT
COURT SYSTEM. A MANDATE OF S¼ B
A 23 I AM HERE TO SHARE WHAT
DEFENDERS SEE AS THE KEY
OBSTACLES AND POTENTIAL
LEGISLATIVE SOLUTIONS TO
FULFILLING THE VISION OF 20
THREE. THE PRIMARY KEY ISSUE IS
THAT CURRENTLY S¼ Y Tð F
FACILITIES ARE HARMING YOUNG
PEOPLE AND PROVIDING
INSUFFICIENT ACCESS TO THE
VARIETY OF SERVICES THAT CLIENTS
NEED TO CHANGE THEIR LIVES. AS A
THRESHOLD MATTERS. THESE SFS
SHOULD NOT BE IN JUVENILE HALLS.
THE LEGISLATURE ENVISIONED S¼ Y
Tð F AS HOME LIKE ENVIRONMENTS
CONDUCIVE TO REHABILITATION. YET
EVERY SINGLE PROBATION
DEPARTMENT THAT ELECTED TO
CREATE AN S¼ Y Tð F DID SO
INSIDE OF A JUVENILE HALL
BUILDINGS HISTORICALLY MEANT TO
HOLD YOUNG PEOPLE FOR A SHORT
AMOUNT OF TIME AND A MAXIMUM
SECURITY FACILITY. YOUTH AND SY
TFS ARE RELEGATED TO A SINGLE
MODULE OF A JUVENILE HALL
POTENTIALLY FOR YEARS AT A TIME
AND LACK THE FREEDOM OF MOVEMENT
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE HAD AT Dð JJ
AND THAT ALL YOUTH NEED AND
DESERVE. JUVENILE HALLS ARE THE
EXACT OPPOSITE OF HOME LIKE
ENVIRONMENTS CONTEMPLATED IN THE
REALIGNMENT STATUTE.
ADDITIONALLY DEFENDERS IN A
NUMBER OF COUNTIES HAVE REPORTED
THAT THERE'S OFTEN JUST ONE
COUNSELING SERVICES PROVIDER ONE
OR TWO VOCATIONAL EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES. AS MS PK WAS
DESCRIBING ONE COLLEGE COURSE,
UM OR DEGREE OFFERED, AND SO ON
SUCH THAT A USE INDIVIDUAL
REHABILITATION PLAN BECOMES ROTE
AND DEPENDENT ON WHAT THAT
PROBATION DEPARTMENT MIGHT OFFER
VERSUS THE INDIVIDUAL
THERAPEUTIC NEEDS THAT A YOUNG
PERSON MIGHT HAVE RENDERING THE
IRP ANYTHING BUT INDIVIDUAL.
SOME YOUTH ARE BEING OFFERED THE
EXACT SAME PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
THAT THEY WERE DOING IN THE
JUVENILE HALL PRIOR TO THEIR
COMMITMENT TO THE S¼ Y Tð. THE
SOLUTION IS TO INCREASE THE
PROGRAMMING PROVIDED BY CBOS AND
S¼ Y Tð F PROGRAMS AS MY
COLLEAGUE JASMINE SO,
ARTICULATELY SAID. BETTER S¼ Y
Tð F S¼ COULD ALSO HELP REDUCE
TRANSFERS TO ADULT COURT
DEFENDERS ON THE GROUND ARE
SEEING AN INCREASE IN MOTIONS TO
TRANSFER YOUTH TO ADULT COURT.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY CONCERNING
GIVEN THIS LEGISLATURE'S PASSING
OF A NUMBER OF LAWS THAT
RESTRICT WHO IS ELIGIBLE FOR
TRANSFER AND THAT RAISE THE
BURDEN OF PROOF AT A TRANSFER
HEARING. A SECOND KEY ISSUE
RAISED BY DEFENDERS THAT WE'VE
ALL TALKED ABOUT TODAY IS THE
NEED FOR MORE OPTIONS FOR LESS
RESTRICTIVE PROGRAMS, BOTH AT
THE TIME OF INITIAL DISPOSITION
WHEN SOMEONE IS GOING TO S¼ Y Tð
F AND WHEN A YOUNG PERSON IS
READY TO LEAVE A SECURE TRACK
PROGRAM TF IS MEANT TO BE A LAST
RESORT. YET TOO OFTEN, IT IS THE
FIRST AND ONLY RESORT. DEFENDERS
IN SOME COUNTIES ARE DESCRIBING
NET WIDENING WHERE THERE ARE
MORE YOUTH BEING COMMITTED TO
SWFS THAN WERE PREVIOUSLY
COMMITTED TO Dð JJ. THIS IS NOT
ACROSS THE BOARD, BUT THIS IS
HAPPENING IN SOME COUNTIES. THE
FOCUS ON IN CUSTODY. S¼ Y Tð F
FACILITIES MEANS THAT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF LESS RESTRICTIVE
PROGRAMS HAS BEEN DE EMPHASIZED
AND IGNORED. DEFENDERS FROM SOME
COUNTIES REPORT THAT THE ONLY
AVAILABLE LRP IS PINE GROVE, A
èC Dð èC R RUN FACILITY OR
THAT PROBATION DEPARTMENTS ARE
WORKING ON CREATING THEIR OWN
LRP, S¼ AND CAMP OR RANCH
SETTINGS OR OTHER ON ON SITE,
PROBATION RUN FACILITIES. WE
NEED TO DEVELOP LESS RESTRICTIVE
PROGRAMS. SO THAT COURTS HAVE
VIABLE SAFE ALTERNATIVES TO S¼ Y
Tð F. WE CAN DO THIS BY
INVESTING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE,
CAPACITY BUILDING AND FUNDING TO
COMMUNITY-BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT CAN SERVE YOUNG PEOPLE
INSIDE AND OUTSIDE OF S¼ Y Tð F
FACILITIES FOR REAL HEALING TO
HAPPEN. YOUTH NEED CONNECTIONS
TO COMMUNITY. THIS CANNOT BE
DONE FROM A CELL IN A JUVENILE
HALL. TO FULLY IDENTIFY THE
PROBLEMS OF NET WIDENING AND
INCREASE IN TRANSFER AND RACIAL
AND ETHNIC DISPARITIES IN OUR
SYSTEM, WE AS ADVOCATES AND YOU
AS LEGISLATORS DESPERATELY NEED
MORE DATA. THERE ARE SOME
STATEWIDE DATA PROVIDED TO Ó. I
èC R PER S¼ B 102, BUT WE NEED
MORE TO FULLY UNDERSTAND
PROBLEMS AND IDENTIFY SOLUTIONS.
WE NEED DATA BROKEN DOWN BY
COUNTY. DESPITE THESE CHALLENGES
, DEFENDERS BELIEVE ABSOLUTELY
THAT WE CAN MAKE CALIFORNIA'S
EXTRAORDINARY VISION OF A HEALTH
BASED APPROACH TO YOUTH JUSTICE.
A REALITY DEFENDERS ARE IN COURT
EVERY DAY FULLY ENGAGED IN THE
MISSION OF REALIGNMENT. WE MUST
DO OUR PART TO CONTINUE THE
IMPLEMENTATION PROCESS UNTIL WE
HAVE ACHIEVED OUR SHARED GOALS.
NOT ONLY IS IT POSSIBLE TO GET
THIS RIGHT, BUT IT'S IMPERATIVE.
IT'S IMPERATIVE FOR THE YOUTH
AND S¼ Y Tð F. IT'S IMPERATIVE
FOR THE SAFETY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND FOR ALL OF US,
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS ISSUE, AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY SEND SENATOR
MENJIVAR IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. WE
NEED LOVE, AND WE ALSO NEED
DOLLARS TO ALIGN TO THE PURPOSE
OF REALIGNMENT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, BROOKE. ALL RIGHT,
WE'RE GONNA I'M GONNA KICK OFF
TWO QUESTIONS AND THEN SEND IT
TO MY COLLEAGUES, MY LEFT AND
RIGHT AND WE'RE JUST CONTINUE
THAT WAY. OK I'M GONNA START
JUST A CLA CLARIFYING QUESTION.
UM ORLANDO ON PAGE SIX. YOU
SPOKE ABOUT THE $400 MILLION
ALLOCATION FOR RENOVATIONS. JUST
I THINK FOR MY UNDERSTANDING, I
WAS ONE VARIOUS ALLOCATIONS OF
ONE TIME FUNDING ARE ALL A LUMP
SUM OF ONE TIME FUNDING FOR $410
. I MEAN, $410 MILLION IN TW
2007. YEAH, IT WAS VERY
ALLOCATIONS THAT SUM UP TO 400.
WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME THAT WE
THIS WAS IN THE 2220 THREE. A
PSYCHO. IT WAS 100,000,110 THAT
WAS PROVIDED FOR THAT PURPOSE.
THE 2220 THREE BUDGET. PERFECT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. UM UH.
DIRECTOR LUCERO, II. I HAVE SOME
SOME QUESTIONS YOUR WAY. WHICH
TRYING TO START OFF WITH, UM YOU
KNOW YOU YOU GAVE SOME. YOU KNOW
SOME INFORMATION REGARDING SOME
OF THE Tð A THAT YOU PROVIDED
COUNTIES AND SO FORTH AND I'LL
START OFF WITH WHAT? UM UH,
BROOKE MENTIONED REGARDING THE
Tð A NEEDED FOR èC B Ó TO HAVE
MORE OPTIONS FOR LESS RESTRICTED
. DO HAVE WE PROVIDED ANY Tð A
TO èC B S¼ TO CREATE MORE
OPTIONS LIKE THAT ACROSS THE
STATE. A UM, A WORK GROUP THAT
IS SPECIFICALLY A èC B Ó
CAPACITY BUILDING WORK GROUP
MADE UP OF A VARIETY OF PARTNERS
THAT MEETS MONTHLY AND IS PART
OF OUR YOUTH JUSTICE COMMITTEE
FROM THE CHILD WELFARE COUNCIL,
AND THAT WORK GROUP SPECIFICALLY
IS RUN BY ALSO PARTNERING WITH
SIERRA HEALTH, THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW AND PUBLIC
WORKS ALLIANCE. THEY ARE, UH,
PROVIDING A STRATEGY FOR JUST
THAT, SENATOR. UM WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE èC B Ó S¼ HAVE
BUILT INFRASTRUCTURE AND
SUSTAINABLE INCOME AND HAVE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH PROBATION THAT
CAN BE DEVELOPED AS TRUSTWORTHY
PARTNERSHIPS FOR BUILDING A
CONTINUUM OF CARE, BOTH
DIVERSIONARY CONTINUUM OF CARE
IN CUSTODY, CONTINUUM OF CARE
AND POST RELEASE CONTINUUM OF
CARE. SO WE ARE THAT IS ONE OF
THE THREE PRIMARY TOPICS AND
GOALS OF Ó Y èC R, AND THAT IS
WHAT WE ARE DOING, AND THAT'S
WHERE WE FUNDED THAT INITIATIVE
AT $14 MILLION. SINCE UM THE
OFFICES Ó Y èC R S¼ INCEPTION.
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU STATED SOME
OF THE JURISDICTIONS UNDER YOUR
YOUR OFFICE, HAVE WE PROVIDED
ANY ACTUAL POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR IMPROVED
OUTCOMES AND IDENTIFIED IT BEST
PRACTICES. FOR THE COUNTY
JUVENILE HALLS. WHEN WE GO ON
SITE VISITS AND WE ARE VERY MUCH
WELCOMED BY THE COUNTY
LEADERSHIP. WE DO HAVE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT BEST POLICIES
AND BEST PRACTICES. AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE. 58 COUNTIES HAVE 58
DIFFERENT WAYS OF DOING THINGS
THAT ARE VERY PARTICULAR AND
UNIQUE. WE COME WITH A USUALLY A
GROUP OF FOLKS WHO HAVE
DIFFERENT EXPERTISE, AND SO WE
ARE ABLE TO SUGGEST POLICY
CHANGES. WE ARE ABLE TO SUGGEST
PROGRAMS AND WITH FOLLOW UP
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. WE'RE ABLE
TO DELIVER MODELS CONTACTS. UM
SO IN THAT WAY, WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO SUGGEST VERY
INDIVIDUALIZED, UH, ASSISTANCE
TO COUNTIES WHEN WE'RE ON SITE
ANY OVERARCHING STATEWIDE? I
BELIEVE THERE'S 4300 AND 58
COUNTIES HAVE THE JUVENILE
HALLS. IF I 43 I BELIEVE, UM,
ANY OVERARCHING POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THOSE 43 SO
MY COLLEAGUE TO MY LEFT IS
SAYING 41. 41 AND, UM. I MEAN, I
THINK A HUGE UM. ASSISTANCE
WOULD BE DEVELOPING, YOU KNOW,
WORKING ON CULTURE? ON ON WHAT?
YOU KNOW. WHAT IS THE CULTURE?
UH, ONE OF THE ONE WE SAW A
REALLY GREAT EXAMPLE OF, UM, A
FACILITY THAT ACTUALLY DOES A
SURVEY A MONTHLY SURVEY AND
TAKES THE TEMPERATURE OF THE
CULTURE WITHIN WITHIN THE
FACILITY FROM STAFF AND FROM THE
YOUTH, AND IN THAT WAY THEY ARE
ABLE TO REALLY SERVE THE YOUTH
WELL, AND STAFF FEEL SAFE AND
YOU FEEL SAFE, SO THAT'S A
DIRECT KIND OF TAKING THE
TEMPERATURE OF THE CULTURE. I
THINK THAT WE DO NEED TO, UM,
LEAD AND BE BEHAVIOR. BEHAVIORAL
MANAGEMENT TYPES OF PROGRAMS,
INCENTIVES. WE NEED TO HELP THE
YOU FEEL LIKE THEY'RE WORKING ON
THEMSELVES WHEN THEY'RE IN THE
FACILITIES AND WORKING ON
POSSIBLY GETTING TIME OFF AT THE
SIX MONTH HEARING, SO I THINK
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO PARTNER
WITH CPAC ON AND WE ARE IN A AAA
WE MEET BIWEEKLY OR THE OTHER 22
TIMES A MONTH AND WE ARE WORKING
ON SOME VERY SPECIFIC TRAINING
FOR, UH, PROBATION OFFICERS.
THANK YOU. COLLEAGUES. YES, I
HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. UM UH. DIRECTOR LUCERO,
CAN YOU DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
YOU'RE GETTING, UM THE KIND OF
INFORMATION AT THE COUNTY LEVEL?
UM AND THE INDIVIDUAL LEVEL? UH,
THAT YOU NEED. AND IF NOT, WHAT
IS THE KIND OF INFORMATION THAT
YOU WOULD NEED? WELL I THINK
DURING THIS TRANSITION PERIOD
WERE STARTING TO IDENTIFY WHAT
WE NEED AND WE'RE STARTING TO
IDENTIFY GAPS. UM I THINK
IDEALLY, IT WOULD HAVE A
SIMILARITY TO HOW WE ARE ABLE
TO, UM, TRACK AND UNDERSTAND OUR
FOSTER CARE POPULATION. UM I. I
THINK THAT WOULD BE THE BEST
CASE SCENARIO. UM BUT THAT SO
THAT'S NOT THE FAULT OF THE
COUNTIES. THAT'S NOT, YOU KNOW,
THAT'S NOT ANYONE'S FAULT. I
JUST THINK THAT THIS IS A NEW
AND DIFFERENT WAY TO SERVE OUR
YOUTH AND TO HAVE WHAT WE NEED
TO DO. THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS
IN DEVELOPMENT. OK? UM. AND
THERE WAS MENTION OF, I THINK
NOT EXACTLY SURE WHO SAID THIS
BUT OF COMMUNICATION BETWEEN, UH
THE COUNTIES AND I'M SHARING.
INFORMATION OR SHARING PROGRAMS
WITH SOMEONE. SOMEONE SAID THAT
IF SOMEONE COULD WELL ADDRESS
THAT, UM YOU KNOW HOW FAR ARE
YOU GOING AND GETTING AND
SHARING THE KIND OF INFORMATION
OR COOPER OPERATION BETWEEN THE
COUNTIES. DO YOU WANNA TAKE THAT
OR I'M NOT SURE. OK SO I WHAT?
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS WE, UH YOU
KNOW INFORMATION IS KING.
HELPING COUNTIES KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN OTHER COUNTIES IS
GOLD. JUDGES WANT TO KNOW?
PROBATION CHIEFS WANT TO KNOW
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FOLKS WANNA
KNOW BECAUSE THIS IS HOW WE
LEARN RIGHT? SO WE'RE TRYING TO
DEVELOP COMMUNITIES OF LEARNING
WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS. WE HAVE
STATE WE HAVE A STAKEHOLDER
INITIATIVE WITH, UH, WITH BROOKS
ORGANIZATION WITH THE
PROSECUTORS ALLIANCE AND WITH
THE L A COUNTY PROBATION EXCUSE
ME. PUBLIC DEFENDERS AND Dð, A
BECAUSE WE WANT A COLLABORATIVE
JUSTICE. WE WANT THIS TO REFLECT
. WHAT DOES COLLABORATIVE
JUSTICE LOOK LIKE? UM WHEN IT SO
IT'S AFTER YOUTH HAS BEEN, YOU
KNOW, PUT IN AN S¼ Y Tð F. WHAT
IS A SIX MONTH REVIEW HEARING
LOOK LIKE SO? SO WE'RE WE WANNA
SPREAD L A IS ACTUALLY DOING A
REALLY GOOD JOB AT THAT. AND I
KNOW YOU'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
JUDGE ESPINOZA IN A LITTLE BIT,
BUT THEY'VE ACTUALLY BUY BUY
ORGANICALLY HAVE DEVELOPED WHAT
I WOULD CONSIDER TO BE A
COLLABORATIVE COURT WHERE THE
STAKEHOLDERS MEET ON THE OF EACH
OF THE YOUTH BEFORE THE HEARING,
AND THEY MAKE THEY THEY TALK
ABOUT THE YOUTH. AND THEN THE
JUDGE CHIMES IN, AND EVERYBODY
GETS TO HAVE SOME SORT OF
AGREEMENT ABOUT HOW THE YOUTH
WILL PROGRESS AND WHAT KIND OF
TIME WILL BE TAKEN OFF THE USE.
SO INFORMATION SHARING IS KING.
SO WE ARE CATALOGING THE LESS
RESTRICTIVE PROGRAMS ACROSS THE
STATE. WE ARE CATALOGING WHO'S
LETTING KIDS GO TO COLLEGE FROM
THE S¼ TF WERE CATALOGING CBOS
AND, UH, NOT ONLY DEVELOPING
CAPACITY, BUT WE'RE IDENTIFYING
WHERE THEY ARE AND WHERE WE, UH,
WE HAVE A PLAN TO ACTUALLY GO
INTO COUNTIES THAT DON'T HAVE
èC B S¼ AND HELP DEVELOP AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT REGIONAL èC B
Ó AGREEMENTS. SO INFORMATION IS
THE KEY AND SHARING IT IS
PARAMOUNT. AND THAT IS. WHAT. UM
. UH, JASMINE. IF YOU. UM I WERE
YOU THE ONE WHO, UM, MENTIONED
ABOUT THE EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES WERE. ARE MORE
RESTRICTIVE THAN WHAT THEY
SHOULD BE ONLY ELECTIVES. UM
VERY LIMITED. SO COULD YOU
DESCRIBE THAT A LITTLE BIT MORE?
AND WHAT DO YOU THINK IS THE
QUICKEST WAY TO ADDRESS THAT?
YES, I THINK THAT SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE HEARING
DIRECTLY FROM YOUNG PEOPLE IS
JUST, UM IT'S JUST THE LACK OF
LIKE CAREER PLANNING WITH THEM.
YOU KNOW THEM UNDERSTANDING SOME
OF THE RESOURCES PATHWAYS THAT
THEY CAN CONSIDER AND TAKE. AND
OFTENTIMES SOME OF THE SCHOOLS
THAT ARE THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THAT THEY'RE PARTNERING WITH ARE
LIMITING THEM TO THE THOSE
ELECTIVES, SO IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY JUST THE FACILITIES
WITHIN ITSELF AS THE INSTITUTION
. UM I THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE
ONGOING COLLABORATION WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES OF CALIFORNIA
TO ENSURE THAT THERE ARE DIRECT
PARTNERSHIPS AND COMMUNICATIONS
AROUND, UM, PATHWAY PLANS FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE, AND I THINK THAT
THAT COULD STREAMLINE VERY
QUICKLY. UM I THINK THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO WE KNOW ARE GOING TO
BE THERE BE THERE WITH WHEN THEY
HAVE MINIMUM TIMES OF THREE
YEARS TO SEVEN YEARS. THOSE ARE
THE YOUTH THAT WE NEED TO
DIRECTLY TARGET AND THEN WE NEED
TO GET PLANS DIRECTLY RIGHT
AWAY. ONE THING THAT I'VE
NOTICED WHEN WORKING WITH SOME
OF THESE YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE
FACILITIES IS THAT WHEN THEY GET
INSIDE FACILITIES, THERE'S NÓ
DIRECT. UM, LET'S LET'S SIT DOWN
AND LET'S TALK ABOUT YOUR THREE
YEAR, SEVEN YEAR PLAN IN THESE
FACILITIES. LET'S TALK ABOUT NOT
JUST SIX MONTHS, BUT THEIR LAX.
AGAIN AROUND A YOUNG PERSON
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THEIR ROLE
WHAT THEY'RE DOING IN THESE
FACILITIES AND HOW THEY'RE
REALLY AIMING TOWARDS HEALING
AND THRIVING BEYOND THESE
FACILITIES, AND SO IN MANY CASES
, IT'S NOT WORKING BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE PLAN PLANS OUT
IMMEDIATELY WHEN A YOUNG PERSON
GETS COMMITTED, SO THEY HAVE
THESE OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE PUT
BEFORE THEM AND THEY'RE TOLD.
HEY HERE ARE SOME COURSES YOU
CAN TAKE. HERE ARE SOME PROGRAMS
AND MANY TIMES SOME OF THOSE
COURSES OR PROGRAMS ARE NOT EVEN
EXISTED BECAUSE THEY MAY BE
NAMED AND THEY MAY OFFER THEM.
THEY HAVE MONEY TOWARDS THEM,
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE A SERVICE
PROVIDER TO DO THAT PROGRAM AND
OFTEN TIMES. WHAT THE ISSUE IS,
IS THAT THAT YOUNG PEOPLE GET
STAGNANT AND WHERE, AND THEN
THEY HAVE FRUSTRATION. UM IN THE
IN THE PLACE AND TIME THAT
THEY'RE AT, AND THEN THEY'RE
CONSIDERED AND THEN THEY'RE
LOOKED AT, LIKE THEY'RE NOT
DOING ANYTHING BUT WE HAVE
FAILED TO PLAN WITH THEM THEIR
PLAN AND STRATEGY. AND SO I
THINK WE JUST NEED TO WORK
TOWARDS, UM AMENDING EITHER
CONTRACTS OR PLANNINGS WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES OF CALIFORNIA
AS WELL AS, UH, UH, EDUCATION.
UM, PARTNERS WHO, ACTUALLY, YOU
KNOW, ARE TRAINED AND ARE ABLE
TO HELP YOUNG PEOPLE STILL TO
FACILITATE A CAREER PLAN. UM,
WHETHER THAT BE VOCATIONAL OR
WHETHER THAT BE THROUGH. UM UM,
GETTING AN A BY THE END OF THEIR
TIME. OK THANK YOU, I. I JUST
WANT TO GO BACK TO THE, UH, DATA
. SHANE DOCTOR, UH, SHARING
DOCTOR LUCERO, DIRECTOR, LUCERO
SAID, UM, INFORMATION IS KEY.
SO, UM UM MP. COULD YOU ADDRESS
THAT ABOUT THE DATA SHARING? AH,
WELL, UM, ABSOLUTELY, AND WE
WOULD AGREE WITH WITH ACTUALLY,
BOTH OF THE POINTS THAT WERE
JUST MADE, UM THERE ARE
LIMITATIONS. SPEAKING OF THE
EDUCATIONAL PIECE, UM JUST NOW,
I MEAN, THERE THERE IS, UH, I
THINK THOSE LIMITS WHEN YOU
DECENTRALIZE A VERY SMALL
PROGRAM, RIGHT WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT GOING FROM ONE PLACE WHERE
IT WOULD WOULD JUST FRANKLY BE
EASIER TO DELIVER ALL OF THE
SERVICES AT Dð JJ AND NOW TRYING
TO FILTER THAT OUT TO ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT SO SOME OF IT IS
PROBABLY DUE TO THAT THE OTHER
PART IS, YOU KNOW YOU CAN'T LOOK
AT IT IN JUST A VACUUM, WHICH IS
ANOTHER REASON WHY INFORMATION
AND DATA SHARING IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST THE
EDUCATIONAL PIECE THAT WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MAKING SURE
HAPPENS, UM AND THE PLANNING
NEEDS TO TAKE PLACE AT THE
BEGINNING. WE WOULD. WE WOULD
DEFINITELY AGREE, AND WE THINK
THAT THAT IS HAPPENING IN A LOT
OF PLACES, AND SO IT IS IN LIGHT
OF TRYING TO, UH DECONFLICT. LOT
OF THE DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS
THAT WE NEED TO BE SURE THE
YOUTH IS GETTING, UM AT THE SAME
TIME, SO YOU KNOW, IT'S A IT'S A
IT'S BOTH THE ECONOMIES OF SCALE
. IT'S BOTH THE, UM YOU KNOW,
STILL NEW IN THE PROGRAMMING
GETTING THAT SET UP AND ALSO
TRYING TO BE SURE THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT EDUCATIONAL AS WELL
AS VOCATIONAL NEEDS, AS WELL AS
OTHER REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS.
UM THAT WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR AND
KNOWING THAT THERE'S ONLY A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME IN THE
DAY SO OF THOSE THINGS WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK ON AND
LEARNING FROM OUR PARTNERS AND
HOW PEOPLE ARE KIND OF BREAKING
SOME OF THOSE CODES IS ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT ACTUALLY CPAC,
UH, TRIES TO, UM DEVELOP, UH,
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS AMONGST OUR
MEMBERSHIP, AND I'M SORRY JUST
TO GO BACK TO THE INFORMATION.
UH, SHARING IS THERE AWAY. I
MEAN, WHAT ARE THE WAYS IN WHICH
YOU CAN DO MORE OF THAT, BECAUSE
, UH, AS DIRECTOR, LUCERO SAID,
WE NEED MORE OF THAT INFORMATION
IS KEY. SO HOW CAN YOU
FACILITATE THAT TO GET THE
INFORMATION THAT'S NEEDED AND WE
WORKED WITH A REALLY CLOSELY
WITH TRYING TO GET THE MOST
RECENT DATA. UH, REQUEST, UM,
DELIVERED, UH TO, UH, BOTH, UH,
DIRECTOR LUCERO AND Ó. I èC R,
WHICH I BELIEVE IS CITED IN SOME
OF THE PACKET OF INFORMATION SO
IN IN SOME OF IT, I WOULD ALSO
AGREE THAT AS WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING, WE ARE LEARNING
EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED. WE ARE
LEARNING EXACTLY WHICH SYSTEMS
ARE THE BEST SYSTEMS TO PULL
SOME OF THAT INFORMATION. WHILE
WE ALSO PARTICIPATE IN THE
FOSTER CARE DATA, AS WAS WAS
NOTED, AND YOU AGREE THAT
THERE'S SOME RICHNESS TO THAT.
IT'S ALSO A SYSTEM THAT'S SET UP
ENTIRELY DIFFERENTLY, RIGHT.
IT'S A FEDERAL MANDATE. THERE'S
FEDERAL WAYS IN WHICH TO PULL
THAT THEIR SYSTEMS THAT HAVE
LONG BEEN BUILT TO SUPPORT THAT.
AND SO I THINK, UM, YOU KNOW, WE
KNOW THAT THE DATA SYSTEM AT Dð
Ó J IS BEING TALKED ABOUT, UH,
PUT TOGETHER TO TRY TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THOSE THINGS WE WANNA BE
ABLE TO HAVE. ONE REPOSITORY IN
WHICH TO DO THAT, SO I THINK
WE'RE OPEN TO ALL OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS FOR WHATEVER REASON,
YOU KNOW, PROBABLY BECAUSE OF
TECHNOLOGY AT TIMES, AND YOU'RE
DEALING WITH 58 DIFFERENT
COUNTIES. UM, THAT CAN BE A
BARRIER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW, I WANT BEFORE I TURN
ON. SORRY SENATOR JUST BECAUSE
ON THIS TOPIC ON THE EDUCATION,
UM YOU KNOW YOU SPOKE KAREN
ABOUT YOU KNOW, SOME CULINARY
ART, RIGHT? YOU KNOW, I VISITED
CAMP Kò P, WHERE ONE OF THE
STATE OF THE ART KITCHEN. BUT NÓ
COURSES ARE BEING GIVEN BECAUSE
OF THE COLLEGE ISSUES, YOU KNOW
AND DIRECT, YOU KNOW, HOW CAN WE
CONNECT WITH THE COLLEGES
BECAUSE, FOR EXAMPLE, IN THAT
CASE, MISSION COLLEGE WHERE FOR
A LOT OF CASES, THEY NEED A
MINIMUM OF 15 STUDENTS TO GIVE
THE COURSE RIGHT. CAM Kò P ONLY
HAS 17. SO THAT WOULD BE THE
ENTIRE SO HOW ARE WE WORKING
WITH Tð A. TO GET THESE COURSES
WE HAVE. THEY ALSO HAVE A, UH, A
WOOD SHOP THAT ISN'T GIVING OUT
ANY COURSES. SO WE HAVE BUILT
THESE ENTITIES. WE BUILT THESE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND IT'S KIND OF
LIKE A TEASE FOR THESE YOUTH.
THEY PASS BY EACH TIME AND THEY
CAN'T UTILIZE. SO WHAT Tð A ARE
WE THINKING ABOUT IN BECAUSE YOU
SAID YOU'RE WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT? YOU WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ON HOW
CAN WE MAKE THESE CLASSES COME
BACK TO LIFE? SO RISING SCHOLARS
IS VERY MUCH IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
L A COUNTY. I THINK MAYBE FOUR
OR FIVE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ACTUALLY WERE AWARDED. UM THERE,
THERE'S UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S
MANY LAYERS. TO GETTING. TO THE
POINT THAT YOU'RE DESCRIBING
SENATOR. IT'S NOT JUST GETTING
RISING SCHOLARS IN THERE, BUT
IT'S ALSO MAKING SURE THAT
PROBATION IS COOPERATING WITH
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
THAT THEY'RE IN THAT IN THAT
ENVIRONMENT THAT WAY IS BEING
MADE BY THE MANY STAKEHOLDERS
THAT NEED TO MAKE A WAY. SO IN
IN, YOU KNOW, EVEN JUST BE JUST
BECAUSE, UM, THE PARTNERSHIP IS
THERE DOES NOT MEAN THAT IT'S UM
IMPLEMENTED WHAT WE'RE DOING TO
PROVIDE. WE HAVE DR MICHAEL
MASSA ON IN L A. HE WAS THE
FORMER PRINCIPAL OF THE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDU EDUCATION AT THE
COURT SCHOOLS. WE HAVE AN
EDUCATION ADVISORY BOARD THAT
MEETS MONTHLY WITH KEY
STAKEHOLDERS FROM ALL OVER, UH,
THE EDUCATION FIELD. UH, I
MYSELF HAVE HAVE MET WITH THE
SUPERINTENDENT COE. THE UH, IN L
A COUNTY. I THINK HER FIRST NAME
IS MARIBEL. BUT I CANNOT
REMEMBER HER LAST NAME. WE HAVE
GONE IN AND TRIED TO UN LAYER.
WHAT IS? WHY AREN'T YOU KNOW WHY
ISN'T THE CULINARY CLASS IN
THERE? WHY ISN'T THE WOODSHOP
CLASS IN THERE? BUT IT'S UM WE
CAN ONLY DO WHAT WE'RE DOING,
WHICH IS INQUIRE WHICH IS HELP
THE ENTITIES START TO UN LAYER
AND UNPACK TO LOOK TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY GATEKEEPING ANYWHERE
TO LOOK TO SEE IF THERE'S A LACK
OF DOLLAR SOMEWHERE TO LOOK TO
SEE IF MAYBE THERE NEEDS TO BE
SUPPORT FROM THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, BUT IT IT IS, AS
YOU KNOW, SENATOR A VERY
COMPLICATED AND LAYERED
POLITICAL SYSTEM, SO WE BUT WE
ARE THERE, I. I SPEND AT LEAST 2
TO 3 DAYS A MONTH IN LOS ANGELES
, ATTENDING VARIOUS PUBLIC
MEETINGS, MEETING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS MEETING WITH, UM Dð
S¼ P Dð S¼ JUDGES. SO UM, I HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO VISIT SOME OF THE
FACILITIES. I WAS JUST AT
DOROTHY KIRBY LAST WEEK. UM SO
THAT'S THOSE ARE SOME OF THE, UM
Tð A WAYS THAT WE'RE IN L, A IN
A ROOM. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
I'M JUST CURIOUS, MS HARRIS.
WHAT UH, WHAT'S DRIVING THE
INCREASE IN ADULT CHARGING OF
YOUTH IN IN CUSTODY AND. ARE
THERE EFFORTS? I MEAN, GIVEN
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE IN THE IN
THE SYSTEM. ARE THERE EFFORTS
BEING MADE TO RETAIN THESE YOUTH
IN THE JUVENILE SYSTEM? AND IF
NOT, WHY NOT? WELL THERE ARE
CERTAINLY EFFORTS ON BEHALF OF
DEFENDERS WHO RECEIVE THESE
CASES WHO FIGHT? INCREDIBLY, UM
HARD TO KEEP YOUTH IN THE
JUVENILE COURT SYSTEM. UM.
FRANKLY THIS THE INCREASE IN
FILING OF TRANSFER PETITIONS MAY
BE USED AS A NEGOTIATION TACTIC.
UM, YOU KNOW, TO GET A
COMMITMENT TO AN S¼ Tð F, UM FOR
A YOUTH, UM WE DON'T KNOW. I
MEAN, WE DON'T KNOW THE TRUTH IS
, WE DON'T KNOW WE DON'T HAVE
THE DATA. WE DON'T HAVE, UM YOU
KNOW, THERE ISN'T CURRENTLY, UM,
THERE'S AGAIN THERE'S THE
STATEWIDE DATA. WE HAVE IT IN
OUR AGENDA. BUT IT'S NOT. IT'S
NOT TELLING US THE COMPLETE
PICTURE OF WHAT'S GOING ON IN
EACH COUNTY. WE REALLY, REALLY
NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT. WE NEED
TO KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING IN EACH
COUNTY. UM, SO HOW DO WE GET
THAT? WELL I THINK THAT THROUGH
THROUGH THE COUNTIES, UM
COUNTIES SHOULD BE ABLE TO TELL
YOU OR I HOW MANY TRANSFER
PETITIONS ARE FILED IN A GIVEN
YEAR? IS IT POSSIBLE THAT THE
CONDITION IN SOME OF THESE
FACILITIES, UM CREATES AN
ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH SITUATIONS
OCCUR, WHICH LEAD TO THE ATTEMPT
TO INCREASE CHARGES AND CHARGE
USE. AS ADULTS. CRIMINAL
PROCEEDINGS. ABSOLUTELY. I MEAN,
THERE'S TWO THERE'S AND THAT
THAT'S SORT OF A. COULD BE A
SIMILAR BUT RELATED ISSUE THAT
WE ARE SEEING THE FILING OF
ADULT CHARGES ON YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO ARE OVER 18 IN S¼ Y Tð F,
BUT UNDER MAYBE 20 THREE, BUT
UNDER 23 THAT'S DIFFERENT THAN
TRANSFER RIGHT. A TRANSFER
PETITION IS FOR A YOUNG PERSON
WHO COMMITS A CRIME BEFORE
THEY'RE 18, AND THEY'RE
PETITIONING TO TRANSFER THEM TO
THE ADULT COURT SYSTEM. SO I
THINK THAT, UM THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY A CONCERN. UM, WE'RE
SEEING IT IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR A LOT MORE
ABOUT THAT TODAY, SO I'M NOT
GOING TO TAKE UP YOUR TIME WITH
IT. BUT WE ARE SEEING YOU KNOW,
THE FILING OF ADULT PETITIONS
FOR YOUTH IN S¼, Y, Tð, F AND
OTHER JUVENILE FACILITIES. UM,
IT'S VERY CONCERNING AND I THINK
THAT A NUMBER OF DEFENDERS IN
COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THIS IS GOING TO
START HAPPENING, UM, IN THEIR
COUNTIES AS WELL. WE WANT TO
PREVENT THAT. WE WANT YOUTH TO
BE ABLE TO STAY IN S¼ Y Tð S¼
WHO ARE COMMITTED TO S¼ Y Tð F
S¼, UM AND WE WANT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT SOME OF THESE BEHAVIORS
ARE, IN FACT, A RESULT OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE FACILITIES.
RIGHT UH, BOREDOM. I REMEMBER.
I'M NOT EXCUSING THEM. BUT I'M
SAYING THAT THERE'S BOREDOM.
THERE'S A LACK OF PROGRAMMING.
THERE'S A LACK OF EDUCATION.
THERE'S A LACK OF, YOU KNOW, UM,
A AND YOU'RE LOOKING AT A
MULTIYEAR, POTENTIALLY
COMMITMENT. UM LOTS OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE LIVING CONDITIONS, NOT
MUCH TO DO. LEADS TO PROBLEMS OF
UNDERCUTS THE REASON WHY WE HAVE
A JUVENILE PROGRAM. IF ALL WE'RE
GOING TO DO IS CHARGE THEM AND
TREAT THEM AS ADULTS IN THE
ADULT CRIMINAL SYSTEM, RIGHT?
THE PROSECUTORS ARE MAKING THESE
DECISIONS. PROSECUTORS YES,
PROBATION FOR UM. TRANSFER
PETITIONS. THOSE ARE TYPICALLY
WE'RE SEEING THOSE THOSE ARE
CRIMES THAT HAPPEN IN THE
COMMUNITY AND POLICE ARE
CONDUCTING AN INVESTIGATION,
ARRESTING YOUNG PEOPLE AND
PROVIDING THAT INFORMATION TO
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICES
FOR IN CUSTODY CONDUCT. WE'RE
SEEING THAT PROBATION IS MAKING
REFERRALS TO THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICES. UM AND THEY
THEY ARE CHARGING OR NOT, UM,
BASED UPON THE INFORMATION
THEY'RE RECEIVING FROM PROBATION
. I WON'T PROLONG IT. IT SOUNDS
LIKE WE'RE GONNA HAVE MORE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS TODAY
AND PROBABLY IN THE FUTURE,
THEN. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. UM
. QUESTION. MS. PENK, UM. A Ó,
UM, MENTIONED SOME OF THE
NUMBERS. UH, COMPARED TO PRE
ALIGNMENT AND POST ALIGNMENT
POST ALIGNMENT. WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY 880 USE LOWER THAN
PRE ALIGNMENT. BUT I KNOW
STAFFING HAS BEEN AN ISSUE. UM
CAN YOU SHARE IS THAT A NEW
ISSUE WITH STAFFING AN ISSUE PRE
ALIGNMENT? BECAUSE IF WE HAVE
LOWER YOUTH NOW, RIGHT, WE
SHOULD HAVE A BETTER RATIO. SO
UM, IT WAS AN ISSUE THAT WAS
STARTING BEFORE REALIGNMENT.
CERTAINLY UH, WE WOULD. WE'RE
SEEING IT POTENTIALLY
EXACERBATED BECAUSE OF EITHER
AFFECTING RETENTION AND OR BEING
ABLE TO ATTRACT PEOPLE TO THE
PROFESSION. UM BUT IT IS, UM,
EVEN WITH A LOWER NUMBER
POPULATION AND YES, ABSOLUTELY.
WITH THE RATIOS. IT COULD IMPACT
IT. BUT REMEMBER, WE HAVE, UM, A
HIGHER LEVEL NEED AND IN SOME
SITUATIONS, A SAFETY CONCERNS.
SO YOU YOU KNOW, WE'RE ALL WE
WERE ALREADY SUFFERING FROM
STAFFING SHORTAGES ACROSS THE
BOARD, AND IT'S JUST HARD TO
REALLY PROMOTE THIS KIND OF WORK
RIGHT NOW. UM UH, WE'RE AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL ACROSS THE BOARD IN
A LOT OF DIFFERENT AREAS, SEEING
THOSE STAFFING SHORTAGE. SO UM
SO NÓ THEY WE'VE BEEN SEEING IT
BEFORE. REALIGNMENT UM, WE ARE
SEEING IT, UH, CONTINUE THROUGH
IT, AND WE'RE LOOKING AT VARIOUS
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES TO TRY TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THAT, COULD WE A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT AND WE'LL HEAR
MORE FROM, YOU KNOW, UH, RANK
AND FILE INDIVIDUAL LATER ON,
BUT SOME OF THE FROM THE CHIEFS
PERSPECTIVE. TRAINING OVERALL,
INCREASED TRAINING TRAUMA,
INFORMED TRAINING ALSO, YOU
KNOW, TO BE HONEST LIKE WE DON'T
WANNA AVOID THE CONVERSATION OF
THIS IS A TOUGH JOB, RIGHT? IT
IS A TOUGH JOB. ABSOLUTELY NOT A
JOB THAT I WOULD WANNA DO I SO I
UNDERSTAND IT TAKES A CERTAIN
INDIVIDUAL TO BE IN THIS JOB,
AND WE WANNA MAKE SURE THEY THEY
ARE ALSO HUMAN BEINGS. UM, WE
WANNA PROTECT AND HAVE THEIR
SELF CARE BE TAKEN CARE OF. WHAT
ARE WE DOING IN THAT IF WE
PROTECT AND WE, UM UH, PROVIDE
SERVICES FOR POS. THEN HOPEFULLY
BY DEFAULT, THEY SHOULD BE ABLE
TO COME INTO WORK WITH A BETTER
MORALE AND SO FORTH. WHAT WHAT
ARE WE DOING IN THAT ROOM?
ABSOLUTELY AND SO, UM, IT'S ONE
OF THE AREAS THAT ACTUALLY WE'RE
WE'RE VERY PROUD OF, BECAUSE UM,
CPAC, IN PARTICULAR HAS BEEN
TRAINING ON TRAUMA INFORMED CARE
FOR MANY, MANY YEARS, AND SO WE
ARE. THE CHIEFS HAVE, UM, A YEAR
AFTER YEAR KIND OF PRIORITIZED
IT AS SOMETHING TO WORK ON AND
BE SURE. WE'RE PROVIDING THE
TOOLS TO OUR STAFF TO BE ABLE TO
DEAL WITH, UM YOU KNOW THE TOUGH
ASPECTS OF THE JOB, AND SO, UH,
SO MORE TRAINING IS NEEDED AND
BEING ABLE TO FUND THAT IS
NEEDED AND BEING ABLE TO MAKE
SURE THAT REMEMBER WHEN YOU'RE
TRYING TO TRAIN INSTITUTION
STAFF. YOU KNOW, THE THEY THEY
HAVE TO BE OUT OF THE
INSTITUTION TO DO IT. IT'S SOME
OF THE HARDEST STAFF TO BE ABLE
TO TRAIN BECAUSE OF THE RATIOS
AND BEING ABLE TO ENSURE IF
SOMEBODY IS IN TRAINING. YOU
HAVE TO BACKFILL THAT PERSON,
UH, IN IN THE FACILITIES, BUT
BOTTOM LINE. I MEAN IT. IT'S
ALWAYS, UM, KIND OF BEEN
DIFFICULT WHEN YOU KNOW WE
REQUIRE HIGH EDUCATIONAL A
DEGREE TO GET INTO PROBATION. UM
BUT YET THERE'S SOME OF THE
LOWEST PAID, UH, YOU KNOW, IN IN
THE, UH, LAW. WORLD IN SOME OF
THE IT'S A HARD JOB. SO LIKE YOU
SAY THEY GET ALL OF THIS
TRAINING AND THEN IT MAY MAKE A
LOT MORE SENSE TO GO WORK IN THE
EDUCATIONAL SETTING. IT MAY MAKE
MORE SENSE TO GO WORK IN THE
HEALTH SETTING. SO HOW DO WE TRY
TO ADDRESS? SOME OF THOSE THINGS
HAVE BEEN REALLY, REALLY A TOUGH
ISSUE NOT AT ALL CAUSED BY
REALIGNMENT, BUT CERTAINLY, UH,
JUST CONTINUES TO EXACERBATE IT
AS OUR AS OUR POPULATIONS BECOME
MORE COMPLEX. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ED ED, I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU
WANTED. THANK YOU AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR BEING LATE. AND
PERHAPS I MISSED A LOT OF THIS.
UM, BUT I SIRS COMMITTEE A
COUPLE OF YEARS AND WATCH THE,
UM THE DISILLUSION OF THE FORMER
PROGRAM AND HAD TWO JUVENILE
FACILITIES IN MY IN MY DISTRICT
AND SPENT A LOT OF I MEAN,
VISITED QUITE A FEW BECAUSE A
LOT OF MY FORMER STUDENTS WORKED
THERE, RIGHT. SO YOU HAD M S¼ W
S¼ L èC S¼ W S¼ WHO WERE DOING
REALLY INNOVATIVE PROGRAMMING.
UM AND SO, I. I GUESS I WANNA GO
BACK TO THE STAFF ISSUE, AND
CLEARLY THERE'S A, UH, A
HISTORIC PROBLEM. I THINK IT'S
FAIR TO SAY IN L A COUNTY
ESPECIALLY AS IT AS IT, UH,
RELATES TO JUVENILE JUSTICE AND
ISSUES. SO WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
AND AGAIN? I APOLOGIZE IF YOU
ALREADY BUT WHAT ARE YOU DOING
TO CHANGE THE CULTURE AND
PROFESSIONALIZE THE STAFF? I
THINK THAT'S KIND OF WHAT
SENATOR MENJIVAR ASKED BEFORE,
BUT IN A REAL I MEAN IN MY
COUNTY RIGHT NOW, RIGHT? THERE'S
SOME SPECIAL, UH, FUNDING GOING
INTO LIKE, GROW YOUR OWN RIGHT.
SO M S¼ W PROGRAMS. UH, MF Tð
PROGRAMS. CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE DOING TO
ACTUALLY AND I UNDERSTAND YOU
SAY IT'S HARD. IT'S ALWAYS BEEN
HARD. IT'S ALWAYS BEEN A
PROBLEM, BUT THAT'S NÓ. I MEAN,
WE HAVE THAT'S NÓ. THAT'S NÓ
ANSWER ANYMORE, RIGHT? RIGHT
IT'S WE CAN'T JUST SAY IT'S
HARD. THIS MUST BE DONE. WE'RE
HERE. WE'RE HURTING KIDS. AND I
THINK THE BURNOUT MAKES IT MAKES
EVEN MORE SENSE THAT PEOPLE
FEELING DISILLUSIONED, RIGHT AND
LIKE IT. THEY'RE JUST IN A PIT.
SO HOW DO WE CHANGE THAT? SURE
AND I AND I CERTAINLY CAN'T
SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TO THE L A
ISSUES. I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE SOME SOME INFORMATION LATER
ON IN THE PANEL THAT MIGHT
PROVIDE SOME FURTHER INSIGHT ON
THAT. BUT I CAN TELL YOU AND I'M
SURE YOU ALL ARE WELL AWARE OF
THIS. THIS DIDN'T HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT, YOU KNOW, AND IT
TAKES AND IT TAKES TIME TO ALSO
GET OUT OF THAT OF THAT PART OF
THE PROGRAM. WE'RE ALSO NOT
SEEING THOSE EXACT TYPE OF, UM
ISSUES IN ALL THE OTHER COUNTIES
AND AT THAT LEVEL, EVEN THOUGH
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
BACKFILLING, UM, OUR OUR
STAFFING SHORTAGES. UM, BUT IT
IT IT'S REALLY NOT A PROBABLY
THE HISTORIC LEVELS THAT THAT L
A IS SEEING AND TRYING TO
ADDRESS. AND SO, UM, SO AS AS IT
RELATES TO HOW YOU GET OUT OF
SOMETHING THAT HAS HAS TO COME
THAT FAR. DO YOU THINK IT'S
GOING TO OBVIOUSLY TAKE TIME AND
DIFFERENT, INNOVATIVE IDEAS
AROUND TRAINING IS THE KEY. UM
AGAIN SEA PARK? UH, BECAUSE THE
CHIEFS HAVE RECOGNIZED THAT AND
DEDICATED THAT A BIG PART OF
WHAT OUR FOUNDATION DOES IS
PROVIDE THAT TRAINING AND IS
REALLY TRYING TO ALSO BE SURE
THAT WE ARE KEEPING THE MORALE
UP. YOU KNOW, THAT'S A THAT'S
ANOTHER REALLY IMPORTANT THING
IS, AS YOU KNOW, AND IN ANY
PROFESSION, AND SO YOU KNOW,
MAKING SURE THAT YOU KNOW MY
TESTIMONY AT THE BEGINNING WAS
WAS REALLY TRYING TO TALK ABOUT.
I MEAN, WE CAN HAVE AS MUCH DATA
AS YOU LIKE. IF YOU DON'T REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING AND
HEAR THOSE STORIES AND LIGHT THE
WAY FOR POSITIVE PEER PRESSURE
AS TO WHY CULTURE SHOULD CHANGE.
YOU KNOW, IT'S GONNA BE MUCH
HARDER TO DO THAT WE'RE DOING
THAT. I THINK WE'RE DOING THAT
REALLY SUCCESSFULLY IN A LOT OF
PLACES. UM YOU KNOW, YOUR COUNTY
IS A SHINING EXAMPLE OF THAT,
QUITE FRANKLY. AND SO I THINK WE
JUST NEED TO DO MORE OF IT. AND
WE DON'T WANT TO WORK BACKWARDS
FROM THAT. REMEMBER THIS IS THE
LAST PIECE OF THE ENTIRE
JUVENILE JUSTICE CONTINUUM. AND
THE REST OF THE CONTINUUM LOCALS
HAVE BEEN HANDLING AT THAT LOCAL
LEVEL SUCCESSFULLY IN THE WAY
THAT IT'S IT HAS BEEN SHRINKING
THE FOOTPRINT OF THE OF
DETENTION. IT HAS NOT SEEN A
CORRESPONDING INCREASE IN CRIME.
SO HOW DO WE NOW? TAKE THAT TO
THIS NEXT PART OF THE CONTINUUM
AND YOU KNOW, THEY'LL PROBABLY
NEED TO BE NEW TOOLS AND NEW
TRAINING ASSOCIATED WITH THAT. I
MEAN, BECAUSE IT JUST IF, IF THE
STAFF PREVIOUSLY WAS AT THE AT
THE STATE LEVEL, RIGHT, AND THEN
IT'S ALL GONNA SHIFT TO THE
COUNTIES AND THE COUNTIES.
REALLY IT'S INCUMBENT UPON THEM,
ESPECIALLY WITH SOME OF THE
OTHER CHANGES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS UNDERTAKEN
RECENTLY. REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT TO GET THE WORKFORCE
UP. ABSOLUTELY. UH, COULD I ASK
THE SAME QUESTION? UH, MY
COLLEAGUE ASKED IN A RESPONSE
FROM MISS. PARIS. ON THE
STAFFING ON TRAINING I. I LIKE
TO SEE NÓ. IS THERE
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN THE
VARIOUS COMMUNITY AND SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS ON THIS ISSUE?
WITH PROBATION STAFF. WELL, YES.
WHAT WE. HEARING AND SEEING IS
THAT THERE IS A RESISTANCE. BY
PROBATION STAFF. TO EXPANDING
COMMUNITY-BASED PROGRAMS IN THAT
COME INTO THE JUVENILE
FACILITIES TO RUN. PROGRAMS THAT
PROBATION IS, UM. THAT DIFFERENT
PROBATION. SORRY PROBATION IS
NOT ONE MONOLITHIC THING THAT
DIFFERENT PROBATION DEPARTMENTS,
UM, ARE ATTEMPTING TO RUN
PROGRAMS WITH THEIR OWN STAFF.
AND THOSE STAFF, UM, ARE NOT
TRAINED TO PROVIDE PROGRAMS IN
THE WAY THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. ARE TRAINED TO DO
THEM. JASMINE WAS TALKING ABOUT
THIS IN HER OPENING REMARKS.
THERE ARE èC B S¼, UM AROUND
THE STATE, THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
JUSTICE IS AN ORGANIZATION THAT
SUPPORTS èC B S¼ ALL OVER THE
STATE THAT ARE READY AND ABLE TO
GO INTO JUVENILE HALLS TO
PROVIDE, UM CREDIBLE MESSENGERS
TO PROVIDE TRAUMA, INFORMED
PROGRAMMING TO PROVIDE SOME, YOU
KNOW. THERAPEUTIC REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING, AND WE NEED A
BETTER PARTNERSHIP. UM WE ARE
ASKING FOR BETTER PARTNERSHIPS
WITH THE PROBATION DEPARTMENTS
TO ALLOW THOSE GROUPS INTO THE
FACILITIES TO DO PROGRAMMING.
AND I JUST HAVE ONE LAST
QUESTION. DIRECTOR LUCERO, UM
YOU KNOW OUR OUR MY. NEXT YEAR.
WE'RE GONNA BE GETTING A REPORT
ON THE EFFICACY EFFICACY OF THE
PROGRAMS AROUND ALL JUVENILE
HALLS. YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY
INSIGHT YOU CAN SHARE WITH US
NOW. HAVE YOU STARTED COLLECTING
SOME THAT DATA THAT YOU WILL BE
REPORTING TO US NEXT YEAR? SO
THE NEW DATA THAT IS REQUIRED
FROM 505 REQUIRES A TOUCH POINTS
AND INFORMATION ON PROGRAM
IMPROVEMENT. SO THE PRIOR, UH
COUNTY PLANS DID NOT REQUIRE
THAT? UM UH SO THAT IS ONE WAY
THAT WE ARE PLANNING TO BE ABLE
TO KNOW MORE ABOUT THE COUNTY'S
OWN ASSESSMENTS. WE'RE ALSO
GONNA DRAW UPON OUR OMBUDS DATA
AND WHERE WE'RE ABLE TO
EFFECTIVELY PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO AMELIORATE
PROBLEMS THAT WE MAY BE SEEING
IN CERTAIN JURISDICTIONS, AND
THAT'S ANOTHER WAY THAT WE CAN
MEASURE PROGRESS. UM, SOME
COUNTIES ACTUALLY PUBLISH ANNUAL
REPORTS. I THINK AT LEAST I
DON'T KNOW. I DON'T WANT TO SAY
THEN SAY THE I THINK IT'S AROUND
10 SOME OF THE LARGER
JURISDICTIONS, SO WE'LL DRAW ON
AVAILABLE PUBLIC DATA. WE'LL
LOOK AT Dð Ó J DATA, BUT WITH
REGARD TO PROGRAMS WE'RE GONNA
ALSO LOOK AT OUR OWN INITIATIVES
. THE LESS RESTRICTIVE PROGRAM
INITIATIVE, THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT INITIATIVE, THE
ENDING GIRLS INCARCERATION
INITIATIVE, SO IT'S REALLY GONNA
BE A VERY DIVERSE APPROACH AND
HOW WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
ANALYZE AND UNDERSTAND WHAT HAS
HAPPENED, UH IN 2025 SINCE THE
REALIGNMENT AND THE COMPLETE
CLOSURE OF Dð JJ IN JUNE OF 2020
THREE. WE WON'T HAVE THINGS AND
I'M STILL STRUGGLING TO REALLY
FIGURE OUT THE RECIDIVISM PIECE.
UM BECAUSE Dð JJ USED TO KEEP
THAT INFORMATION. I'M NOT SURE.
UM RIGHT NOW. WHO'S THE KEEPER
OF THAT INFORMATION? IT MIGHT BE
OUR NEW Dð Ó J, UM, DATA? UM,
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT PIECE. IT'S NOT THOUGH
, YOU KNOW, WE ALSO WANT TO KNOW
OUR YOUTH CONNECTED TO THEIR
FAMILIES. ARE THEY LEAVING? UH,
CARCERAL SETTINGS WITH, UH,
SUSTAINABLE INCOMES OR
CERTIFICATIONS THAT CAN ALLOW
THEM TO BEGIN WORK IMMEDIATELY.
ARE THEY GOING FROM CARCERAL
SETTINGS TO COLLEGE? THERE'S A
LOT OF THINGS THAT WE'RE GONNA
BE ABLE TO TRACK ALSO WITH
RISING SCHOLARS, AND BECAUSE WE
HAVE AN EDUCATION ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THAT IS AGAIN PULLING
TOGETHER AND HELPING US TRACK
DATA, THERE'S A LOT OF DATA IN
THE COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION,
PUBLIC PORTALS. UM WE'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO LOOK AT PO
POSSIBLE, YOU KNOW, UH, LITERACY
RATES AND MATH AND READING. SO
WE'RE LOOKING, UM, SENATOR AT A
VARIETY OF WAYS TO TELL THAT
STORY. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. EVERYONE FOR PARTICIPATING
IN PAN Ó A. WE'RE GONNA BE
MOVING ON TO PANEL TWO. POWER TO
HAS BROKEN UP INTO TWO SUB
PANELS. WE HAVE THE FIRST THREE
SPEAKERS COMING UP WITH
COLLEAGUES. I ASK IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FOR THESE FIRST
THREE SPEAKERS, LET THEM BE
SMALLER ONES, AND WE'LL FOCUS ON
THE BIGGER QUESTIONS, UM, FOR
THE ENTIRE PANEL AFTER BOTH OF
THEM ARE DONE. I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME UP FROM B èC, THE BOARD
OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS, KATHLEEN HOWARD.
FROM ASK ME LOCAL 685 THAT
REPRESENT SOME PROBATION
OFFICERS. JONATHAN BY AND L, A
PROBATION OVERSIGHT
COMMISSIONER, MELINDA KANI. I
WAS RIGHT. GREAT. WE'LL START
KATHLEEN WHEN YOU'RE READY. GOOD
MORNING. UM. GOOD MORNING
SENATORS, UH, CHAIRS AND OTHER
SENATORS HERE TODAY. THANK YOU
FOR INVITING ME. MY NAME IS
KATIE HOWARD AND I'M, THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE BOARD
OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS. B S¼ èC èC, AND
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO TALK TODAY
ABOUT THE BOARD'S CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLAN PROCESS AND
DETERMINATIONS OF SUITABILITY
SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON THREE OF
THE JUVENILE FACILITIES IN L, A
COUNTY CENTRAL JUVENILE HALL,
LOS PADRINO'S JUVENILE HALL AND
BARRY JAY NEIDORF. UM AND THAT
FACILITY HAS BEEN BOTH A
JUVENILE HALL AND AN OR SECURE
YOUTH TREATMENT FACILITY. UM,
IT'S CURRENTLY OPERATING AS AN
S¼ Y Tð F AND I'LL EXPLAIN. I'LL
GO THROUGH THROUGH THAT IN A
COUPLE OF MINUTES HERE. UM THERE
HAS BEEN A GREAT DEAL OF
ACTIVITY AT THE B S¼ èC, UH,
WITH OUR INSPECTIONS, UM,
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS AND
SUITABILITY DETERMINATIONS IN
THESE L A FACILITIES SO I'M
GOING TO OFFER A REALLY FAST
HIGH LEVEL SUMMARY. UM ABOUT
RECENT AND UPCOMING BOARD, UM,
ACTIONS SO THE B S¼ èC IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR INSPECTING ALL
OF THE LOCAL ADULT AND JUVENILE
DETENTION. FACILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF OUR MISSION,
AND IT OBVIOUSLY ADDRESSES THE
SAFETY OF YOUNG PEOPLE AND STAFF
IN THESE FACILITIES. UM AND
BOTTOM LINE WHEN OUR INSPECTIONS
IDENTIFY THAT A FACILITY IS OUT
OF COMPLIANCE WITH ANY OF THE
REGULATIONS, THE FACILITY IS
NOTIFIED IN AN INITIAL
INSPECTION REPORT ABOUT AN ITEM
OF NON-COMPLIANCE, AND THEN THE
FACILITY IS REQUIRED TO SUBMIT A
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN OR A CAP
TO THE B S¼ èC THAT OUTLINES
HOW THE FACILITY WILL CORRECT
EACH ITEM OF NON COMPLIANCE. ALL
OF THIS IS REQUIRED BY WELFARE
AND INSTITUTIONS. CODE SECTION
209, WHICH STATES THAT THE
FACILITY MUST HAVE AN APPROVED
CAP WITHIN 60 DAYS OF THE NOTICE
OF NON COMPLIANCE ONCE THE
COUNTY HAS AN APPROVED CAP. THEY
HAVE A 90 DAY PERIOD IN WHICH TO
REMEDY THOSE ITEMS OF NON
COMPLIANCE, AND YOU HAD ASKED
FOR INFORMATION ABOUT THE
CRITICAL ISSUES THAT WERE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE IN CENTRAL JUVENILE
HALL AND BJ  N JUVENILE HALL
LAST YEAR. I'M NOT GONNA LIST
EVERY SINGLE ONE AND GIVE YOU A
WHOLE BUNCH OF NUMBERS. ALL THIS
INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE ON OUR
RIGHT, BUT THE ISSUES PRIMARILY
HAD TO DO WITH STAFFING, AND THE
PRIOR PANEL TALKED ABOUT SOME OF
THOSE CHALLENGES. UM AT BJ  N,
UM, THE OUT OF COMPLIANCE ISSUES
RELATED TO STAFFING, FIRE SAFETY
, SAFETY CHECKS, ROOM
CONFINEMENT, USE OF FORCE
SEARCHES, EDUCATION PROGRAMS,
UH, PROGRAMS, RECREATION AND
EXERCISE AND DISCIPLINE. SO A
BROAD RANGE OF THE OPERATIONAL
ISSUES IN THAT FACILITY. VERY
SIMILAR LIST OF ITEMS OF NON
COMPLIANCE. UM PERSISTED AT
CENTRAL JUVENILE HALL AND AFTER
MANY DIFFERENT HEARINGS AND
PROCEDURAL STEPS LAST YEAR IN
MAY, MAY 2023 OUR BOARD
DETERMINED THAT THESE TWO
JUVENILE HALLS WERE UNSUITABLE
FOR THE CONFINEMENT OF MINORS,
AND THAT AT THAT POINT, LOS
ANGELES COUNTY HAD 60 DAYS PER
WICK TWO Ó THREE TO VACATE
THOSE JUVENAL TWO JUVENILE HALLS
AND MOVE THE YOUNG PEOPLE AS I'M
SURE YOU'RE AWARE L, A COUNTY
MOVED QUICKLY TO GET LOS PADNOS
JUVENILE HALL READY FOR THE
YOUNG PEOPLE. BE MOVED THERE
WITHIN 60 DAYS. UM THAT MOVE WAS
COMPLETED IN LATE JULY OF 2023,
AND WE WENT INTO LOS PADNOS IN
AUGUST OF 2020 THREE TO INSPECT
OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO STAY ON
TOP OF THESE THINGS, AND WE HAVE
DONE SO, UM THERE WERE ITEMS OF
NON COMPLIANCE IDENTIFIED IN
THAT AUGUST INSPECTION. L. A
COUNTY. UH, PROVIDED A CAP. WE
APPROVED THAT CAP. SO IT WAS IN
PLACE OF A, UM AS OF OCTOBER
16TH OF LAST YEAR AND THEN THE
COUNTY HAD 90 DAYS TO MAKE THOSE
CORRECTIONS ON JANUARY 10TH OF
THIS YEAR WE RECEIVED A
COMMUNICATION FROM L, A COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENT, UM,
STATING THAT THE CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLAN HAD BEEN COMPLETED
IN ALL AREAS. WE WENT BACK TO
THE FACILITY AND REINSPECTED AT
LOS PADNOS IN LATE JANUARY AND
EARLY FEBRUARY, AND WE
DETERMINED THAT ALL OF THOSE
ITEMS HAD NOT BEEN CORRECTED. UM
SO. THE MOST CURRENT INFORMATION
. UM, LISTS AGAIN A REALLY
SIMILAR LIST OF THOSE, UM ITEMS
OF NON COMPLIANCE AS HAD BEEN
PRESENT IN THE JUVENILE HALLS
LAST YEAR REMAINING OUT OF
COMPLIANCE AT LOS PADRINO'S
AGAIN STAFFING, YOUTH
SUPERVISION, STAFF ORIENTATION
AND TRAINING THEIR POLICY AND
PROCEDURE. MANUAL FIRE SAFETY
PLANS. SAFETY CHECKS, ROOM
CONFINEMENT USE OF FORCE
SEARCHES EDUCATION PROGRAM.
PROGRAMS RECREATION, EXERCISE
AND DISCIPLINE. SOME OF THESE
ARE MUCH MORE SERIOUS THAN
OTHERS AS YOU CAN SEE, BUT THAT
IS A LIST OF THE REMAINING ITEMS
OF THAT ARE OUT OF COMPLIANCE.
UM I'D LIKE TO PROVIDE THE
CURRENT STATUS INFORMATION AT BJ
N S¼ Y Tð F AND AS YOU HEARD
QUITE A BIT IN THE PRIOR PANEL,
THE SECURE YOUTH TREATMENT
FACILITY IS A NEW TYPE OF LOCAL
DETENTION FACILITY THAT CAME
INTO BEING AFTER Dð JJ
REALIGNMENT AND S¼ B 820 THREE
AND IN GENERAL, AS THE LAST
PANEL WAS DISCUSSING S¼ Y Tð F
S¼ HER COMMITMENT FACILITIES, UM
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE WHO WOULD HAVE
GONE TO Dð JJ PRIOR TO
REALIGNMENT AND A COMMITMENT
FACILITY MEANS A POST
ADJUDICATION PLACEMENT. UM, IN
GENERAL TERMS THE JUVENILE HALL
FACIL. IS UH, HOUSE YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO HAVE NOT YET BEEN THROUGH
THE TRIAL PROCESS. UM YOU ALSO
HEARD TODAY ABOUT THE HIGH
LEVELS OF PROGRAMMING. AND
TREATMENT NEEDS IN THE SPY TF
FACILITIES. UM SO THE B S¼ èC
èC DID NOT HAVE THE LEGAL
AUTHORITY UNDER WIC 209 TO MAKE
A SUITABILITY DETERMINATION IN
ALL TYPES OF JUVENILE FACILITIES
. UH, UNTIL LAST YEAR, SO WHEN
WE MADE THAT SUITABILITY
DETERMINATION ABOUT THE BARRY
JANE NEIDER OF JUVENILE HALL,
THE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO WERE IN THE
S¼ Y Tð F PORTION OF THAT
FACILITY, UM, REMAINS THERE AND
THAT'S AND IT'S STILL BEING
OPERATED IN THAT WAY. SO AS SOON
AS WE HAD THE LEGAL AUTHORITY TO
INSPECT IN A WAY THAT WOULD
ULTIMATELY POTENTIALLY LEAD TO A
SUITABILITY DETERMINATION. WE
INSPECTED, UH BJ  N IN AUGUST OF
LAST YEAR, A PRETTY SIMILAR TIME
FRAME. TO WHAT? I JUST WENT OVER
WITH LOS PADRINO. WE RECEIVED UM
AND ÁP AND APPROVED A CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLAN. AS OF OCTOBER. 9TH,
UM THE COUNTY HAD 90 DAYS TO
MAKE THOSE CORRECTIONS ON
JANUARY 5TH OF THIS YEAR, THEY
PROVIDED VERIFICATION THAT MOST
OF THOSE, UM ITEMS HAD BEEN HAD
BEEN CORRECTED. WE DID FOLLOW UP
INSPECTIONS AND, UM OUR REVIEW,
UM LED US TO CONCLUDE THAT THERE
ARE STILL A NUMBER OF ITEMS OF
NON-COMPLIANCE SIMILAR LISTS TO
THE OTHERS. SO THAT BRINGS US TO
TODAY AND TOMORROW. UM THE BS
èC MEETS TOMORROW AND ON OUR
AGENDA IS A DETERMINATION OF
SUITABILITY FOR BOTH. LOS PADNOS
, UM, JUVENILE HALL AND THE
BARRY J NEIDORF S¼ Y Tð F. UM
AGAIN ALL THIS INFORMATION IS
AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE. L A
COUNTY HAS RESPONDED WITH SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION HAS MADE
A VARIETY OF REQUESTS OF THE
BOARD AND, UM, WE ANTICIPATE L A
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES TO BE
PRESENT AT THE BOARD MEETING
TOMORROW FOR DISCUSSION WITH OUR
BOARD. IT REALLY WOULDN'T BE
APPROPRIATE FOR ME TO SPECULATE
ON WHAT THE BOARD MAY DO
TOMORROW. BUT I'M VERY HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY PROCESS QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO MR BIRD. THANK YOU. I
NEEDED POETS ON. THANK YOU.
FIRST OF ALL FOR INVITING, UH,
THE RANK AND FILE, BUT I DON'T
ONLY REPRESENT THE RANK AND FILE
WE WORK CLOSELY WITH, UH S¼ EIU
721 JOINT COUNCIL WHO ARE
SUPERVISORS AND ALSO, UH, THE
DIRECTORS WHO WAS A PART OF ASK
ME AS WELL AS WE ARE. SOME
MESSAGING IS DIFFICULT IN THIS
ERA. THERE'S A THING CALLED
BEING POLITICALLY CORRECT. AND
THEN THERE'S ALSO. UH CREATED
NOWADAYS REALITY SHOWS THAT
DON'T SHOW REALITY. AND THEN
LASTLY, I'LL SAY WE HAVE COME TO
A POINT WHERE ALTERNATIVE FACTS
HAVE TAKEN THE PLACE. FACTS AND
SO SOMETIME WHEN IT'S MESSAGING
IS A LITTLE DIFFICULT, SO I WAS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT SHOULD
I SAY ON BEHALF OF THE WORKING
MEN AND WOMEN WHO WORK IN
PROBATION, WHICH WILL CROSS OVER
TO BE PART PARTLY PROACTIVE
TOWARD PRO PROBATION AND MAY
HAVE SOMEWHAT OF A BIAS. UH I
WILL SAY THERE ARE CERTAIN
TERMINOLOGIES THAT'S BEING USED
IN L. A COUNTY UH, MAYBE NOT
GLOBALLY. BUT IN L, A COUNTY,
FOR INSTANCE, THERE'S
ALTERNATIVE TO INCARCERATION.
UH, PROBATION. THE MEN AND WOMEN
THAT WORK IN PROBATION. THEY'VE
ALREADY CONSIDERED THEMSELVES TO
BE THE ALTERNATIVE INC IN UH,
INCARCERATION, FOR INSTANCE, WE
CHANGED THE NAME OF CAMPS TO
CAMPUS. IN OTHER WORDS, GIVEN
THE INDICATION THAT WE GIVE AND
PROVIDE SOMETHING DIFFERENT THAN
JUST, UH INCARCERATING KIDS OR
YOUTH, UH, AND HAVING THEM IN
CUSTODY. UH WE'RE CONSIDER
OURSELVES TO BE THE LARGEST
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION.
THERE IS WHY DO I SAY THAT? OVER
80% OF THE MEN AND WOMEN THAT
WORK IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND
PROBATION. PEOPLE OF COLOR. THEY
COME RIGHT OUT OF THE COMMUNITY.
WHEN THEY GET THE JOBS, THEY
DON'T GO AND MOVE OUTSIDE OF THE
COMMUNITY. THEY WORK WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY, SO IT WOULD BE VERY
SUSPICIOUS TO THINK THAT AS A
PROBATION OFFICER, YOU WOULD DO
SOMETHING TO DAMAGE YOUR OWN
COMMUNITY BY TRYING TO INCREASE
RECIDIVISM. ARE TRYING TO NOT
GIVE THEM THE SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED. AND SO I'M TRYING TO GIVE
YOU THE UNDERSTANDING OF KNOWING
WHAT IS EMBEDDED IN THE HEART OF
A PROBATION OFFICER. THE
MAJORITY OF US ARE EDUCATED.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN WE'RE NECE.
NECESSARILY SUCCESSFUL IN THE,
UH, IDEOLOGY OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE, BUT IT DOES MEAN THAT
WE CAN ADAPT. IN OTHER WORDS, WE
GO TO COLLEGE. WE GET A FOURYEAR
DEGREE. WE ARE ABLE TO ADAPT. SO
WHAT WE'RE SAYING ABOUT
PROBATION AND THE PROBATION
OFFICER IS ANYTHING THAT YOU
IMAGINE THAT YOU WON'T CAN BE
DONE THROUGH THE LEAD OF THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT. THE STATE
HAVE DECIDED THAT PROBATION IS
THE ENTITY LONG TIME AGO THAT IF
YOU HAVE YOUTH THAT, FOR SOME
REASON CANNOT SUCCEED IN THE
PREVENTIVE MEASURES THEY
SOMETIMES HAVE TO BE. EXCUSE THE
WORD INCARCERATED, BUT THE
INCARCERATED THE INCARCERATION
DOESN'T HAVE TO LOOK LIKE
PRISON. IT SHOULD LOOK LIKE
SOMETHING THAT PROVIDES HOPE.
THEREFORE THE STRUCTURES WE
TALKED ABOUT THE FACILITIES. UH,
WHAT'S THE NEED OF IMPROVEMENT
AND FACILITIES? YES, MONEY HAVE
BEEN GIVEN TO, UH, FACILITIES. I
THINK I HEARD SOMETHING ON THE
CASE OF 900 MILLION, BUT THAT'S
DIVIDED THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
I'VE BEEN WORKING IN JUVENILE
INSTITUTIONS FOR 32 YEARS. WHEN
I FIRST STARTED, WE WERE THE
HIGHLIGHT OF PROBATION IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. WE ACTUALLY
HOSTED, UH, COUNTRIES THAT WOULD
COME OVER AND TRY TO FIND OUT
WHAT WE DID. BUT EVEN THEN, WE
WERE ASKING LOS ANGELES COUNTY
TO MAKE CHANGES TO THE
STRUCTURE. MAKE IT LOOK MORE
LIKE A CARE FOR HOME LIKE
ENVIRONMENT. UH, THEY REFUSED.
AFTER A WHILE, WE HAD 19 CAMPS,
AND THEN THEY DECIDED THEY
WANTED TO REDUCE IT. THAT'S FINE
. WE KNOW WE REDUCED THE
POPULATION OF INCARCERATION BY A
LARGE NUMBER OVER THE YEARS.
THEY DON'T GIVE CREDIT TO
PROBATION. BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THAT AS PROBATION OFFICERS
WHAT WE GAVE TO THOSE WHO CAME
INTO OUR CUSTODY WHEN THEY WENT
BACK HOME TO THEIR FAMILIES. UH,
THEY DECIDED THAT MAYBE THEY
WOULD SHARE THAT MESSAGE, UH,
WITH THEIR FAMILIES AND FRIENDS,
AND THEREFORE THERE'S A
REDUCTION IN THE INCARCERATION,
BUT WHEN THEY REDUCED THE CAMPS
THEY ALSO REDUCED THE STAFFING
INVENTORY. IN OTHER WORDS, IN
2010, THERE WERE MORE THAN 4400
MEMBERS OF PROBATION IN THE RANK
AND FILE. TODAY WE HAVE LESS
THAN 2600 NOW, UH, ATTRITION WE
KNOW HAPPENED, BUT WHAT ALSO
HAPPENED IS BECAUSE THE TERM
PROBATION OR INCARCERATION IS
LOOKED AT AS A NEGATIVE THING.
THEREFORE NÓ INVESTMENT WAS MADE
TO, UH, KEEPING STAFF WHO HAVE
THE ABILITIES. THE SENIORITY.
THE VETERAN SHIP, HOWEVER YOU
WANT TO INTERN IT, UH, IN THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT. SO MANY
PEOPLE HAVE LEFT. THERE WAS A
PERIOD OF TIME FOR OVER FIVE
YEARS THAT THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS DECIDED WE'LL PUT A
HIRING FREEZE ON PROBATION.
DURING THAT TIME, UH, WE LOST
MANY STAFF THROUGH ATTRITION AND
WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO RECOVER
FROM THAT. I SAY THAT ONLY TO
SAY THAT, UH, WHEN IT COMES TO
THE B, S¼ èC B S¼ èC èC
INSPECTIONS AND REVIEWS. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
CERTAIN THINGS THAT WE HAVE
FAILED AT. THAT WHERE YOU COME
FROM A SHORTAGE STAFF SHORTAGE
OF STAFFING. I'LL GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE. THERE'S A THING CALLED
A HOCK. YOU GO DOWN AND YOU
CHECK THE DOOR AND YOU MAKE SURE
THAT YOU OR YOU HIT THE NEW
MONTH. UH, MONITORING SYSTEM NOW
WE FAIL AT THAT. WHY BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT DIRECT SUPERVISION
OVER THE YOUTH THAT WE HAVE IS
MORE IMPORTANT THAN CHECKING THE
DOOR. SO SOMETIME IF YOU ARE
CRITICALLY SHORT, IT CAUSES
OTHER PROBLEMS THAT YOU WILL
FAIL IN. SO I. I JUST GIVE THAT
EXAMPLE. BUT LASTLY, UH I KNOW
TIME IS MOVING ON I. I WILL SAY
THAT THE INVESTMENT IN STAFF UH,
AS I SAID, THERE, MOST OF THEM
ARE WELL EDUCATED. THEY HAVE THE
ADAPTABILITY TO TRAINING. I
AGREE, I. I DISAGREE FOR
SOMETHING THAT I HEARD THAT WE
DON'T WANT TO BE TRAINED IN THE
HIGHER LEVEL FORMS OF TRAINING
NECESSARY TO PROVIDE THERAPEUTIC
CARE. I HAVE A DAUGHTER WHO, UH,
MAJORS IN, UH, SHE'S A LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER. I KNOW
ALL ABOUT DIALECTICAL BEHAVIOR
THERAPY. UH THOSE THINGS ARE
EMBEDDED IN THE HEART OF
PROBATION OFFICERS. WE WANT TO
GIVE THE BEST. THAT WE CAN. NOW
THERE IS THE ELEPHANT IN THE
ROOM. IT'S ALWAYS THE ELEPHANT
IN THE ROOM. AND THAT ELEPHANT
IS WE'VE BEEN PUBLICIZED AS
CHILD ABUSE OR SEX ABUSERS NOT
GOING TO WORK AND I WILL SAY
THIS IN ANY ENTITY IN ANY
ORGANIZATION, YOU MAY HAVE SOME
ISSUES. WE ARE A SELF REGULATORY
INSTITUTION. IN OTHER WORDS,
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT WE ARE
MANDATED TO REPORT ANYTHING WE
SEE THAT'S OUT OF CHARACTER FOR
A PROBATION OFFICER, AND WE DO
THAT ON A LARGE SCALE SOMETIME,
YOU WILL HAVE ISSUES, BUT THEY
HAVE A PROCESS TO TAKE CARE OF
THOSE ISSUES. AND IF WE HAVE
ANYBODY IN OUR INSTITUTIONS THAT
, UH, DO THAT TYPE OF THING.
THEY NEED TO BE OUT. MR BIRD. IF
YOU WRAP UP, PLEASE, I WILL WRAP
UP. I WILL SAY THIS. I BELIEVE
THAT PROBATION AND THE PROBATION
OFFICER IS THE LEAD INTO
RECEIVING ARE REIMAGINING. I
WILL GIVE THIS EXAMPLE AND YOU
MAY NOT BE RELIGIOUS AND YOU MAY
NOT HAVE HEARD THE STORY. BUT
THERE'S A THING CALLED THE TOWER
OF BABBLE HAS TO DEAL WITH THE
SEPARATION OF LANGUAGES. BUT THE
PRINCIPLE OF THAT WAS IF THEY
ALL SPOKE THE SAME LANGUAGE.
WHATEVER THEY IMAGINE, AND I'LL
SAY REIMAGINE. THEY CAN DO SO
WHEN IT COMES TO PROBATION, AND
èC, B S¼ AND, UH, ADVOCACIES IF
THEY WOULD SPEAK WITH THE SAME
LANGUAGE AS THE PROBATION
DEPARTMENT AND LET PROBATION BE
THE LEAD TO FORM THESE M Dð Tð
S¼ AND INCORPORATE PEOPLE INTO
OUR, UH, INSTITUTIONS TO HELP.
THEN THERE'S NOTHING IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA CAN'T
ACCOMPLISH WITH THE YOUTH THAT
WE HAVE. THANK YOU. MISS
MELINDA. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
. ONCE AGAIN. I'M MELINDA KANI,
DIRECTOR OF YOUTH JUSTICE AT
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND,
CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO SUPERVISOR
HOLLY MITCHELL'S APPOINTEE TO
THE PROBATION OVERSIGHT
COMMISSION. BUT I'M GIVING MY
TESTIMONY LARGELY IN MY CAPACITY
AS A DIRECTOR OF YOUTH JUSTICE
AT CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND, AND
WHILE I DON'T SPEND MY DAYS
WORKING INSIDE FACILITIES IN MY
ROLE AS PROBATION OVERSIGHT
COMMISSIONER, I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VISIT THEM. AS
RECENTLY AS THIS PAST SUNDAY AND
I, I JUST WANT TO START WITH THE
PREMISE THAT CAGING OUR CHILDREN
, INCARCERATING THEM, DETAINING
THEM. WHATEVER VERB YOU WANT TO
CHOOSE IS NOT NORMAL, AND WE
MUST CONSISTENTLY REMIND
OURSELVES OF THAT. AND MY I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS A
BELIEF HELD BY SOME THAT THERE
WILL ALWAYS BE CHILDREN WHO NEED
THIS INSTITUTION. I WANT TO
PAINT THE PICTURE THAT I'M LEFT
WITH EVERY TIME I SPEND TIME IN
THESE FACILITIES. YOUR HORIZON
IS FILLED WITH BARBED WIRE. SOME
OF THE UNITS HAVE DAY ROOMS THAT
ARE A FRACTION OF THE SIZE OF
THIS HEARING ROOM MEANT TO
OCCUPY THE TIME OF 15 TO 20
YOUNG PEOPLE. YOU HAVE LIMITED
TO NÓ NATURAL LIGHT. THERE ARE
NÓ WINDOWS THAT YOU CAN OPEN NÓ
CLOCKS TO MARK THE PASSING OF
THE DAYS, WHICH ARE WILDLY WROTE
THE DOOR TO YOUR BEDROOM. UM,
ALTHOUGH CAGE OFTENTIMES FEELS
LIKE A MORE APPROPRIATE WORD
LOCKS BEHIND YOU, AND YOU HAVE
NÓ POWER TO OPEN THAT DOOR WHEN
YOU NEED TO THE DOOR TO FRESH
AIR IS LOCKED IN FRONT OF YOU
WITH NÓ CONTROL TO SMELL THE AIR
JUST AFTER IT RAINS OR AFTER THE
GRASS IS MOWED. SCHOOL OFTEN
OCCURS IN THAT AFOREMENTIONED
TINY DAY ROOM WHERE EDUCATION IS
COMPETING WITH VIDEO GAMES.
YOU'RE CUFFED AT YOUR ANKLES AND
YOUR WRISTS JUST TO GET YOUR
EYES CHECKED OR YOUR WRIST X
RAYED. IT ACTUALLY DOES FEEL
HOPELESS. IT'S CRAMPED. IT'S
STIFLED. IT'S SUFFOCATING, AND
THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT THE
STRUCTURES OF THE FACILITIES.
THESE LIVES OF THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE. THEY DON'T FEEL PRECIOUS
. THEY FEEL ABANDONED. NÓ ONE
REALLY NEEDS THIS INSTITUTION.
AND ONE OF THE UNDERLYING
PRINCIPLES OF SENATE BILL 823
WAS FOR COUNTIES TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF YOUTH BY IMPLEMENTING
PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACHES TO
SUPPORT POSITIVE YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT. BUILDING THE
CAPACITY OF A CONTINUUM OF
COMMUNITY BASED APPROACHES AND
REDUCING CRIME BY YOUTH AT ITS
CORE. PUBLIC HEALTH PROMOTES AND
PROTECTS THE HEALTH OF ALL
PEOPLE IN THEIR COMMUNITIES. THE
SCIENCE BASED EVIDENCE BACKFIELD
STRIVES TO GIVE EVERYONE A SAFE
PLACE TO LIVE TO LEARN TO WORK
TO PLAY. WHERE THREE YEARS INTO
THIS INCREDIBLE VISION THIS CALL
TO ACTION, THIS ACKNOWLEDGMENT
THAT THE INCARCERATION OF
CHILDREN IS A FAILED EXPERIMENT,
AND YET WE COULDN'T BE FURTHER
FROM WHERE WE NEED TO BE, IN
LARGE PART BECAUSE INSTEAD OF
PRIORITIZING OUR YOUNG PEOPLE,
THEIR BRILLIANCE, THEIR UNTAPPED
POTENTIAL, THEIR HEALING THEIR
JOY. WE FOUND OURSELVES IN THIS
CYCLE OF TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO HUMANELY INCARCERATE
THEM. AND WE HAVE DIVERTED
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ACTUALLY, A BILLION DOLLARS AS
YOU MENTIONED SENATOR MENJIVAR
TO JUVENILE CARTAL FACILITIES IN
THE NAME OF REHABILITATION,
HEALTH AND WELLNESS, AND YOU
CANNOT GET WELL IN A CELL. IT'S
REALLY NOT MORE COMPLICATED THAN
THAT. I WENT TO BERKELEY FOR
UNDERGRAD, AND FOR WHATEVER
MISGUIDED REASON I DECIDED TO
MAJOR IN BUSINESS. FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO KNOW ME THAT'S A BIT
COMICAL. BUT THERE'S A CONCEPT I
REMEMBER BEING EXPOSED TO RETURN
ON INVESTMENT. AND I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE INVESTMENT THAT
WE'RE MAKING IN L, A WE SPEND
OVER $420 MILLION OF OUR COUNTY
BUDGET ON OUR JUVENILE
INSTITUTIONS IN L, A COUNTY THAT
DOESN'T INCLUDE THE $88 MILLION
THAT CAME FROM THE STATE THAT L
A HAS RECEIVED AS PART OF THE
CLOSURE OF Dð JJ. THE 26 MILLION
THAT WE'RE SPENDING ON SECURITY
AND ENHANCEMENTS, THE TENS OF
MILLIONS WE SPENT ON FIXING OUR
FACILITIES TO MEET THE TERMS OF
THE Dð Ó J SETTLEMENT WE
ENTERED INTO IN 2021. OR THE L,
A COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION'S
JUVENILE COURT, SCHOOLS BUDGET
OR Dð, M HÌ S¼ JUVENILE SERVICES
BUDGET WITH 500 KIDS INSIDE
THESE FACILITIES, ONE OF THE
LOWEST NUMBERS WE'VE EVER HAD.
WE'RE SPENDING OVER A MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR ON THEIR
INCARCERATION. THAT'S OUR
INVESTMENT. WE'VE INVESTED IN AN
INSTITUTION, NOT THE SUCCESS OF
YOUNG PEOPLE, AND THE RETURN IS
ATROCIOUS. THE RETURN INVOLVES
39 YOUNG PEOPLE FACING NEW
CRIMINAL CHARGES BECAUSE OF THE
CULTURE AND ENVIRONMENT THEY ARE
SUBJECTED TO IN OUR CARCERAL
FACILITIES, AND THAT'S JUST FOR
THE LAST SIX MONTHS 36 YOUNG
PEOPLE WHILE THEY'VE BEEN
INCARCERATED AT LOS PADNOS AND
AT BARRY J NEIDORF ARE NOW
FACING NEW CRIMINAL CHARGES.
SOME ADULTS SOME JUVENILE BUT
ALL BECAUSE OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES
UNDER WHICH THEY ARE
INCARCERATED. THE RETURN
INVOLVES NEARLY HALF OF THE
PROBATION STAFF CALLING OUT OF
THEIR SHIFTS AT LOS PADNOS ON
SUPER BOWL SUNDAY BECAUSE THIS
WORK IS TAKING A TOLL ON THEM,
TOO. I WAS THERE ON SUNDAY TO DO
A STAFFING AUDIT. OF THE 60
STAFF THAT WE WERE GIVEN LIKE
NUMBERS TO BASED ON THE UNIT. 26
OR EITHER BEING HELD OVER OR HAD
VOLUNTEERED BECAUSE THEY WERE
AWARE THAT THEY WERE GOING TO BE
CALL OUTS RELATED TO SUPER BOWL
SUNDAY. SO THESE ARE 26 PEOPLE,
SOME WHO ARE WHAT ARE CALLED GSN
OR NIGHT STAFF, RIGHT? SO THEY
DON'T REALLY INTERACT WITH THESE
YOUNG FOLKS. THEY'VE BEEN UP ALL
NIGHT. AND THEY'RE BEING ASKED
TO PUT IN ANOTHER DAY, EIGHT
HOURS. ANOTHER AGAIN. THAT WAS,
I THINK, 14 OR SO AND THEN
ANOTHER 12 HAD JUST VOLUNTEERED,
AND THOSE WERE FOLKS WHO WERE
OUT IN THE COMMUNITY WHO ARE
FIELD SUPERVISORS OR FIELD Dð P
S¼, WHO GENERALLY DON'T WORK
INSIDE THE HALLS, BUT THEY'RE
SHOWING UP BECAUSE THEY CARE BUT
NOT BECAUSE THEY NECESSARILY
HAVE THE SKILLS TO BE INSIDE
HALLS AND CARE FOR THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE. THE RETURN ALSO INVOLVES
ABSOLUTELY NÓ, ACCOUNTING FOR
THE $88 MILLION THE STATE HAS
GIVEN TO L A COUNTY FOR OUR KIDS
WHO WOULD HAVE GONE TO Dð JJ.
THE RETURN IS FACILITIES THAT
CANNOT EVEN MEET THE MOST BASIC
OF MINIMUM STANDARDS SET FORTH
BY THE B èC. THE RETURN IS KIDS
HOARDING EMPTY MILK CARTONS SO
THAT THEY HAVE A PLACE TO
URINATE WHEN STAFF CAN'T OR
WON'T OPEN THEIR BEDROOM OR CAGE
DOORS. THE RETURN INVOLVES SO
MUCH TRAUMA AND I WAS A TERRIBLE
BUSINESS. MAJOR HATED NEARLY
EVERY SECOND OF IT, BUT I CAN
SPEAK WITH CONFIDENCE. WHEN I
SAY THIS IS A TERRIBLE RETURN ON
OUR INVESTMENT. A PUBLIC HEALTH
APPROACH REQUIRES BUILDING OUT
ALTERNATIVE STAT. A PUBLIC
HEALTH APPROACH REQUIRES REALLY
LOOKING AT THE EXPERIENCE, THE
EDUCATION THE OPPORTUNITIES
WE'RE SPENDING OUR DOLLARS ON
AND ASKING A Y èC R TO TRACK
THAT SPENDING, EVALUATE THESE
PROGRAMS AND ASSESS THE OUTCOMES
FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE, NOT JUST
BY RELYING ON LIKE COUNTY
REPORTING, BUT BY TALKING TO ALL
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS AND
REPORTING ON THAT, BECAUSE WHAT
HAPPENS IN A COUNTY LIKE L, A
BECAUSE IT'S A COUNTY FAMILY.
PUBLIC DEFENDERS, FOR EXAMPLE,
AREN'T ALLOWED TO SPEAK IN
CONTRADICTION TO WHAT THEY ARE
SEEING BEING DONE IN THE HANDS
OF THE PROBATION DEPARTMENT. I
CAN LISTEN FOR YOU FOR A FULL
HOUR. OK, SORRY. I JUST I JUST
WANNA LIKE WRAP UP REALLY
QUICKLY. I JUST WANNA SAY A
PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH REALLY
REQUIRES IN INCENTIVIZING OUR
COUNTY TO SURROUND OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE WITH HUMANITY AND CARE.
WE NEED TO DIVERSIFY THE POWER.
IT CANNOT SOLELY BE IN
PROBATION'S HAND TO SPEND THESE
MONEY TO THINK TO SPEND THIS
MONEY TO THINK OF SOLUTIONS TO
HANDLE THE EDUCATION TO HANDLE
THE REENTRY TO HANDLE ALL THE
THINGS WE NEED TO DIVERSIFY THE
POWER AND WE NEED TO DIVERSIFY
THOSE INVESTMENTS BECAUSE THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT CANNOT BE
THE PRIMARY INSTITUTION PROVIDED
, UM, TO MEET THE UNMET NEEDS OF
OUR BLACK AND BROWN YOUNG YOUNG
PEOPLE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
COLLEAGUES ANY INITIAL THOUGHTS
BEFORE WE BRING UP THE REST OF
THE PANEL. SENATOR ROTH. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR I. I WAS I'M
TAKEN BY YOUR REMARKS, MA'AM, I
I'M TRYING TO, YOU KNOW, I CAME
OUT OF THE MILITARY. SO WHAT
GETS MEASURED GETS DONE, AND WE
BELIEVE IN ACCOUNTABILITY AND
PEOPLE BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
SO WHERE DOES THE BUCK STOP
HERE? DOESN'T IT STOP AT THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS? I. I THINK
THE BUCK STOPS WITH BOTH. YEAH
THE PROBATION DEPARTMENT AND THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS APPROVES THE
BUDGET FOR THE PROBATION
DEPARTMENT AND THE AND THE CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICER WORKS FOR
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. I'M I MEAN, I. I
WANNA PIN THE TAIL ON THE RIGHT,
DONKEY. I AGREE WITH YOU, BUT
ALSO RIGHT? I MEAN THE WAY THE
WELFARE AND INSTITUTIONS CODE
LAYS OUT WHO HOLDS THE POWER AND
WHO RUNS THESE FACILITIES.
THAT'S THE PROBATION DEPARTMENT.
SO I THINK THEY GO HAND IN HAND.
YES THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
APPROVE A GREAT DEAL. I MEAN,
THEY'RE ALL MY FRIENDS, SO I
DON'T WANT THEM TO THINK THAT
I'M SPANKING THEM. I MEAN, I'M
APPOINTED BY ONE OF THEM RIGHT
AND MY ABILITY TO GO INSIDE THE
FACILITIES AND SEE WHAT IS
HAPPENING ON A REGULAR BASIS IS
BECAUSE OF MY APPOINTMENT. BUT
I, I ENTIRELY AGREE WITH YOU
THAT THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
PLAY A VERY LARGE ROLE IN WHAT
IS HAPPENING AND WHAT THEY ARE
ALLOWING TO HAPPEN AND WHERE
THEY DECIDE TO MAKE THEIR
INVESTMENTS AND WHAT THEY DECIDE
TO PRIORITIZE. UM BUT I MEAN, WE
ARE ALL RESPONSIBLE, RIGHT? AND
I GUESS JUST ONE QUICK. FOLLOW
UP, I. I GUESS YOU DON'T
DISAGREE THAT IN IN SOME CASES,
SOME YOUTH AT LEAST IN A
TEMPORARY BASIS, UM, NEED TO
SPEND TIME IN A CURER SETTING.
BUT THAT IT'S JUST THE TYPE OF
CARCERAL SETTING THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT. I MEAN,
PERSONALLY, I DON'T THINK ANY I.
I DON'T THINK ANY YOUNG PERSON
BENEFITS FROM BEING IN A CAR
SETTING. YOU ARE ONLY
COMPOUNDING THEIR TRAUMA. YOU'RE
ONLY NORMALIZING WHAT PRISON
LOOKS LIKE THE NUMBER OF YOUNG
FOLKS THAT I'VE TALKED TO
WHETHER THEY'RE IN ON THE IN
THERE FOR A VIOLATION FOR SEVEN
DAYS OR WHETHER THEY ARE IN
THERE FIGHTING THEIR FITNESS FOR
THREE YEARS. CAN SPEAK TO THE
TRAUMA THAT COMES WITH BEING
THERE JUST FOR ONE NIGHT. YOU
KNOW, L, A COUNTY HAS THIS
BEAUTIFUL VISION THAT THEY'VE
LAID OUT CALLED YOUTH JUSTICE
REIMAGINED THAT'S OBVIOUSLY
DIFFICULT TO IMPLEMENT WHEN WE
HAVE WELFARE AND INSTITUTIONS
CODE THAT MANDATES CERTAIN
THINGS BE HELD BY PROBATION. BUT
WHEN WE KEEP YOUNG FOLKS IN
SMALLER SETTINGS WHEN THEY CARED
FOR BY FOLKS WHO DON'T HAVE TO
USE SPRAY WHO DON'T HAVE TO USE
ROOM CONFINEMENT. DON'T HAVE TO
LOCK THE DOOR BEHIND YOU. I
THINK WE CAN EXPECT DIFFERENT
OUTCOMES. ARE THERE EXAMPLES
EITHER IN THE UNITED STATES OR
SOMEWHERE ELSE IN THE WORLD
WHERE OF YOU WHO HAVE COMMITTED
OFFENSES. THAT'S WHY THEY'RE
THERE, PERHAPS MORE SERIOUS
OFFENSES, UM, ARE ARE TREATED IN
A DIFFERENT WAY IN A HOME
SETTING WHERE IT ACTUALLY WORKS,
UH, NEW ZEALAND. UM UH, SOME OF
OUR COLLEAGUES ACTUALLY SPENT
SOME TIME IN NEW ZEALAND. UM,
LOOKING AT THEIR SYSTEM THAT I
THINK, UM IS MUCH MORE DEDICATED
ON THE HEALING OF YOUNG FOLKS
AND RECOGNIZING THE ROLE THAT
THAT PLAYS IN PUBLIC SAFETY.
BECAUSE TO BE QUITE HONEST, WHAT
WE'VE CREATED RIGHT NOW DOES
NOTHING FOR PUBLIC SAFETY. WE'RE
NOT MAKING OUR COMMUNITIES SAFER
BECAUSE WHEN THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
LEAVE, WHICH, UH, YOU KNOW,
FORTUNATELY, MOST OF THEM DO
WHETHER AGAIN IT'S AFTER SEVEN
DAYS OR SEVEN YEARS. UM WE
HAVEN'T DONE MUCH TO ENSURE THAT
THEY'RE NOT GONNA CYCLE RIGHT
BACK INTO THE SYSTEM. VERY
INTERESTING. I REALLY ENJOYED
THE CONVERSATION. I DON'T WANT
TO BELABOR THE POINT, THOUGH,
BUT THANK YOU. AND NEW YORK ALSO
HAS A SMALLER KIND OF LIKE
COMMUNITY BASED, UM, APPROACH.
THANK YOU. THANKS FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. WELL. THAT WAS A. BOTH
YOUR PRESENTATION AND YOUR
CONVERSATION WERE VERY GOOD, AND
THAT SHOULD BE THE BACKGROUND OR
THE FOUNDATION OF UM. BEING ON
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE OVER OUR
èC Dð èC R. MANY SIMILAR
CONVERSATIONS AS FAR AS WHAT'S
THE WHAT'S THE VISION THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE? AND WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ADULTS, AND THE VERY SAME
THING APPLIES BUT LOT WORSE, I
THINK FOR CHILDREN UM AND WHAT
THE. YOU KNOW WHAT? WHAT IS IT
THAT WE REALLY WANT TO DO HERE?
WE WANNA PUNISH. WE WANNA ADD TO
THE PUNISHMENT MAKE IT WORSE. UM
OR HOW DO WE COMPLETELY CHANGE
THIS SYSTEM SO THAT IT'S NOT
ABOUT THE HOW SEVERE CAN THE
PUNISHMENT? UH BE? WE'RE HAVING
THIS DEBATE ABOUT SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT. YOU KNOW HOW MUCH
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT IS? OK UM,
SO ANYWAY, UM. I'D RATHER HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION THAN I THINK A
LOT OF THE DETAILS, UM, THAT WE
HAVE TO UM ASK, BUT I JUST WANNA
ASK MISTER BIRD. IF YOU CAN TALK
ABOUT THE KIND OF TRAINING THAT.
PROBATION OFFICERS RECEIVE, UM.
FOR ESPECIALLY FOR WORKING IN
THE HALLS AND IN THE CAMPS. UM
IS THERE A TRAINING SPECIFIC TO
YOU THAT NEEDED FOR ALL OFFICERS
, AND WE HAVE MAYBE WE GOTTA
CALL IT SOMETHING ELSE. BUT I
KNOW SAN QUENTIN PROJECT IS, YOU
KNOW IS NOW THE CALIFORNIA MODEL
. UH YOU KNOW WHAT? WHAT IS THE
REAL MODEL AND WHAT AND HOW WHAT
KIND OF TRAINING IS TAKING
PLACE? YES I THINK THE, UH,
TRAINING HAS CHANGED OVER THE
YEARS SINCE I'VE COME IN. UH
QUITE NATURALLY WE HAVE WHAT
THEY ACRONYM OF J èC Ó èC,
WHICH IS JUVENILE CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS. TRAINING UM, THAT
GIVES YOU SIX WEEKS OF TRAINING,
UM, TO LEARN HOW TO DEESCALATED.
HOW TO TALK. HOW TO HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THOSE ARE IN
YOUR CUSTODY. ALSO IT DEALS WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY. UM. THAT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY MEET THE NEW S¼ Y Tð
F AS WE BELIEVE. WE BELIEVE, UH
UH, THOSE WHO ARE COMMITTED TO
THE S¼ Y Tð F NEED A HIGHER
LEVEL TRAINING BECAUSE THEY'RE
WHAT WE WOULD CALL MORE
SOPHISTICATED. I HAVE COMMITTED
MORE SERIOUS CRIMES SOMETIME
THAT MENTALITY YOU NEED TO STEP
UP YOUR ABILITY TO DEAL WITH
THEM IN THOSE SETTINGS. UM. I
WILL SAY ALSO THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS WE'VE ALWAYS ADVOCATED
FOR WAS A MODERNIZED TRAINING
CENTER. UH, IF YOU IN L A COUNTY
UH, WE TRAIN IN A DILAPIDATED
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL. THAT EVEN YOU
WOULDN'T PUT ELEMENTARY KIDS IN
AND TRY TO GIVE ADEQUATE
TRAINING. IT DOESN'T HAVE THE
MODERNIZED TECHNOLOGY. UH IT'S
KIND OF DEMORALIZING WHEN YOU GO
THERE JUST TO LISTEN BECAUSE
YOU'RE IN TRAILERS AND, UH,
THINGS OF THAT SORT. SO TRAINING
IS VERY IMPORTANT. UH I BELIEVE
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISOR HAS
FINALLY, UH, GIVEN THE CHIEF THE
ABILITY TO LOOK FOR A NEW
TRAINING CENTER AND MAYBE
TRAINING FROM SOME OF THE
COLLEGES. WE HAVE NOT REACHED
THAT POINT YET BECAUSE WE KEEP
DEALING WITH THE CRITICAL ISSUE
OF STAFFING. UM BUT I ALSO SAY A
LOT OF THE TRAINING THAT WE NEED
TO DEAL WITH JUVENILES COME
RIGHT FROM WHERE YOU COME FROM.
AND WHAT I MEAN BY THAT AGAIN. I
WILL SAY THAT WE COME OUT OF THE
COMMUNITIES. UM I DIDN'T GO TO
BERKELEY. I WENT TO U S¼ èC AND
I MAJORED IN BUSINESS, BUT IT
DIDN'T KEEP ME FROM
UNDERSTANDING HOW TO WORK WITH
THOSE IN MY COMMUNITY THAT I
LIVED IN. AND SO A LOT OF TIMES,
YOU'RE INHERENT TRAINING IS ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT TOOLS
BECAUSE THE YOUTH YOU'RE DEALING
WITH ARE YOUR NEIGHBORS. AND
SOMETIME. UM, I HEARD MR ROTH
TALK ABOUT INCARCERATION IN HIS
QUESTIONING. UH, WHETHER IT'S
VALID OR NOT, THERE'S A THING
CALLED A CREDIBLE MESSENGER.
RIGHT AND WE SAY THEY ARE
CREDIBLE BECAUSE THEY HAVE
EXPERIENCE SO THEY U. THEY USE
THAT TERM TO SAY THAT THEY
EXPERIENCE IN BEING
INCARCERATED. HELPS THEM TO COME
BACK AND TALK TO YOUTH AND HELP
THEM TO AVOID INCARCERATION OR
NOT TO REC. WE HAVE A THING
AMONGST OUR PROBATION OFFICERS
CALLED A èC MESSENGER. AND IT
SIMPLY GOES LIKE THIS. IF I GREW
UP IN THE COMMUNITY THAT I
REPRESENT. AND I GO AND I
ACCOMPLISH SOMETHING IN MY LIFE,
WHETHER IT BE EDUCATION,
VOCATION SKILLS OR WHATEVER. IS
THAT A CREDIBLE MESSENGER TO THE
YOUTH THAT COME INTO OUR
PRESENCE, SO THERE'S A ALL TYPES
OF TRAINING NECESSARY TO KEEP
PEOPLE FROM OUR YOUTH FROM
RECITING. AND I THINK, UH, ONE
OF THE GREATEST EFFECTS THAT WE
HAVE AS PROBATION OFFICERS WHO
HAVE THE DESIRE FOR YEARS TO
MAKE IT AN OCCUPATION, THOUGH
IT'S VERY REWARDING. UH, IS THAT
SELF TRAINING THAT YOU GET FROM
GROWING UP IN YOUR OWN COMMUNITY
? YOU CAN'T LEAVE THAT OUT OF
THE SITUATION. AND LASTLY, I'LL
SAY AFTER 30 YEARS, THINK ABOUT
IT IF I HAD SOMEBODY IN MY
CUSTODY 15 YEARS AGO. THEY ARE
NOW 30. ARE THEY AT 3240 YEARS
OLD AND WE SEE THEM EVERY DAY IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. AND THEY THINK
THE PROBATION OFFICERS, BUT WE
CANNOT PUBLICIZE THAT BECAUSE
MOST PEOPLE THAT COME THROUGH
THE SYSTEM THEY DON'T WANT YOU
TO KNOW THEY CAME THROUGH THE
SYSTEM. THAT'S WHY WE EVEN HAVE
A SPONGE. UH, LAWS THAT TRY TO
KEEP EVERYBODY FROM KNOWING, BUT
I WILL SAY THIS MY WIFE IS
DISABLED. UH AND, UH, SHE WENT
TO A PAIN MANAGEMENT DOCTOR THE
OTHER DAY, AND HE ASKED WHAT DID
YOUR HUSBAND DO? AND SHE SAID
HE'S A PROBATION OFFICER, SHE
SAID. HE SAID, I WOULD LIKE TO
TALK TO HIM BECAUSE I WAS ON
PROBATION WHEN I WAS GROWING UP,
AND NOW I'M A DOCTOR, AND I LIKE
TO SEE IF I CAN FIND A PROBATION
OFFICER WHO CHANGED MY LIFE. SO
I WANT YOU TO KNOW. TRAINING
COMES INHERENT. IT COMES THROUGH
EDUCATION, AND IT COMES FROM THE
, UH, SYSTEMS THAT WE DESIGNED
TO HELP ADVANCE THE TRAINING
THAT WE HAVE. THANK YOU. UM, NÓ
QUESTIONS. JUST SOME THOUGHTS
HERE, UM YOU KNOW, I THINK
SENATOR ROTH WHEN YOU ASKED
ABOUT WHERE THE BUCK STOPS, I
THINK YOU KNOW. YES SPORT IS
SUPER SPORT OF SUPERVISORS OVER
ARCHING BUT FOR EACH PROBATION
OFFICER, YOU KNOW THE B KIND OF
STOPS WITH THEM INDIVIDUALLY,
RIGHT? YOU KNOW YOU SHARED MR
BIRD REGARDING, YOU KNOW, BEFORE
L. A COUNTY WAS LIKE THIS MODEL.
PEOPLE WOULD COME AND LEARN
ABOUT IT. BUT AT THAT VERY SAME
TIME HUNDREDS OF YOUTH WERE
BEING SEXUALLY ASSAULTED. AND WE
ONLY FOUND OUT YEARS LATER. AT
THE TIME. WHERE L A MODEL, THE L
A WAS A GOOD BOTTLE. JUST LAST
YEAR WE SAW ON THE NEWS ABOUT
203 100. PEOPLE FILED A SUIT
AGAINST L, A COUNTY FOR SEXUAL
ASSAULTS. THAT BEING SHORTAGES
HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH THE LAST
MONTH, A PROBATION OFFICER IS
BEING PUT ON LEAVE FOR HOSTING
FIGHT CLUBS AT LOS PADRINO'S.
THERE HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
SHORTENING STAFFS. IF YOU HAVE
LESS STAFF, YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE
THE TIME TO HOST A FIGHT CLUB.
IN FACT, YOU THAT MEANS YOU'RE
BUSY DOING OTHER THINGS THAT
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO DO. YOU SPOKE
ALSO, MISTER BIRD REGARDING
SOMETIMES IT'S NOT IN CORRECT ME
IF I MISUNDERSTOOD THIS NOT AS
IMPORTANT TO CHECK A DOOR
BECAUSE THERE ARE OTHER MORE
PRESSING THINGS. WE HAD A KID
OVERDOSE AT BARRY J BECAUSE THE
PROVA THE P Ó DID NOT CHECK
THEIR DOORS THROUGHOUT THE
NIGHT. SO WHEN I HEAR THESE
COMMENTS LIKE THE THERE'S NÓ
MORE EXCUSES OF STAFFING
SHORTAGES, AND WE SHOULD BE THE
ONLY ENTITY OVERSEEING THIS
YOUTH THAT FOR DECADES WE'VE
ENTRUSTED OUR YOUTH IN THESE IN
THIS ONE PARTICULAR ENTITY. I'M
NOT LOOKING TO DISMANTLE THE
SYSTEM. I'M JUST LOOKING TO SEE
WHAT OTHER SUPPORT WE CAN BRING
INTO THIS SYSTEM TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH PROBATION
OFFICERS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE I THINK I
THINK WE NEED HELP. AND YOU MAY
HAVE A DAUGHTER WHO IS A L èC
S¼ W AND YOU ARE PRIVILEGED
ENOUGH TO HAVE THE INFORMATION
THAT OTHER PEOPLE DON'T HAVE I
AN MSW. I'M PRIVILEGED ENOUGH TO
UNDERSTAND SOCIAL SYSTEMS, BUT
JUST BECAUSE SOMEONE HAS A B A
DOES NOT MEAN OR THEY GET EIGHT
HOURS 16 HOURS OF TRAUMA.
INFORMED CARE TRAUMA, INFORMED
THIS TERM TRAUMA INFORMED HIS
THROWS THROWN AROUND SO LOOSELY
THAT IT HAS NÓ MORE VALUE OF
WHAT TRAUMA INFORMED CARE IS
BECAUSE WE'RE SEEING PROBATION
OFFICERS GETTING MORE TRAINING
AT CAMP KILPATRICK. THAN WE DO
AT BARRY J. WE'RE SEEING
PROBATION OFFICERS WHO ARE JUST
STARTING IN THIS LINE OF WORK.
GET THROWN A LOS PATRINOS KIND
OF LIKE A HAZING. PROCESS WE'RE
GONNA TOUGHEN YOU UP HERE VERSUS
I WOULD LIKE TO START OFF IN A
SOFTER PLACE WHERE I LEARN
ACTUAL WAYS TO COMMUNICATE WITH
THESE YOUTH AND THEN GO TO LOS
LOS PRENOS TO THEN TAKE THAT
WORK WITH ME. SO THOSE ARE MY
INITIAL THOUGHTS. WHEN I'M
HEARING THIS, MS KANI, I THINK
YOUR WORDS ARE GONNA SIT WITH ME
FOREVER. I THINK YOU CANNOT GET
WELL IN A CELL IS SOMETHING THAT
WE SHOULD ALL SIT WITH. SO WE'RE
WE'RE GONNA SAVE THE REST OF OUR
QUESTIONS FOR THE REST OF THE,
UM, AFTER WE'RE DONE WITH THE
NEXT PANEL. SO WE CAN GET SOME
PANEL B UP HERE, PLEASE. JOINING
US HERE ON TOP PANEL B. ARE TWO
INDIVIDUALS WITH PREVIOUS
EXPERIENCE. TONY BROWN, WHO IS
NOW A STUDENT AT CAL POLY POMONA
, WITH LIVED EXPERIENCES AND
MAGIC MCKAY, A STUDENT AT U èC
BERKELEY WITH LIVED EXPERIENCES.
ALONG WITH JUDGE MIGUEL ESPINOZA
FROM L, A JUVENILE COURT.
RISING. RESIGN CROOMS FROM
LOYOLA LAW SCHOOL JUVENILE
JUSTICE CLINIC AND SCOTT BUDNICK
, THE FOUNDER OF ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION, WE'LL START WITH MR
BROWN. IS IT ON ART ARE GOOD.
ALRIGHT, SO FIRST AND FOREMOST
GOOD MORNING TO ALL IN
ATTENDANCE AS WELL AS I WANT TO
SHOW MY GRATITUDE FOR INVITING
ME TO THIS WONDERFUL EVENT. MY
NAME IS TONY BROWN. I'M A CAR
POLY POMONA STUDENT STUDYING
ANIMAL SCIENCE. I AM ALSO A
CHANGE AGENT WITH THE PRISON
EDUCATION PROJECT, WHERE I'LL GO
BACK INTO L, A COUNTY JUVENILE
DETENTION CENTERS AS WELL AS GO
ABROAD TO TEACH INTRO TO COLLEGE
SOFT SKILLS AND CAREER
DEVELOPMENT. I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO MENTION MY SUCCESS IS IN
SPITE OF PROBATION, NOT BECAUSE
OF PROBATION. I CHOSE TO RISE
ABOVE ALL ADVERSITY AND APPROACH
EACH OPPORTUNITY WOULD
DETERMINATION AND AMBITION. I
FIND MY I FOUND MY POTENTIAL
WITHIN A CELL. I WAS DETAINED AT
THE AGE OF 14 WITH A CHARGE OF
MURDER RECENT RE RECENTLY
RELEASED MARCH EIGHTH OF LAST
YEAR AFTER SERVING A 7.5 YEAR
SENTENCE. PROBATION IS ALLOCATED
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN FUNDS
WHERE THEY ARE SET TO MAKE A
PAYMENT PLAN FOR THE YOUTH AND
PROVIDE REHABILITATIVE SERVICES.
AFTER TAKING COUNTLESS HOURS OF
FINDING THIS FUNDING PLAN TO
SEEK AN UNDERSTAND WHY THERE ARE
VERY LITTLE TO NÓ PROGRAMS AND
WHERE THIS MONEY WAS ACTUALLY
GOING WELL, ACCORDING TO THE
FUNDING PLAN FOR S¼ Y Tð F
SERVICES, WHICH CAN BE FOUND
UNDER L, A COUNTY.GOV SO FIRST
AND FOREMOST, I WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK ON THE DOG PROGRAM. YOU
KNOW, LIKE I SAID, I WAS
INCARCERATED AND BARRY J NARDO
FOR SEVEN YEARS. I WAS IN THE
COMPOUND THE WHOLE TIME, YOU
KNOW, VERY TRAUMATIC SITUATION.
IT WAS VERY DETRIMENTAL TO THE
SUCCESS OF YOUTH. VERY TRAUMATIC
AS WELL. YOU KNOW, UM, AND ONE
OF THE BIGGEST THINGS I NOTICED
WAS IT WAS A LACK OF
PROGRAMMING. SO I'M LIKE, OK,
HOW CAN WE BENEFIT AS YOUTH AND
ALSO FIND SOMETHING TO HEAL OUR
TRAUMA OUTSIDE OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES, SO I DECIDED TO WRITE
A PROPOSAL FOR THE DOG. PROGRAM
WHICH BECAME A MANDATORY PROGRAM
IN BARRY J Kò OF JUVENILE HALL,
AS WELL AS CAMPUS KILPATRICK AND
IT STARTED IN LATE 2022, BUT THE
PROGRAM ENDED UP FALLING SHORT
MID OF 2020 THREE AFTER I WAS
RELEASED DUE TO THE
IRRESPONSIBLE USAGE OF THE FUNDS
BY LOS ANGELES COUNTY PROBATION.
AT TIMES I DO FEEL SOCIALLY
DISPLACED DUE TO THE FACT THAT I
SERVED SEVEN YEARS 7.5 IN TOTAL
IF YOU'RE INCLUDING CAMPUS
KILPATRICK INSIDE OF A JUVENILE
DETENTION FACILITY. I FEEL MOST
COMFORTABLE WHEN I WORK AND
TRAIN WITH DOGS DUE TO THE LACK
OF DAILY SOCIETAL DEEDS AND
INTERACTIONS WITH OTHER PEOPLE
THAT WANNA SUCCEED AND GROW LIKE
ME. IN ADDITION TO THAT, WHEN
YOU SPEAK ON EMPLOYMENT THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT. OFFERED
KITCHEN PATROL AS AN EMPLOYMENT
DEED. THERE WAS NÓ OTHER
VOCATIONAL PROGRAMS SUCH AS WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT HAWAII, WHICH I
JUST CAME BACK FROM. AFTER
TEACHING INTRO TO COLLEGE THEY
OFFER WELDING. THEY OFFER THEM
AGRICULTURAL DEEDS, SUCH AS
WORKING IN THEIR FARMS, WORKING
IN THEIR THEIR GARDENS AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE. THEY ALSO
WORK WITH ANIMALS LIKE HORSES.
THEY WANT TO GET A DOG PROGRAM,
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE TO PICK
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING LIKE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY PROBATION DOES.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE SAFETY
FOR THE YOUTH, SO I WAS HOUSED
WHEN S¼ Y Tð F FIRST OPENED IN
THE HOUSING UNIT UNIT X. IT FELT
SO MUCH SIMILAR TO Dð JJ. NOT
THAT I WAS HOUSED IN Dð JJ BY
HEARING ALL THE EVENTS I HAD A
BROTHER THAT WAS INCARCERATED
THERE, BUT AS I WALKED INTO THIS
UNIT WINDOWS WERE BOARDED UP
DOORS WERE BROKEN YOUTH WERE ALL
OVER THE PLACE. GRAFFITI
EVERYWHERE. FIGHTS WOULD BREAK
OUT. I WAS INVOLVED IN A RIOT.
NOT UH, AT MY OWN WILL. I WAS
FORCED INTO THIS RIOT BEING
TARGETED BY OTHER YOUTH. OF
COLLEGE, A VERY SAFE SPACE WHERE
I FELT I CAN AVOID ALL OF THESE
DRUGS FIGHTS JUST GANG VIOLENCE.
AS FROM THERE I WAS ALSO JUMPED
COMING FROM COLLEGE. MENTAL
HEALTH. WE'RE ALSO FRIGHTENED
STOPPED, DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO KEEP
THE SITUATION UNDER CONTROL.
YOUTH ALWAYS HAD THEIR HEADS ON
A SWIVEL WONDERING, AM I GOING
TO BE NEXT? WHO'S GONNA ATTACK
ME? WHAT'S GOING ON? IT WAS VERY
TRAUMATIC. PROGRAMMING WHEN I
TALK ABOUT PROGRAMS, THE MAIN
PROGRAMS I LOOK FORWARD TO MOST
WAS HEALING DIALOGUE AND ACTION,
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION AS
WELL AS INSIDE OUR WRITERS,
WHICH HAS TAUGHT ME HOW TO BE
CREATIVE AND USE. UTILIZE MY
POWER OF WORDS THROUGH THE
POETRY. I WRITE. THESE TWO
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN ACTIVELY
INVOLVED IN THE YOUTH JOURNEYS
BEHIND THE WALLS AND DURING OUR
TRANSITION TO BE PRODUCTIVE
CITIZENS TO OUR COMMUNITIES. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SHOUT OUT TO
EACH MEMBER OF HÌ Dð A FOR THE
OUTINGS AND GREAT EXPERIENCES.
ALSO WANNA EXTEND MY GRATITUDE
TO A R èC FOR THE SAME THING,
BUT FOR ALSO PAYING FOR ME TO GO
TO HAWAII THIS PAST JANUARY, AND
I'M ALSO GOING TO LONDON IN
MARCH. ANOTHER PROGRAM. I WOULD
LIKE TO EXTEND MY GRATITUDE TO
IS MARLEY'S MUCH POSITIVE CHANGE
PROGRAM, WHICH I ALSO HELP WRITE
THE PROPOSAL TO GET THEM IN
THERE AS WELL AS, UH, PARTS FOR
LIFE WITHIN SOME JUVENILE HALL.
THESE PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN VERY
BENEFICIAL FROM FOR LIKE. THESE
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN VERY
BENEFICIAL BECAUSE THEY HAVE
TAUGHT US SKILLS TO BE GREAT
PEOPLE TO LEARN FROM GREAT
REENTRY RESOURCES. AND ONE OF
THE PROGRAMS I'VE BEEN TALKING
TO MANY STAFF ABOUT RE
IMPLEMENTING WAS THE SPORTS
PROGRAM. THIS ALLOWS THE YOUTH
WHO HAVE COME FROM ATHLETIC
BACKGROUNDS, SUCH AS MYSELF WHO
I PLAYED BASKETBALL TO NOW SHOW
THEIR TRUE POTENTIAL AND TALENT
TO POSSIBLY GET RECRUITED BY
COLLEGES. SPORTS CREATE
BROTHERHOOD, SISTERHOOD SE FIVE
FINGERS AND ONE IS THE HAND
TOGETHER. WE COME INTO UNITY,
WHICH CREATES COMMUNITY. WE NEED
TO START IMPLEMENTING BETTER
VOCATIONAL TRAINING. LIKE I SAID
, LIKE WELDING, CONSTRUCTION AND
CULINARY. THESE ARE HANDS ON
SKILLS THAT THE YOUTH CAN BE
TAUGHT AND USED TO HELP BUILD
RESUMES. AGRICULTURE IS ALSO
VERY IMPORTANT. AND CONCLUSION
TO THAT. I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A
CALL OF ACTION THAT BOTH MARY J
ARDOR AND CAMPUS. KILPATRICK
CONTINUE FUNDING BOTH PARTS FOR
LIFE AND POSITIVE CHANGE. LIKE I
SAID, SOMETIMES I FEEL SOCIALLY
DISPLACED EVEN ON A COLLEGE
CAMPUS AT CAL POLY POMONA. I
FEEL SOCIALLY DISPLACED BECAUSE
I WASN'T EXPOSED TO TOO MUCH
POSITIVE INTERACTION WHILE
INCARCERATED. IN ADDITION TO
THAT, I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
EXTEND MY GRATITUDE TO EACH
EMPLOYEE OF THE PROBATION
DEPARTMENT WHO HAS WORKED WITH
ME AND HELPED ME PURSUE MY
DREAMS. THE STUFF THAT
INDIVIDUALLY WORKED WITH THE
YOUTH BY PROBATION CONTINUED TO
HOLD THEM BACK, ONE OF THEM
BEING SENIOR DETENTION OFFICER.
REST IN PEACE. KENDALL GOOD MISS
DIXON, LARONDA, GARY, WILLIAM
SIMPSON, RAFAEL VENTURA, MIRIAM
SMILEY, MICHELLE MEDINA, TIMOTHY
VÀ, MISS COLLINS, MISS AL DEZ, I
THANK YOU ALL. I ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO EXTEND MY GRATITUDE TO MY
ATTORNEY, LIZ BRONSTEIN. THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY. MY
HONORABLE JUDGE MARIO BARRERA. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK MR
MIGUEL ESPINOZA FOR ALSO BEING
IN ATTENDANCE. ANGELA ZARAGOZA.
THANK YOU, SCOTT BUDNICK, EDWIN
PRAGA, ZACH SCOW AND SO MANY
OTHER PEOPLE WITHIN MY JOURNEY.
I JUST HONESTLY WANNA SAY THANK
YOU TO ALL OF THEM. AND I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU AS WELL BOARD
MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING ME THIS
EXPERIENCE. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MR BROWN. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO MR MCCABE. YES UM, HELLO. MY
NAME IS MONTE MAGIC. MCKAY I'M
21 YEARS OLD, CURRENTLY
ATTENDING BURKE U èC BERKELEY
AS A COMPARATIVE LITERATURE AND
FILM MAJOR WHILE MONITORING AND
CREATIVE WRITING. YEAH. WHEN I
WAS 17 YEARS OLD. I WAS ARRESTED
FOR SECOND DEGREE MURDER. AS I
WAS FIGHTING MY FITNESS. I WAS
ALMOST CERTAINLY GOING TO LOSE.
IN TURN, I WOULD HAVE ENDED UP
SPENDING A MAJOR PORTION OF MY
LIFE IN ADULT PRISON.
FORTUNATELY I WAS SAVED BY THE
BELL WITH THE CLOSURE OF Dð JJ
REALIGNMENT. GEORGE GASCONS
ORDERS IN MY TRANSFER TO S¼ Y Tð
F. I WAS PROVIDED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RISE ABOVE MY
SITUATION. MOST PEOPLE FACING
THE PRISON SENTENCE. DON'T GET
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO A PLACE
LIKE CAMP KILPATRICK OR GET THE
SUPPORT OF A NETWORK THAT HELPS
THEM FIND THEIR DREAMS AND THEN
GO ACHIEVE THEM. MY CASE WAS A
VERY SPECIAL ONE. I WAS ABLE TO
SLIP THROUGH THE CRACKS THROUGH
A HIGHLY CIRCUMSTANTIAL AND
EXTREMELY IMPROBABLE STRING OF
EVENTS. IT DOESN'T AND SHOULDN'T
HAVE TO BE THAT WAY FOR
EVERYONE. OUR YOUTH PASSING
THROUGH THE SYSTEM CAN AND
SHOULD BE PROVIDED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE THE SUCCESS
THAT I HAVE. AND THEN SOME THE
SYSTEM SHOULDN'T MAKE IT HARDER
FOR YOU TO HURTLE THE BARRIERS.
IT SHOULD ASSIST IN DIRECTING
PAST THOSE BARRIERS. THE MAIN
REASON I'VE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE
THIS EXCUSE ME THE MAIN REASON
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE THE BEST
OUT OF WHAT I WAS GIVEN WAS
BECAUSE THERE WERE PEOPLE WHO
SAW MY POTENTIAL AND WERE ABLE
TO GUIDE ME. SURE I HAD THE
AMBITION AND THE TRUTH IS, THERE
ARE HUNDREDS OF YOUTH JUST LIKE
ME WHO GET OVERLOOKED AND
UNDERMINED. THESE SYSTEMS AND
INSTITUTIONS. INSTITUTIONS CAN
BE DESIGNED TO PAVE A WAY FOR
HEALING, REHABILITATION AND
PROSPERITY FOR EVERYONE. IT WAS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS IN
CREDIBLE MESSENGERS WHO ASSISTED
ME IN MY JOURNEY WHILE INSIDE IT
WAS JUDGE ESPINOSA WHO
RECOGNIZED MY HARD WORK. IT WAS
RAFAEL VENTURA. IT WAS ELIZABETH
BRONSTEIN, TIMOTHY VAEZ, KEVIN
DE AMICO, ERIC NATIONS AND A FEW
OTHER KING PROBATION OFFICERS
WHO BELIEVED IN ME. IT WAS A
WOMAN NAMED PASTOR NAGA, A
SCHOOL STAFF MEMBER AT CAMP
KILPATRICK, WHO ASSISTED ME WITH
TO APPLYING TO FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY. PAT SPENT HOURS WITH
ME REVISING MY COURSE, PLANS,
APPLYING FOR SCHOLARSHIPS AND
LOOKING FOR RESOURCES TO ENSURE
I WAS WELL EQUIPPED ON MY NEXT
JOURNEY. SHE KEPT ME MOTIVATED
BY REASSURING ME WHEN I SHARED
MY DOUBTS AND ENCOURAGED ME TO
NEVER QUIT WITHOUT HER AND HER
ASSISTANCE. I MIGHT NOT HAVE
RECEIVED MY A DEGREE IN SOCIAL,
SOCIAL AND BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES
OR HAVE BEEN ABLE TO TRANSFER
THE COW. I MIGHT NOT HAVE BEEN
ACCEPTED TO EVERY SINGLE
UNIVERSITY. I APPLIED TO IT WAS
MISTER KAN, WHO WOULD INDULGE ME
IN DISCUSSIONS ABOUT QUANTUM
PHYSICS, PHILOSOPHY, RELIGION,
PSYCHOLOGY, HISTORY, LITERATURE
AND ART BEFORE CLASS STARTED. IT
WAS THOSE CONVERSATIONS THAT
INSPIRED ME TO SEEK HIGHER
EDUCATION. SOME OF THE PEOPLE I
MIGHT HAVE SOME OF THOSE PEOPLE
I MIGHT HAVE NEVER CROSSED PATHS
WITH. HAD I BEEN SENT TO Dð JJ.
HAD I NOT MET THEM. I WOULDN'T
BE IN A POSITION I AM IN TODAY.
IT WAS A R èC THAT HELPED PAY
FOR MY MOTHER'S FUNERAL PROVIDED
ME WITH A SCHOLARSHIP.
CONNECTING ME WITH JOBS, TOOK ME
TO DIFFERENT STATES AND HELPED
ME FIND HOUSING. IT WAS HÌ Dð. A
THAT HELPED ME PROCESS MY
TRAUMAS UNDERSTAND THE EXTENT OF
MY DECISIONS DEVELOP EMOTIONAL
REGULATION. REGULATION AND
CONNECT ME TO MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES UPON RELEASE. IT WAS
ON INSIDE OUT RIDERS THAT HELPED
ME GRASP AND CHANNEL MY PASSIONS
FOR STORYTELLING. IT WAS
JAILHOUSE GUITARS THAT PUSHED ME
TO FIND PEACE IN MUSIC. WITH THE
INDIVIDUALIZED PLANS. EMOTIONAL
INTELLIGENCE ASSIGNED MENTORS,
CAREER TRAINING, A PROPER AND
SUFFICIENT EDUCATION IN
FINANCIAL LITERACY. YOUTH WOULD
BE PREPARED TO RE ENTER THE
COMMUNITY AS MODEL CITIZENS
EVERY DAY. THESE KIDS SHOULD BE
PLANNING TO ENTER THE WORLD. THE
FREE WORLD HIGH ACHIEVING HEALED
AND REHABILITATED ROLE MODELS
FOR THE NEXT GENERATION. THEY
SHOULD NOT LEAVE OUT WORSE THAN
THEY CAME IN, LIKE THE MANY
BEFORE THEM, SURROUNDED BY
VIOLENCE AND DISORDER. MANY WERE
FORCED TO ADAPT TO THEIR
SURROUNDINGS. HOW ABOUT WE
SURROUND THEM AROUND THINGS AND
PEOPLE THAT POSITIVELY INFLUENCE
THEM? UPON RELEASE, MANY WEREN'T
ABLE TO PROPERLY ADJUST TO THE
WORLD AROUND THEM AND REOFFEND
IT. WHY BECAUSE OF A LACK OF
ATTENTION, STRUCTURE, GUIDANCE
AND LOVE. THERE IS NÓ ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH TO ANYTHING.
NOT EVERYONE SHARES THE SAME
STORIES, TALENTS, LIFESTYLES,
AMBITIONS OR UPBRINGING. EACH
YOUTH SHOULD HAVE AN
INDIVIDUALIZED PLAN TAILORED TO
THEIR SPECIFIC NEEDS AND
CONCERNS THESE YOU THESE YOUTH
DESERVE TO BE IN CONDUCIVE
ENVIRONMENTS, PLACES THAT FOSTER
POSITIVITY AND GROWTH SURROUNDED
BY PEOPLE WHO CARE ABOUT THEIR
FUTURE AND WELL BEING, DESPITE
THEIR MISTAKES. GOD. EXCUSE ME.
OH, CONTINUE TO FUND HÌ Dð A.
I'M GONNA SAY HEALING DIALOGUE
AND ACTION. ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION ACTORS GANG INSIDE
OUT. WRITERS PAUSE FOR LIFE.
MARLEY'S MUTTS, JAILHOUSE GUITAR
DOORS AND OTHER COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT FOLLOW
INDIVIDUALS AS THEY ENTER THE
COMMUNITY. HIRE MORE STAFF THAT
CARE ENSURE THE SUCCESS OF EACH
YOUTH, EVEN THE HARD HEADS, EVEN
THE ONES WHO SEEM LIKE LOST
CAUSES. CAN I CURSE? EVEN THE F
UPS BECAUSE EGYPT HAS A STORY TO
TELL AND SOMETHING MEANINGFUL TO
BRING TO SOCIETY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MISTER MCKAY
JUDGE. WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
EVERYONE BEFORE WE AND WITH
MAGIC. I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY
THAT HE HAD A HUGE DAY
YESTERDAY. HIS JOURNEY WITH THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM FORMALLY
ENDED YESTERDAY WHEN HE HAD HIS
CASE SEALED AND THAT IS THE
BIGGEST DAY YOU CAN HAVE.
CONGRATULATIONS. MAGIC AND TONY.
IT'S AN HONOR TO BE SEATED UP
HERE WITH YOU TODAY. MY NAME IS
MIGUEL ESPINOSA AND I'M THE
SUPERVISING JUDGE OF THE 14
JUVENILE JUSTICE COURTS IN L, A
COUNTY FOR THE PAST TWO YEARS,
I'VE ALSO SUPERVISED ONE OF FOUR
S¼ Y Tð F HUB COURTS PRIOR TO MY
APPOINTMENT. I WAS A LOCAL
PROSECUTOR WITH THE Dð, A S¼
OFFICE AND ALSO AN ASSISTANT
UNITED STATES ATTORNEY. THANK
YOU SENATORS FOR HAVING ME. I
HAVE TO SAY YOUR STAFF ARE
EXCELLENT THEY HAVE. I'VE NEVER
TESTIFIED BEFORE, AND THEY MADE
THIS A VERY SEAMLESS EXPERIENCE.
AND SO I'D REALLY LIKE TO THANK
THEM FOR THAT. SENATOR DROSS IN
A PAST LIFE. I WAS A LONGTIME
AIDE TO MAYOR VILLARAIGOSA. AND
THERE'S NÓ REASON YOU WOULD
REMEMBER THIS. BUT MORE THAN 20
YEARS AGO, I ENDED UP AT YOUR
HOUSE. THIS WAS WHILE MR
CONTRERAS WAS STILL WITH US, AND
I WAS A YOUNG STAFFER AND I SAT
BACK AND I LISTENED TO YOU
ENGAGE ABOUT HOW TO IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF WORKING FAMILIES ON THE
EAST SIDE, AND THAT HAD A HUGE
IMPACT ON ME. IT'S ONE OF THE
MAIN REASONS THAT I JOINED A
UNION SIDE LABOR LAW FIRM WHEN I
FIRST WAS ENTERING THE LAW, AND
I COME FROM A FAMILY OF UNION
MEMBERS, MOSTLY TEACHERS. AND
NURSES AND I WAS A MEMBER OF A
UNION MYSELF. THANK YOU FOR
EVERYTHING THAT YOU DO. OF THE
VARIOUS ISSUES BEING DISCUSSED.
TODAY I'LL START WITH ONE THAT
BRINGS ME OPTIMISM. ALMOST
EXACTLY. ONE YEAR AGO, WE BEGAN
TRANSFERRING YOUTH FROM Dð JJ TO
L A COUNTY. I PERSONALLY OVERSAW
THIS LITIGATION. THROUGHOUT THE
PAST YEAR, THE COURT HAS FORGED
A STRONG PARTNERSHIP WITH THE DA
DEFENSE BAR AND PROBATION AS WE
DETERMINED THE MOST APPROPRIATE
PLACEMENT FOR THE APPROXIMATELY
100 YOUTH WHO HAD EITHER NOT YET
COMPLETED THEIR BASELINE TERMS
AT Dð JJ OR HAD RECENTLY
RE-ENTERED THE COMMUNITY. THIS
WAS AN IMMENSELY CHALLENGING
EXPERIENCE, BUT IT IS RESULT. IN
ONE OF THE MOST COLLABORATIVE
AND TRAUMA INFORMED. TRULY, I
BELIEVE TRAUMA INFORMED
PARTNERSHIPS. THAT I HAVE SEEN
DURING MY 15 YEARS WORKING IN
CRIMINAL JUSTICE. OVER THE PAST
YEAR. I'VE TRAVELED TO STAY WITH
OUR PARTNERS, INCLUDING SOME OF
YOUR STAFF MEMBERS DOWN IN LOS
ANGELES TO DEVELOP AND
STRENGTHEN RELATIONSHIPS WITH
SUBJECT MATTER. EXPERTS IN YOUTH
REHABILITATION LIKE THE
NATIONALLY RENOWNED ANTI RECTIV
COALITION, FOUNDED BY SCOTT
BUDNICK, I, I THINK THERE IS NÓ
SINGLE PERSON WHO HAS HAD A
GREATER IMPACT, PROBABLY ON
YOUTH REHABILITATION THAN MR
BUDNICK. SEVERAL OF OUR PARTNER
ORGANIZATIONS OFFER LESS
RESTRICTIVE PLACEMENTS WHERE
YOUTH RESIDE AND RECEIVE
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. ARCS
MAGNOLIA HOUSE IS THE GOLD
STANDARD IN THIS SPACE, AND WE
HAVE KEPT THOSE BEDS FULL. AND
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF SUCCESS, MUCH
OF IT POSSIBLE THROUGH THE
SUPPORT OF JUDGE LUCERO AND HER
TEAM. THANK YOU, JUDGE LARO FOR
YOUR STRONG SUPPORT ON A WEEKLY
BASIS. MAGIC AND TONY ARE TWO
SHINING EXAMPLES OF HOW WELL
YOUTH CAN DO WHEN SUPPORTED IN
THE COMMUNITY. BOTH OF THESE
YOUNG MEN WERE AT PLACEMENTS IN
L, A COUNTY THE MODEL THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED FOR Dð JJ YOUTH HAS
BEEN SO PROMISING THAT IT HAS
PROVIDED A ROADMAP FOR S¼ Y Tð F
YOUTH, MANY OF WHOM ARE NOW
LIVING AT THESE SAME LESS
RESTRICTIVE PLACEMENTS AND
THRIVING THE COLLABORATION IN
OUR COURT HAS ALSO BEEN SO
FORWARD THINKING, IN FACT, THAT
THE LAWYERS WHO COMPRISE OUR S¼
Y Tð F TEAM, AS JUDGE LARO
REFERENCED HAVE BEEN AWARDED AN
Ó IR GRANT TO TRAIN SIMILAR
TEAMS ACROSS THE STATE. MAOA AND
MS BRONSTEIN ARE TWO OF THOSE
ATTORNEYS AND THEY'RE HERE WITH
US TODAY. THESE PLACEMENTS HAVE
GIVEN US GREAT REASON FOR
OPTIMISM. BUT REALIGNMENT HAS
ALSO EXACERBATED THE SINGLE
GREATEST THREAT TO OUR YOUTH.
OUR CASE LOADS HAVE INCREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY DUE TO REALIGNMENT
, INCLUDING DOZENS OF S¼ TF
TRANSFER HERE. EXCUSE ME, S¼ Y
Tð F HEARINGS EACH WEEK. THIS
ADDS TO AN ALREADY BUSY DOCKET
IN WHICH THE COURT MAKES
THOUSANDS OF DECISIONS EACH YEAR
DIRECTLY IMPACTING THE LIBERTY
OF OUR KIDS. MOST OF THE
PRESSING ISSUES DISCUSSED HERE
TODAY ARE SUBJECT TO LITIGATION
IN A COURTROOM WHERE THE COURT
ULTIMATELY RENDERS A DECISION
THAT IS SUBJECT TO APPELLATE
REVIEW DECISIONS TO REMOVE
CHILDREN FROM THEIR HOMES,
DECISIONS TO ADDRESS VIOLENCE,
USE OF FORCE AND CONTRABAND IN
THE HALL. DECISIONS REGARDING
ACCESS TO EDUCATION AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. DECISIONS TO
FIND YOUTH COMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL DECISIONS TO TRANSFER
YOUTH TO ADULT COURT WHERE IF
THEY'RE CONVICTED IN THE ADULT
COURT, THEY MAY SPEND THE REST
OF THEIR LIVES IN PRISON.
TESTIMONY FROM FAMILIES OF
MURDER VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT. HARD TO IMAGINE
MORE WEIGHTY LITIGATION HARDER
STILL TO IMAGINE ENGAGING IN
SUCH LITIGATION WITHOUT A
TRANSCRIPT OF THE PROCEEDINGS,
LEAVING OUR YOUTH WITH NÓ
RECOURSE TO CHALLENGE THESE
FATEFUL DECISIONS. YET THAT
UNCONSCIONABLE SCENARIO IS
NEARLY UPON US SENATORS. LAST
YEAR BECAUSE OF THE ONGOING
COURT REPORTER SHORTAGE. MORE
THAN THREE 130,000 HEARINGS TOOK
PLACE IN L, A COUNTY WITHOUT ANY
TRANSCRIPT, RENDERING APPEAL
IMPOSSIBLE. THESE HEARINGS
INVOLVE LIFE CHANGING ISSUES
SUCH AS DIVORCE, CHILD CUSTODY
AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. THIS IS A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS AND IT'S
COMING FOR OUR KIDS THIS TIME
LAST YEAR, OUR PRESIDING JUDGE
AND EXECUTIVE OFFICER LEVERAGED
NEARLY 10 MILLION IN STATE
FUNDING TO ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE.
THE COURT LATER SUBSTANTIALLY
INCREASED RECRUITMENT AND RETAIN
BONUSES, INCLUDING A $1000
SIGNING BONUS, GENEROUS STUDENT
LOAN AND EQUIPMENT ALLOWANCES UP
TO $10,000 IN RETENTION BONUSES
IN A $25,000 FINDERS FEE FOR
COURT EMPLOYEES WHO BRING COURT
REPORTERS TO THE COURT. THESE
ABUNDANT OUTLAYS OF CASH HAVE
BARELY ALLOWED THE COURT TO
MAINTAIN ITS CURRENT REPORTER
STAFFING SINCE THE COURT
ANNOUNCED ITS INCENTIVES. LAST
YEAR, 18 COURT REPORTERS HAD
LEFT COURT SERVICE IN 11 HAVE
JOINED, RESULTING IN A NET LOSS
OF SEVEN AS OF DECEMBER. DESPITE
SPENDING MILLIONS. OUR COURT
STILL HAS A VACANCY RATE OF OVER
100 COURT REPORTERS S¼ B 662,
RECENTLY HELD IN THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WOULD
HAVE ADDRESSED THIS CRISIS BY
PROVIDING FOR ELECTRONIC
RECORDINGS IN CERTAIN CASE TYPES
, INCLUDING CIVIL BUT ONLY WHEN
A COURT REPORTER IS NOT
AVAILABLE. WITH YOUR FOCUS ON
PUBLIC SAFETY AND THE JUDICIARY
AND YOUR OVERSIGHT OF
REALIGNMENT. I FELT COMPELLED TO
MENTION THIS THE DETRIMENTAL
IMPACT. THIS ISSUE CONTINUES TO
HAVE ON ACCESS TO JUSTICE UP AND
DOWN THE STATE. I MAKE THIS
REQUEST ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY AND THE THOUSANDS OF
CHILDREN WHO RELY ON THE WISDOM
OF BODIES SUCH AS THIS TO ENSURE
THEY ARE AFFORDED BASIC LEGAL
PROTECTIONS, LIKE A TRANSCRIPT
OF THEIR PROCEEDINGS. THERE IS
NÓ GREATER SINGLE THREAT TO OUR
YOUTH, IN MY ESTIMATION THAN THE
COURT REPORTER CRISIS BECAUSE IT
DIRECTLY IMPACTS OUR TO ADDRESS
EACH OF THE OTHER VERY URGENT
ISSUES THAT WE ARE DISCUSSING
HERE TODAY. THAT CONCLUDES MY
PREPARED REMARKS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD MORNING
SENATORS AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS ROSEANNE
REMS. AND I'M CAN YOU AND I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH THE CENTER FOR
JUVENILE LAW AND POLICY,
JUVENILE JUSTICE CLINIC. I'M
HERE AS A JUVENILE ATTORNEY TO
SPEAK ABOUT LOS ANGELES
REALIGNMENT AND THE EXPERIENCES
MY CLIENTS AND COLLEAGUES HAVE
HAD SINCE THE TRANSITION. ON THE
MORNING OF MAY, 9TH 2020 THREE,
I RECEIVED A FRANTIC CALL FROM A
CLIENT OF MINE. PRIOR TO ANY
NEWS ARTICLES, REPORTS THAT
WOULD LATER BE WRITTEN. HE TOLD
ME THAT AN S¼ Y TF YOUTH HAD
BEEN FOUND DEAD THAT MORNING AT
BARRY JAY. HE INFORMED ME THAT
THIS BOY HAD DIED FROM AN
OVERDOSE AND DUE TO STAFFING
OVERSIGHT WAS NOT FOUND IN TIME
TO SAVE HIS LIFE. MY CLIENT KNEW
THESE DETAILS BECAUSE THE TRAGIC
AND AVOIDABLE DEATH OF BRIAN
DIAZ OCCURRED IN HIS UNIT. UPON
LEARNING THIS INFORMATION. WE
IMMEDIATELY FILED TO HAVE OUR
CLIENTS RELEASE FROM S¼ Y Tð F.
AND PLACE IN A STEP DOWN
FACILITY, STEP DOWN FACILITIES
THAT WE CLICK QUICKLY LEARNED
DID NOT EXIST. ON THE DEEDS OF
THE HEARINGS. OUR CLIENTS PLEDGE
THE JUDGES TO LET THEM OUT. TO
SAY THEY WERE TERRIFIED IS AN
UNDERSTATEMENT. AND THEY'RE
PLEASED. THEY SAID THAT THEY
DIDN'T FEEL SAFE AND THAT THEY
WERE AFRAID. THEY WERE SCARED
THAT NÓ MATTER WHAT THE KIDS
SAID ABOUT THE CONDITIONS,
PEOPLE WOULDN'T LISTEN. THEY
WERE SCARED THAT THE LACK OF
OVERSIGHT WOULD MEAN THAT THEY
WOULDN'T MAKE IT OUT OF THE
FACILITY ALIVE AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY, THEY WERE SCARED
THAT THEY WOULD BE NEXT. I
RECALL A YOUNG PERSON, OFTEN
RAISING THEIR VOICE DURING
HEARINGS. BEGGING FOR THE COURT
TO LISTEN TO WHAT WAS REALLY
GOING ON AT BARRY J. YOU TALKED
ABOUT CHILDREN SOILING
THEMSELVES OR USING WATER
BOTTLES TO URINATE AT NIGHT
BECAUSE STAPH IS NOT PRESENT TO
OPEN TO OPEN THE DOORS. THEY
TALKED ABOUT MULTIPLE OCCASIONS
OF YOUNG PEOPLE BEING INJURED
WITHOUT AID FROM STAFF. THEY
TALKED ABOUT THE LACK OF OUTSIDE
TIME AND HOW KIDS WERE LOCKED IN
THE DAY ROOM FOR COUNTLESS
HOURS, UNABLE TO SIMPLY STRETCH
THEIR LEGS. THEY ALSO TALKED
ABOUT THE LACK OF SCHOOLING AND
SERVICES PROVIDED IN S¼ Y Tð F
AND HOW ALL THEY RECEIVED WAS
PACKET LEARNING AND INCONSISTENT
ACCESS TO EDUCATION OR
EDUCATORS, FOR THAT MATTER. AND
HOW THERE WAS MINIMAL ABILITY TO
DO WELL IN PROGRAMMING SINCE
THERE WAS LIMITED PROGRAMMING
AVAILABLE. OVER THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS. WE FILED EVERY ORDER WE
COULD THINK OF, INCLUDING ORDERS
TO SIMPLY ALLOW OUR CLIENTS TO
GO OUTSIDE AND SEE THE SUN. ALL
ORDERS THAT WERE GRANTED BY THE
COURT. AND ALL ORDERS THAT WERE
IGNORED BY THE DEPARTMENT. I
WISH I COULD SAY THAT THIS WAS
THE END OF THE PROBLEMS. YOUNG
PEOPLE EXPERIENCE. WHILE
DETAINED IN S¼ Y Tð F, BUT IT
ISN'T MANY HAVE GONE THROUGH
PERIODS OF CASE AND COURT
DISRUPTIONS. SOME DUE TO
PROBATION OFFICER SUSPENSIONS,
INCLUDING ALLEGATIONS OF
OFFICERS DISTRIBUTING FENTANYL
LACED DRUGS TO DETAIN KIDS. SOME
DUE TO PROBATIONS MODIFIED DUTY
ASSIGNMENTS WHERE STAFF SHOW UP
TO S¼ Y Tð F BUT HAVE NÓ
INTERACTION WITH YOUNG PEOPLE
DETAINED. AND ALMOST ALL DUE TO
THE LACK OF STEP DOWN OR REENTRY
PLANNING WHERE THE ONUS IS 100%
ON DEFENSE ATTORNEYS TO FIND
SERVICES FIND ADEQUATE HOUSING.
MAKE SURE THEY'RE SCHOOLING IS
IN PLACE WHEN THEY RAN HER MAKE
SURE THERAPY IS IN PLACE AND
ABOVE ALL, TO MAKE SURE THERE'S
AN ABILITY FOR THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE TO SUCCEED OUTSIDE OF
DETENTION. FOLLOWING THE TRAGIC
DEATH OF BRIAN DIAZ, WHO WAS
DETAINED IN S¼ Y Tð F, THIS
FACILITY WAS DEEMED UNSUITABLE.
ON THE JUVENILE HALL SIDE. ALL
YOUTH REMOVED EXCEPT FOR THE S¼
TF YOUTH. YOUTH WHO TO THIS DAY
ARE STILL DEALING WITH THE
TRAUMA THAT COMES FROM SEEING,
UH SOMEONE SO YOUNG, DECEASED IN
THE PLACE THEY LIVE LAY THEIR
HEAD DOWN AT NIGHT. SO WHEN I
THINK ABOUT THE PROBLEMS OR
FAILURES THAT PERSIST, THE
COMMON THREAD IS THAT THERE'S
JUST NÓ TRUE DESIRE BY THE
DEPARTMENT TO REHABILITATE THESE
YOUTH. THEIR LIVES ARE NOT
VALUED. THEIR POTENTIAL IS NOT A
PRIORITY. YES, THERE ARE A
HANDFUL OF STAFF WHO TAKE
SERIOUSLY THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
THE CARE OF THESE YOUNG PEOPLE.
BUT EVEN THEY ARE SO OVERWHELMED
THAT THEY CANNOT KEEP UP. THESE
INSTANCES ARE NOT ISOLATED AND
ARE REPRESENTATIVE OF THE LARGER
ISSUE, WHICH IS OUR RELIANCE ON
THE DEPARTMENT TO SERVE OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE WHEN THEY CANNOT
ACHIEVE THE BARE MINIMUM. THE
GOAL OF S¼ B 82 THREE WAS TO
REDUCE RELIANCE ON INCARCERATION
AND EXPAND COMMUNITY BASED
OPTIONS FOR USE. THIS GOAL CAN
ABSOLUTELY BE ACHIEVED BY MAKING
A FUNDAMENTAL SHIFT IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND INVESTING IN
COMMUNITY SERVICES SERVICES THAT
ARE NOT PROBATION, LED AND ALLOW
FOR COMMUNITY BASED STEP DOWNS,
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOU TO PURSUE
A HIGHER EDUCATION OR LEARN
SKILLS THAT WILL LEAD TO
EMPLOYMENT AND A DEDICATED
LIVING WAGE FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
UPON TERMINATION OF S¼ Y Tð F.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN
FROM WHAT IS HAPPENING IN LOS
ANGELES AND MOO JU NOW JUSTICE
TOWARD A REHABILITATIVE TRAUMA,
INFORMED AND DEVELOPMENT,
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
SYSTEM, BUT WE CANNOT DO THAT BY
THROWING MONEY TOWARDS THE WRONG
UNCHECKED DEPARTMENTS. OR AS MY
COLLEAGUE MILLIE HAD SAID THE
WORST RETURN ON INVESTMENT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OUR FINAL PANEL IS IN THIS
PANEL. SCOTT. HØI THIS AFTERNOON
. SENATORS UM THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME. UM I'M ON THE B S¼ E
èC. I'M RECUSED FROM THE L A
VOTE SO I CAN SPEAK OPENLY, NOT
AS A B èC MEMBER AND NOT ON
BEHALF OF A R èC. BUT SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF MYSELF WHO HAVE
BEEN IN THESE JUVENILE HALLS IN
BARRY JANE E EVERY WEEK FOR 20
YEARS, MY 20 YEAR ANNIVERSARY
WAS LAST WEEK. I GOT TO WATCH
THESE TWO FINE GENTLEMEN, UH,
EVERY WEEK OF THEIR GROWTH WHILE
THEY WERE IN THERE, AND IT WAS,
IT WAS INSANELY IMPRESSIVE TO
WATCH. RIGHT NOW, WHAT WE HAVE
TODAY IN L, A IN SF I CANNOT SAY
IS ANY BETTER THAN THE FAILURE
OF Dð JJ. UM, NOT FOR
REHABILITATION. NOT FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY. NOT FOR THE HEALING OF
VICTIMS. AND DEFINITELY NOT FOR
THE TRANSFORMATION AND CHANGE OF
THE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT ARE THERE.
UM JUST TO GIVE YOU AN OVERVIEW
OF WHERE WE'RE AT IN LOS ANGELES
CURRENTLY TODAY AT BARRY J
NEIDORF, WHICH IS THE MAIN S¼ Y
Tð F HUB, THERE'S 54 YOUTH. WHEN
I STARTED THERE, THERE WERE 600.
THERE'S 54 YOUTH. S¼ Y Tð F
YOUTH IN BARRY JANE I JUVENILE
HALL. THERE'S 20 IN CAMP
KILPATRICK. AND THERE'S SIX AT
PINE GROVE, WHICH IS RUN BY èC
Dð èC R, WHICH IS THE FIRE
CAMP. UM SO IN ALL OF S¼ Y Tð F,
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT 80. YOUNG
PEOPLE. UM COMPARE THAT TO THE
THREE 100 PREDISPOSE YOUTH.
THEY'RE SITTING IN LOS PADRINO
RIGHT NOW AND BECAUSE OF ALL OF
THOSE ISSUES, THE DEPARTMENT'S
FOCUS IS ALMOST ALL IN LOS
PADNOS, AND WE REALLY DON'T SEE
MUCH OF UPPER MANAGEMENT AT
BARRY J, WHERE THE S¼ Y Tð F
POPULATION IS ALL BECAUSE
THERE'S SO MANY FIRES TO BE PUT
OUT. AT LP, UM, GIVING YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF THE HISTORY. 2022
EARLY 2020 THREE START OF S¼ Y
Tð F. THE CONDITIONS WERE
ABYSMAL IS AN UNDERSTATEMENT.
INCREDIBLY HIGH AMOUNTS OF
VIOLENCE AND STAFF ASSAULTS. NÓ
PROGRAMS. LITERALLY THESE GUYS
CAN ATTEST THE FACT THAT THEY
MADE IT OUT OF UNIT X AND DIDN'T
DIE OR WEREN'T HURT. VERY BAD IS
A MIRACLE THEY WOULD SIT IN THE
DAY THEY WAKE UP AT EIGHT IN THE
MORNING AND SIT IN THE DAY ROOM,
PLAYING VIDEO GAMES AND WATCHING
Tð VÆ UNTIL THEY WENT TO BED AT
NINE O'CLOCK AT NIGHT. NEVER
GOING OUTSIDE, NEVER GOING TO
SCHOOL, NEVER GOING ANYWHERE. UM
THERE WERE NÓ PROGRAMS, UM WHILE
IN THOSE THAT YEAR, AN X THERE
WERE PROBABLY EIGHT STAFF WALKED
OUT FOR BRINGING IN DRUGS OR
HAVING SEX WITH MINORS. UM AND
THEN MY MENTEE BRIAN DIAZ DIED.
UM FROM A FENTANYL OVERDOSE. AND
THE DAY BEFORE HE DIED. I WALKED
INTO UNIX WAS WONDERING WHERE A
LOT OF THE KIDS WERE. THERE WERE
TWO STAFF SITTING IN THE DAY
ROOM THAT I'D NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
I STARTED PUSHING DOORS OPEN.
ALL THE DOORS WERE SUPPOSED TO
BE LOCKED, AND THERE'S SIX KIDS
IN ONE ROOM. WITH A BUNCH OF
PILLS CUT UP SNIFFING PILLS WITH
A TWO STEP SITTING IN THE DAY
ROOM AND THEN WALK TO THE
BATHROOM. THERE'S FOUR KIDS IN
THE BATHROOM. IT'S ONLY SUPPOSED
TO BE ONE PERSON IN THE BATHROOM
AT A TIME. THERE'S FOUR YOUTH IN
THE BATHROOM, SMOKING WEED
TOGETHER AND WE HAVE TWO STAFF
IN THE DAY ROOM, ONE SENIOR IN
THE MIDDLE AND A STAFF MEMBER ON
THE OTHER SIDE, ALL WHO HAD
STARTED WORK IN L, A COUNTY
PROBATION TWO WEEKS PRIOR. THEY
WERE TERRIFIED. I STOPPED THE
GUYS FROM SNIFFING THE PILLS. I
REPORTED IT TO STAFF IN THE NEXT
DAY. WE GOT THE CALL AT SEVEN IN
THE MORNING THAT THAT 18 YEAR
OLD BRIAN DIAZ WAS FOUND DEAD IN
HIS CELL. THAT'S THE HISTORY
HERE, UM FEW MONTHS AGO. 456
MONTHS AGO, ALL THE
PREDISPOSITION YOUTH WERE MOVED
TO LP, AND SO INSTEAD OF RUNNING
A 300 PERSON FACILITY AT BARRY
JANE NEIDORF THERE'S NOW A 54
PERSON FACILITY. CONDITIONS ARE
BETTER. ARE THEY BETTER THAN Dð
JJ? I CAN'T SAY THAT. BUT
THEY'RE BETTER. THERE'S A NEW
MANAGEMENT TEAM. THAT'S THERE
THAT HAVE MADE THINGS BETTER.
BUT IF WE LOOK AT WHAT WORKED
AND DIDN'T WORK IN Dð JJ AND
WHAT'S WORKING AND NOT WORKING
IN S¼ Y Tð F. I THINK IT'S VERY
CLEAR. UM THE STAFFING SHORTAGE
AFFECTS EVERYTHING. EVEN IF WE
HAD PROGRAMS, THE ABILITY TO
ESCORT YOUTH TO PROGRAMS. WHEN
ONLY 11% OF STAFF ARE SHOWING UP
TO WORK. THAT SOMETIMES BECOMES
IMPOSSIBLE SO THE PROGRAM COULD
BE THERE BUT TO GET THEM FROM
THE UNIT TO THE CHAPEL OR THE
UNIT TO A CLASSROOM CAN'T HAPPEN
BECAUSE THERE'S NÓ STAFF. DO THE
ESCORT, BUT I WILL SAY ONE
MASSIVE DIFFERENCE THAT WE HAVE
IN L. A PROBATION THAN Dð. JJ IS
IF YOU ASK ANY KID THAT WAS IN
Dð JJ. WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE
STAFF CARED ABOUT YOU. YOU'LL
NEVER HEAR MORE THAN 5. EVEN THE
BEST KIDS WHO PROGRAM THE BEST
THEY WOULD SAY, AND Dð JJ, ONLY
5% OF THE STAFF CARED ABOUT US.
AND IF WE ALL KNOW THAT PEOPLE'S
LIVES CHANGE BECAUSE OF THE
HUMAN BEINGS THAT ARE IN THEIR
LIFE, RIGHT? L, A COUNTY
PROBATION. THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
SHOWING UP TO WORK EVERY DAY.
ARE UNBELIEVABLE. FOR THE MOST
PART. THEY ARE GREAT. UM.
THEY'VE WEEDED OUT A LOT OF
REALLY BAD PEOPLE WHO HAVE
WEEDED OUT THEMSELVES. THERE'S
STILL SOME BAD APPLES. BUT
OVERALL AS THESE GUYS HAVE
MENTIONED SOME STAFF, THERE'S
SOME VERY GOOD STAFF THERE. BUT
THE SHORTAGE OF STAFF MUCH
BETTER THAN Dð JJ STAFF. WISE
QUALITY WISE, CARING WISE HOPE
WISE, BUT THE STAFFING NUMBERS
ARE HORRIBLE. PROGRAMS WAY BELOW
Dð JJ LEVELS AND Dð JJ YOU GO TO
THE COMPUTER CODING AT THE LAST
MILE, YOU CAN GET A
CONSTRUCTION, VOCATIONAL CLASS
CULINARY VOCATIONAL CLASS. I CAN
KEEP GOING ON AND ON AND ON
BECAUSE OF IT'S A FACILITY THAT
WAS BUILT FOR THAT. LOTS OF
SPACE, ETCETERA HERE. NOTHING
JUST LIKE YOU, SAID SENATOR
MENJIVAR, EMPTY CULINARY
TRAINING SCHOOL KITCHEN IN
KILPATRICK. EMPTY UM, WOOD SHOP
ECHO PATRICK. EMPTY VOGUE SPACE
AT BARRY J NEIDORF. NOTHING
HAPPENING. UM, NOTHING TO
PREPARE THESE FOR WHEN THEY WALK
OUT THE DOOR. THERE ARE COLLEGE
CLASSES, AND THERE ARE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE FOLLOWED THE
TRAILBLAZER OF TONY BROWN AND
MONTY MCKAY AND GETTING THEIR A
DEGREE THERE. UM ONE ISSUE THAT
HASN'T BEEN BROUGHT UP TODAY. IS
THAT IN Dð JJ YOU TO GET OUT?
YOU WENT TO A PAROLE BOARD AND
IT WAS CLEAR WHAT YOU NEEDED TO
DO TO GET THROUGH THAT BOARD
HERE. THERE IS NÓ TRANSPARENCY
AND ME AND JUDGE ESPINOSA HAD
THIS CONVERSATION THIS MORNING
AND I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
FEELING THIS WAY. THERE'S A LOT
OF LACK OF TRANSPARENCY IN WHAT
THE STEP DOWN, STEP OUT PROCESS
IS AND I DON'T KNOW ANY OTHER
COUNTY OTHER THAN L A. BUT I'M
SURE DIFFERENT COUNTIES ARE
DOING DIFFERENT THINGS ABOUT HOW
AND WHEN TO CHOOSE WHEN A YOUTH
READY TO STEP DOWN OUT OF THE
FACILITY. Dð JJ, ONE OF Dð J J'S
ONLY BRIGHT SPOTS WAS THEIR SEX
OFFENDER BEHAVIOR TREATMENT.
THEY ARE ONE OF THE BEST IN THE
NATION. L A COUNTY PROBATION HAS
ZERO. IF YOU'RE A SEX OFFENDER
IN L, A COUNTY PROBATION, YOU
GET ZERO TREATMENT THE ENTIRE
TIME AND YOU GET OUT WITH ZERO
TREATMENT. NOTHING. ZERO. AND SO
JUST AS TO CONCLUDE WITH SOME
SOME POTENTIAL THOUGHTS,
RECOMMENDATIONS, THINGS TO THINK
ABOUT, UM ONE I ARE THERE.
PROGRAMS THAT CAN BE RUN. NOT BY
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS. MAY BE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS MAY BE RUN BY A èC
B NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THERAPY
, MENTAL HEALTH ORGANIZATION,
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ORGANIZATION,
ETCETERA. TWO. WHEN YOU LOOK AT
PROGRAMS LIKE PINE GROVE, WHICH
IS NOT RUN BY, UH L, A COUNTY
PROBATION. I SEE EVERYTHING IN
THE WORLD. I'VE NEVER SEEN A
VOCATIONAL TRAINING PROGRAM
BETTER THAN THE PINE GROVE FIRE
CAMP THAT LEADS TO A FIREFIGHTER
CAREER IN CAL FIRE. OR IF YOU
DON'T DECIDE TO PURSUE THAT PATH
GIVES YOU THE DISCIPLINE AND THE
BELIEF IN YOURSELF THAT YOU CAN
ACCOMPLISH ANYTHING THAT YOU
WILL ACCOMPLISH WHATEVER YOU DO
WHEN YOU GET OUT. THAT'S WHY THE
RECIDIVISM RATE IS SO MUCH
LOWER. YOU CAN WE HAVE MORE
STATEWIDE PROGRAMS LIKE PINE
GROVE SEND YOU TWO MORE VICTIMS
AND RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PROGRAMS
TO HELP VICTIMS HEAL FROM THESE
CRIMES AND ALSO MAKE SURE THESE
GUYS UNDERSTAND THE PAIN THAT
THEY'VE CAUSED. SO THEY NEVER
WANT TO CAUSE IT AGAIN AND
AGAIN, FIGURING OUT CLARITY AND
TRANSPARENCY AROUND THE STEP
DOWN. RE ENTRY PROCESS. THANK
YOU. YES I AGREE WITH YOU,
SENATOR RAZZO BIG BIG BUT IN, UM
. ANY INITIAL THOUGHTS. IF NOT,
I'M GONNA JUMP IN SOME
QUESTIONS. OK? UM JUDGE AS WELL.
I WAS LIKE YOU BREAK TO BREAK
DOWN THE PROCESS DOES A YOUTH
BEFORE THEY GET DOWN TO A STEP
DOWN FACILITY? THE ONES THAT
EXIST THERE. DO THEY HAVE TO
COME BACK TO THE COURT TO GET
APPROVAL FOR THAT? IN L, A
COUNTY WE FOLLOW THE PROTOCOL
SET FORTH IN WELFARE AND
INSTITUTIONS CODE SECTION 875.
WHEN A YOUTH IS COMMITTED TO THE
SECURE YOUTH TREATMENT FACILITY,
THEY ARE AFFORDED A HEARING AT
LEAST EVERY SIX MONTHS. IT
USUALLY WORKS OUT IN OUR COURTS
THAT WE'RE SEEING OUR YOUTH.
EVERY MONTH EVERY THREE MONTHS
AND AT THE SIX MONTH MARK FOR A
REVIEW HEARING WHERE THROUGH
THEIR ATTORNEY, THEY CAN REQUEST
A REDUCTION IN THEIR BASELINE
TERM. IT IS THROUGH THAT PROCESS
THAT THE COURT WORKS WITH THE
ATTORNEYS IN THAT COLLABORATIVE
MODEL THAT JUDGE LUCERO
DESCRIBED TO SEE HOW THE YOUTH
IS DOING WITH THE PROGRAMMING
THAT HAS BEEN SET FORTH IN THE
IRP TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION. YES
TO BE RELEASED. THAT IS A
DECISION THAT'S MADE BY THE
COURT AT ONE OF THESE HEARINGS,
REASON WHY I ASK WE HEARD SOME
OF THE NUMBERS 20 YOUTH CAMP. A
Kò Kò P 56 54 54 AT? UM UH BARRY
J AND APPROXIMATELY THREE 100 OF
LP NUMBERS ARE VERY OFF. I AT
CAMP KILL PEAK AT CAMP Kò P. WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO HAVE
APPROXIMATELY 60 YOUTH THERE.
I'M WONDERING, ARE YOU ARE WE
GETTING ENOUGH CASES COMING DOWN
TO COURT TO SAY, HEY, THIS YOUTH
CAN GO FROM BARRY JANE, NOW TO
CAMP Kò P BECAUSE I WILL BE
HONEST WITH YOU. I'M HEARING
THAT, UM, THERE WAS A DEAL WITH
THE NIMBYS OF MALIBU. THAT WE
THEY WILL NOT PUT MORE YOUTH IN
THERE BECAUSE, UM, THE RICH AND
THE FAMOUS DO NOT WANT THE YOUTH
THERE, AND INSTEAD THEY WANT TO
KEEP THEM AT BARRY J IN MY AREA
WHERE IT'S COMMUNITIES OF
WORKING CLASS THAT DON'T HAVE
THE TIME TO COME AND SHARE HOW
THEY FEEL ABOUT THE BLACK AND
BROWN KIDS IN SUMMER. WE KNOW
THAT THE PROGRAMMING OFFERED AT
CAMP KILPATRICK IS. PRO PROVIDES
A BETTER ENVIRONMENT THAN THAT
OF BARRY. JAY WE KNOW THAT AND
THIS IS WHY YOU'RE ASKING THE
QUESTION. HOW DO WE GET MORE
KIDS OVER TO CAMP KILPATRICK?
SENATOR I DO NOT KNOW THE ENTIRE
POLITICAL BACK STORY AS TO WHY
THERE IS NOT INCREASED CAPACITY,
BUT I HAVE BEEN ME REFRAIN. OUR
JUDGES. OUR JUDGES AWARE THAT
THEY CAN SEND MORE KIDS TO CAMP
Kò P WHEN THE CASES GET BROUGHT
UP TO THEM FOR A STEP DOWN, I
WAS UNDER THE IMPRESSION THAT
THERE WAS A LIMIT SOMEWHERE
AROUND 18 OR 20. AND THEN WHICH
SHOULDN'T BE A LIMIT. I WANT I
WANNA FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN GO
PAST THAT INVISIBLE LIMIT
BECAUSE THE ACTUAL LIMIT IS
AROUND 60. SO IF WE CAN WORK ON
FIGURING OUT HOW WE CAN GET MORE
KIDS IN THERE BECAUSE THAT'S
WHERE I'VE I SAW A KID WHEN I
FIRST VISITED BARRY J, DAVID UM
AND THEN I SAW HIM WHEN I THEN
VISITED CAMP Kò P. HE HAD
ALREADY TRANSFERRED OVER AND HIS
PERSONALITY WAS NIGHT AND DAY. I
NEED TO SEE MORE KIDS LIKE THAT.
AND I AM NOT GONNA BE HERE TO
CATER TO THE RICH AND FAMOUS.
UM, BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT MORE
KIDS AT THESE FACILITIES FOR
THEM TO BE SUCCESSFUL. SO THIS
IMAGINARY 20 MAX CANNOT EXIST
AND CR IS WE'RE HEARING THIS. WE
NEED TO ENSURE WE GET MORE KIDS
IN THERE FOR THE JUDGES. TO KNOW
THAT THIS THIS ISN'T IN STATUE
THAT THEY NEED TO SEND MORE KIDS
THERE. YES. AND THE YOUNG MAN
THAT YOU'VE DESCRIBED IS NOT AN
ISOLATED YOUNG MAN. THAT'S WHAT
WE SEE WITH MOST OF THE YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO GO TO CAMP KILPATRICK
AND IF THERE'S A WAY FOR YOU AND
Ó Y èC R TO ASSIST IN THE
INCREASING OF CAPACITY THAT
WOULD BE WELCOMED. GREAT.
COMMENT. CAN. WE TALK MORE ABOUT
KIRKPATRICK CAPACITY OR NÓ. OK?
UM, IT IS THE COMMUNITY. UM IT
IS THE COMMUNITY OF MALIBU AND
THE COG THAT EXISTS ON THE
COMMUNITIES AROUND THERE. UM,
I'VE BEEN MEETING WITH A LOT OF
THOSE FOLKS JUST WANTING TO MEET
WITH CITY COUNCIL FOLKS STUFF
AROUND THE LOCAL COMMUNITY, AS
WELL AS ALL OF THE NEIGHBORS AND
NEIGHBORING BUSINESSES AROUND
CAMP KILPATRICK THE DIFFERENCE I
HEAR FROM THE PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND THAT ACTUALLY LIVE THERE
AND LIVE AROUND THE FACILITY.
THEY LOVE IT. THEY WANT IT. THEY
HAVE NÓ ISSUE WITH MORE KIDS. IT
IS THE POLITICAL LEADERS. UM WHO
ARE AND PROBABLY JUST A SMALL
HANDFUL OF POLITICAL LEADERS
THAT ARE BEING VERY LOUD ON IT.
I WILL SAY THIS WHEN AND BEFORE
THEY WERE GONNA MOVE THE YOUTH
TO KILPATRICK WHEN IT BLEW UP
POLITICALLY. THERE WERE SOME
SECURITY ISSUES THAT WERE NOTED
BY THE BS THAT MADE THE FACILITY
OUT OF CLIENTS. UH COMPLIANCE
FROM A STRUCTURAL POINT OF VIEW,
EVEN A PERIMETER FENCE THAT HAD
FALLEN DOWN. SO THAT CREATED
SOME FEAR IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD
THAT A FENCE HAD FALLEN DOWN
AROUND A SECURE FACILITY IN
THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD. UM, THAT I'M
TOLD, HAS BEEN ADDRESSED. AND
THERE WAS ISSUES OF STAFFING. DO
THEY HAVE THE NUMBER OF STAFF TO
INCREASE THE CAPACITY TO 30? 40
50? I THINK AT THIS POINT, THE
ANSWER IS ABSOLUTELY YES. I
THINK THERE IS NOTHING STOPPING
THE FACILITY FROM GOING TO 30 40
50 60, OTHER THAN AT THIS POINT,
POLITICAL WILL BUT I'M SORRY. I
DON'T WANNA KEEP. YOU KNOW, WITH
THIS HEARING JUST ON THAT ONE
ISSUE, BUT WHERE IS THAT FINAL
DECISION? TO INCREASE. THE USAGE
I. I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW THIS
CAN GO ON AND ON. SOMEBODY'S GOT
TO BE IN A POSITION TO SAY.
WE'RE GONNA ADD MORE OF OUR
YOUTH THERE, I THINK THE
WOULD BE THE CHIEF OF PROBATION
AND SUPERVISOR HORVATH, WHOSE
DISTRICT IT'S IN AND SUPERVISOR
HORVAT, SO FAR PROBATION
OFFICERS CHIEF DEPARTMENT THE
CHIEF OF THE L, A COUNTY
PROBATION, THE ONE THAT WAS
INVITED, UM I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THAT. THE CHIEF OF L, A COUNTY
PROBATION, UM AND SUPERVISOR,
HORVATH, WHO'S DISTRICT IT IS
AND SO FAR SURVIVOR SUPERVISOR
HORVATH HAS BEEN A BIG SUPPORTER
OF REHABILITATION AND S¼ Y Tð F,
SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS. OK? I KNOW. DO YOU
HAVE ANYTHING RIGHT NOW? UM LET
ME GET MY SON. OK UM, GO BACK TO
MY QUESTIONS HERE. APOLOGIZE
SENATOR ROTH, IF YOU HAVE, I'M
JUST LOOKING FOR MY QUESTIONS
HERE. I ASK YOU A COUPLE QUICK
ONES. A JUDGE. UM, I HAPPEN TO
AGREE WITH YOU ON ELECTRONIC
REPORTING, UM THAT'S ANOTHER
ISSUE, BUT WITH RESPECT TO THE
JUVENILE PROCEEDINGS, ARE YOU
ARE YOU MAN? YOU'RE MANDATED TO
HAVE A REPORTER. ARE YOU NOT IN
YOUR COURT? YES SO WE'RE REALLY
TALKING ABOUT VERY, VERY
CRITICAL SITUATIONS IN FAMILY
COURT AND SOME OF THE OTHER
COURTS THAT PROBABLY PLAY A PART
IN WHAT YOU DO AS WELL. IT IS
ALREADY IMPACTING THOSE COURTS.
IT WILL IMPACT THE JUVENILE
COURT SOON. OH WHAT HAPPENS IF
YOU'RE A MANDATED? IF YOU'RE
MANDATED TO HAVE A REPORTER,
THEN YOU DON'T HAVE PROCEEDINGS.
I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION. ARE YOUR COURTROOMS
WIRED FOR ELECTRONICS? MINE IS
NOT CURRENTLY TO MY KNOWLEDGE.
ONE OTHER JUST A COMMENT. I
KNOW. I'M GONNA LET THE CHAIRS.
UH, TAKE OVER HERE IN A SECOND.
BUT SINCE YOU GAVE ME THE
OPPORTUNITY QUICKLY, YOU KNOW,
UM, I'M FINISHING. WINDING UP MY
12TH YEAR HERE AND ONE OF THE
THINGS WE DO WELL SOMETIMES IS
TO SET POLICY AND ADJUST POLICY.
AS IN THIS JUVENILE JUSTICE,
REALIGNMENT AND THE OTHER THING,
UH, AS YOU SEE EVIDENCE OF TODAY
THAT WE USUALLY DO PRETTY WELL
AS SHINE A SPOTLIGHT ON THINGS
THAT AREN'T WORKING, AND IT
SEEMS LIKE THIS PROCESS IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY IS SORT OF
BROKEN. AND MAYBE I'VE MISSED IT
. BUT SOMEWHERE ALONG THE LINE
HAS SOMEONE IN CHARGE OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SET IN MOTION AN
INVESTIGATIVE PROCESS OR AN
OVERSIGHT PROCESS TO IDENTIFY
PROBLEMS. THE PROBLEMS YOU'RE
LINING OUT HERE, THE PROBLEMS IN
THE FACILITIES, THE PROBLEMS
ACTUAL OR PERCEIVED WITH THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT, WHERE
THEY'RE HANDLING IT THE STAFFING
ISSUES AND SET OUT
RECOMMENDATIONS AND A AND A
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN THAT
COULD BE OR SHOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED BY SOMEONE BEFORE
SCOTT. I MEAN, SENATOR ROTH AND
THE NEXT PANEL WE WILL HEAR FROM
THE Ó Y èC R OMBUDS PERSON
THAT THAT IS WELL, THAT'S A
COMPLAINT PROCESS AND IN THE
INVESTIGATE AS WELL. OK, WELL, I
WILL. I WILL. I WILL. I'LL NÓ.
I'LL WAIT FOR THAT, BECAUSE I
THE ONE THING WE CAN'T USUALLY
DO UP HERE IS JUMP AS A STATE
LEGISLATURE INTO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND FIX LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ISSUES WHERE THEY'RE
BROKEN, WHERE THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE
NOT STEPPING UP. AND AS I SAID,
I KNOW THEY ARE. PERHAPS THAT'S
A QUESTION FOR KATHLEEN. WELL I
I'LL WAIT. MADAM CHAIR. SHE WAS
IN THE PREVIOUS. I DON'T KNOW IF
SHE OH, IS ARE YOU ABLE TO SPEAK
ON THAT A LITTLE BIT? I'M SURE
I'LL LET YOU ALL NÓ. I'M
FINISHED FINISHED. THIS MOTION
FOR NOW FOR SUB A AND B SO
APPROPRIATE RIGHT NOW. GOOD
MORNING, KATIE HOWARD AGAIN WITH
THE B èC SENATOR, I THINK YOUR
QUESTION HAD TO DO WITH WHO AT
THE STATE LEVEL HAS AUTHORITY TO
COMPEL LOCALS NÓ WHEN WE HAVE A
SET OF PROBLEMS NORMALLY,
SOMEBODY DROPS IN SORTS OUT WHAT
THE PROBLEMS ARE YOU CALL? YOU
CAN CALL AN INSPECTOR GENERAL.
YOU CAN CALL IT A STATE AUDITOR.
YOU CAN CALL IT A COUNTY
AUDITOR. THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
APPOINT AN INDEPENDENT MONITOR
TO HIRE A LAW FIRM TO CONDUCT AN
INVESTIGATION TO DEVELOP A
REPORT TO IDENTIFY WHAT THE
SPECIFIC PROBLEMS ARE, AND WE'VE
HEARD A LOT OF THEM AND WHAT THE
WHAT THE CORRECTIVE ACTION AND
THE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE THAT'S
THEN DELIVERED AND THEY EITHER
ADOPT IT IN WHOLE OR PARTS, OR
THEY SOME IGNORE IT, BUT IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR US TO SORT THROUGH
THAT UP HERE AND TO GIVE A BUNCH
OF ORDERS TO PEOPLE THAT WE
DON'T CONTROL. SURE SURE, I, I
THINK, UM SOME OF THESE
PANELISTS HERE HAVE A LOT OF
EXPERTISE ABOUT HOW THINGS ARE
AND AREN'T HAPPENING AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL IN LOS ANGELES, AND
IT SEEMS IT SEEMS FROM MY
OBSERVATION TODAY THAT THE
PRESSURE POINTS BY MR BUDNICK
AND OTHERS ARE THE PRESSURE IS
BEING APPLIED AT THE POINTS THAT
THAT IT NEEDS TO BE IT JUST IN
TERMS OF MY OWN RESPONSIBILITIES
OF OUR BOARD AT THE B S¼ èC.
THIS IS BEYOND THE SCOPE OF WHAT
WE CAN DO. BUT THE ISSUE OF CAN
MORE YOUNG PEOPLE BE MOVED BE
PLACED AT CAMP KILPATRICK. UM IT
SOUNDS LIKE THERE'S PROGRESS
BEING MADE LOCALLY. AND
CERTAINLY HEARING LIKE THIS
TODAY ALSO DOES EXACTLY AS YOU
SAID, PROVIDES A GREATER
SPOTLIGHT. WELL, IT SOUNDS TO ME
LIKE THE ANSWER IS THERE'S
NOTHING THAT'S BEEN DONE LOCALLY
IN TERMS OF DIRECTING AND A
SPECIFIC INVESTIGATION OF THIS
PARTICULAR. SET OF FACILITIES
THE STAFFING IN THE FACILITIES
TO DEVELOP A PLAN OF CORRECTIVE
ACTION THAT'S DELIVERED TO THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR REVIEW.
OH, THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IS
VERY AWARE OF ALL OF THE WORK
THAT THE BS èC DOES ON
COMPLIANCE WITH THE UM
OPERATIONAL REGULATIONS FOR THE
FACILITY. I'M JUST TRYING TO
DECIDE WHAT WE CAN DO. THIS IS
VERY DISTURBING TO HEAR THIS.
AND YET AT THE STATE LEGISLATIVE
LEVEL, WE TYPICALLY DON'T PASS A
BILL TO SET THE LIMIT ON THE
NUMBER OF THE POPULATION AT
CAMP. KILPATRICK KILPATRICK,
RIGHT, THAT'S DONE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. AND SO THE QUESTION IS
THERE A DOCUMENT SOMEWHERE THAT
EXISTS THAT IDENTIFIES SPECIFIC
FAULTS CORRECTIVE ACTION THAT WE
CAN POINT TO AND SAY, DO IT OR
DON'T DO IT. TO MY KNOWLEDGE AT
THAT LEVEL OF DETAIL. NÓ THERE'S
NOT THAT SORT OF PLAN. THAT'S
WHAT I WANTED TO ASK SENATOR
RUFF. UM I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IF
THE LEGISLATURE HAS THE POWER OF
THIS TYPE OF FIX BUT I DON'T
THINK AT THIS POINT, THE CHIEF
OF PROBATION OR MEMBERS, SOME
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS LIKE THAT THAT CRAZY
WORD OF RECEIVERSHIP. THAT MOST
PEOPLE BEFORE WOULD HAVE PUSHED
AWAY FOR, I THINK AT THIS POINT
I THINK THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE
REALIZE HOW BROKEN THIS IS. AND
I THINK EVEN THE PEOPLE THAT
WOULD NORMALLY BECAUSE OF THEIR
THEIR POLITICAL STANCE PUSH
AGAINST THAT WOULD WELCOME
RECEIVERSHIP AT THIS POINT.
WELL, I CAN ASSURE YOU THIS IS
WHAT WE'VE BEEN LISTENING TO AT
ALL LEVELS IS VERY DISTURBING.
BUT I'M GONNA LET MY CHAIRS WHO
KNOW MORE ABOUT THIS THAN I DO
TO CONTINUE TO ASK QUESTIONS.
YOU KNOW, SENATOR ROTH? YOU
ABSOLUTELY BRING UP KIND OF LIKE
THAT UP IN A ROOM, RIGHT? YOU
KNOW, WE DECIDED I MENTIONED
SOME OF THESE TALKING POINTS IN
MY IN MY OPENING STATEMENTS
REGARDING THE TRANSFER OF
JURISDICTION OVER THE COUNTIES.
BUT IF WE'RE SENDING CLOSE TO A
BILLION DOLLARS DOWN. HOW CAN WE
THEN UTILIZE THOSE FUNDINGS TO
ACTUALLY MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
KIDS? UH, SO IN COWS, YOU KNOW,
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AS A
WHOLE. ALL THE PROGRAMS THAT
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD TOWARDS IS
INDIVIDUALIZED PLANTS VERSUS A
LUMP SUM. YOU KNOW, WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE FOSTER RATE
REFORM THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
SEEING. UM CAL, AIM IS
INDIVIDUALIZED. YOU KNOW, HOW
CAN WE THEN US AT THIS LEVEL,
REALIGN THESE FUNDINGS TO SAY,
HEY, THIS IS HOW BECAUSE WE HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER THAT. THIS IS
HOW THE GRANTS ARE GONNA BE
ADMINISTERED NEXT YEAR. WELL IF
IT'S NOT DELAYED, WE WERE GONNA
CREATE A METHODOLOGY FOR THE SEE
IF I KNOW THE ACRONYM J JB
GRGRBG, UM, GRANTS THAT WE
DEDICATE DOWN TO THE COUNTIES
AND WE'RE GONNA BE COMING UP
WITH A METHODOLOGY ALONGSIDE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND DEPARTMENT ON
HOW WE'RE GOING TO ADMINISTER
THAT FUNDING, SO UTILIZING THE
SPACE TO SEE WHAT
RECOMMENDATIONS WE CAN PROVIDE
AND HOW FUNDING IS GOING TO BE
UTILIZED STARTING EITHER IN 2024
OR 2025. THAT'S WHERE I SEE OUR
JURISDICTION HERE, AND
ADDITIONALLY, WE AS A, UH AS
LEGISLATORS CREATED THE CR
CREATED STATUE OF THE
OMBUDSPERSON AND LAST YEAR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING IF I'M NOT
MISTAKEN, ADDED MORE TEETH TO
THE OMBUDS PERSON TO HOLD
ACCOUNTABLE THE YOUTH THAT WE
SENT OUT SO I UNDERSTAND. YOU
KNOW, IT'S GONNA BE HARD YOU
KNOW TO AND I'M NOT HERE TO
MANDATE A BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AT L A DO THAT I'M BRINGING UP
THESE NOTIONS SO WHEN WE LOOK AT
LEGISLATION AROUND ALIGNMENT
FUNDS WHEN WE LOOK AT DO WE NEED
TO ADD MORE TEETH TO THE
OMBUDSPERSON? WE HAVE THE
NECESSARY DATA TO SAY THIS IS
WHY WE NEED A FURTHER BRING DOWN
SOME DIRECTION. BECAUSE OUR
INTENTION OF REALIGNMENT OF WHY
WE GAVE IT DOWN TO COUNTIES THAT
PROMISE THAT WE GOT FROM
COUNTIES IS NOT BEING UM IT'S
NOT BEING HELD TO PART TO WHAT
WE THOUGHT. SO THAT'S THE
APPROACH. I HAVE IN ALL THIS,
CAUSE WE'RE GONNA BE HEARING
SOME THINGS THAT WE DON'T HAVE
JURISDICTION. YES BUT I THINK IT
IT ADDS TO THE STORY OF THE NEED
AND THE REALIGNMENT DOLLARS. BUT
COULD I ASK, UM, FROM MISS? UH
KANI. WHAT YOUR OPINION IS ON
THE LOCAL, UM, THE OVERSIGHT. I.
I CAN JUST SPEAK IT FIRST OF ALL
AS IT RELATES TO CAPACITY FOR
KILPATRICK, UM, BASED ON A FORM
THAT THE PROBATION DEPARTMENT
PROVIDED TO THE B S¼ èC èC
CAPACITY IS 48. AS IT RELATES TO
PLACEMENT JUDGES CAN ORDER THAT
A YOUNG PERSON BE PLACED AT A
CAMP THAT A YOUNG PERSON BE
PLACED AT AN SPF THAT A YOUNG
PERSON BE RELEASED ON AN ANKLE
MONITOR OR THE COMMUNITY
DETENTION PROGRAM, BUT THEY
DON'T GET TO SPECIFY WHERE
SPECIFICALLY THAT YOUNG PERSON
GOES. THAT IS ENTIRELY IN
PROBATION'S HANDS. IT'S ENTIRELY
IN KIND OF HOW PROBATION THE
PROBATION UNION THE PROBATION.
YOU KNOW, KIND OF STAFF ARE
HOLDING THINGS DOWN AND
PRESUMABLY THEIR INTERACTION
WITH PEOPLE IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
AND WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO
UPHOLD. UM FROM THE BEGINNING,
THE PROBATION UNION AND THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT FELT VERY
STRONGLY ABOUT MAINTAINING THE
S¼ Y Tð F AT BARRY J. UM AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE
DOING. UM, THERE WAS A SECOND
QUESTION. THAT I DIDN'T ANSWER.
I'M SORRY. OVERSIGHT ABOUT
OVERSIGHT AS IT RELATES TO
WHAT'S HAPPENING. I MEAN, YES,
ABSOLUTELY. YOU KNOW, WE DO
ANNUAL INSPECTIONS, AND WE
PROVIDE ALL OF THAT INFORMATION
TO THE B. S¼ èC, UM, WE ALSO I
MEAN, WE ARE TRYING TO SET UP A
GRIEVANCE SYSTEM WHERE YOUNG
FOLKS AND FAMILY CAN ALSO
COMMUNICATE DIRECTLY WITH THE
PROBATION OVERSIGHT COMMISSION.
BUT YOU KNOW, OUTSIDE OF
SUBPOENA POWER LIKE WE DON'T
HAVE ANY. ALL WE CAN DO IS MAKE
A RECOMMENDATION. ALL WE CAN DO
IS CALL FOR FOLKS TO DO BETTER.
UM BUT WE CAN'T CHANGE. UH, THE
POWER THAT REALLY I THINK
PROBATION HOLDS I. I HONESTLY
FEEL LIKE THAT THAT RESTS IN
YOUR HANDS. UM, BECAUSE ALL OF
THAT IS MANDATED BY THE WELFARE
AND INSTITUTIONS CODE, UM SO WE
CAN CALL OUT THE MISSTEPS AND,
UM ACKNOWLEDGE THE SHORTCOMINGS
OF WHICH THERE ARE VERY MANY, UM
AND I. I KNOW THAT THERE'S YOU
KNOW THIS MENTION OF
RECEIVERSHIP. I'M NOT SURE THAT
RECEIVERSHIP CAN FIX A BROKEN
SYSTEM. UM AND THAT THAT'S VERY
MUCH WHAT THIS IS, AND I THINK
WE NEED TO BE A LITTLE MORE
CRITICAL ABOUT HOW IT IS THAT WE
SUPPORT THESE YOUNG FOLKS
BECAUSE RECEIVERSHIP WILL JUST
MAINTAIN THE EXISTING SYSTEM,
PERHAPS DO A BETTER JOB OF
INCARCERATING OUR YOUNG PEOPLE.
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S
THE ANSWER. AND I'M SORRY. ONE
MORE QUESTION ABOUT THE, UM,
PROBATION OVERSIGHT COMMISSION.
UM HOW WHAT MORE CAN BE DONE TO
ADDRESS PARTICULARLY THE UH,
COMMENTS MADE BY SENATOR ROTH.
AROUND KIND OF LIKE WHO IS THE
PERSON WHO OR WHO IS THE ENTITY
THAT SHOULD BE HANDLING THESE
THINGS? I MEAN, ALL WE CAN DO IS
BRING IT TO LIGHT. WE DO HAVE
THE OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL. RIGHT SO THEY PROVIDE,
UM B ANNUAL REPORTS THAT ARE IN
CONNECTION TO THE SETTLEMENT
BETWEEN L, A COUNTY AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. I MEAN,
THE Dð THE Dð Ó J COULD
PROBABLY BE DOING A LOT MORE.
YEAH WE ARE. L A COUNTY IS
WILDLY OUT OF COMPLIANCE, NOT
JUST AS IT RELATES TO MINIMUM
STANDARDS, BUT ALSO THE
SETTLEMENT THAT WE ENTERED INTO
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
EVERY SINGLE TIME, THE OFFICE OF
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL HAS
PROVIDED A REPORT BACK L. A
COUNTY HAS FAILED, WHETHER IT'S
UM, PROGRAMMING WHETHER IT'S USE
OF, UM OUR CAMERAS, WHETHER IT'S
USE OF FORCE WHETHER IT'S JUST
Ó èC SPRAY, LITERALLY EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THOSE REPORTS THAT
WE HAVE RECEIVED SINCE THE
SETTLEMENT WAS ENTERED INTO HAS
LISTED BOTH BARRY JANE NEIDORF
AND AT THE TIME CENTRAL BECAUSE
THOSE WERE THE TWO FACILITIES AS
FAILING IN ALL OF THE KIND OF UM
, AREAS THAT THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL WAS CHARGED IN
REPORTING ON THERE HAS BEEN
NOTHING NECESSARILY FILED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, CALLING
OUT L A COUNTY AS BEING OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH EACH OF THOSE
EACH OF THOSE KIND OF SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS. WELL, THAT'S
OUTRAGEOUS ON ALL LEVELS. IT IS
WITHOUT A DOUBT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MY LAST
QUESTION IS, MR BIRD. UH, WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT, UH, SOME
TRAINING FOR RICK AND FILE AND
SO FORTH. CAN YOU TALK TO ME
ABOUT SOME, UH, DISCREPANCIES
AROUND SOME POS GETTING SOME
TRAINING AND OTHER P Ó S¼
GETTING OTHER TRAINING IS OR IS
THERE UNIFORMITY ACROSS ALL POS
GETTING THE SAME KIND OF
TRAINING? YES WELL, WHEN YOU
SPEAK OF, UH P Ó S¼, UH, I HAVE
TO FRAME IT IN TERMS OF CRITICAL
STAFFING SHORTAGES, SO THERE'S A
THING CALLED DEPLOYMENT. IN
PROBATION IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
WE HAVE JUVENILES, AND WE HAVE
ADULTS. THE JUVENILE OFFICERS
ARE SEVERELY DEFICIENT IN TERMS
OF STAFFING INVENTORY. SO THE
CHIEF HAS HAD TO ORDER FIELD
STAFF. WE CALL THEM TO BE
DEPLOYED INTO THE INSTITUTIONS
THAT IS NOT THEIR AREA OF
EXPERTISE. THAT IS NOT THEIR
NICHE. AND SO SOMETIME WHEN YOU
HAVE THESE DEPLOYED STAFF COMING
INTO THE INSTITUTION, SOME OF
THEM HAVE NEVER WORKED WITH
JUVENILES, AND SO IT PRESENTS A
PROBLEM OF CONTROL. AND WHAT YOU
HEAR TODAY IS THE DEFICIENCIES
IN THE DEPARTMENT. UH LIKE I
SAID, THE B S¼ èC èC COMES OUT
AND IT DOES ITS INVESTIGATION
AND WE FAIL. WE FAIL FOR MANY
REASONS, BUT THE MAIN REASON IS
WHEN IT COMES TO INSTITUTIONAL
STAFF. WHO WORK WITH KIDS, WHICH
I I'M PROUD TO SAY I'VE DONE FOR
32 YEARS. UH WE DON'T HAVE THE
STAFFING INVENTORIES THAT WE
NEED AND THEREFORE CONTROL. IN
TERMS OF AN ENVIRONMENT FOR
LEARNING. GETS DISPLACED WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT PROGRAMS AND YOU
SAY THEY NEVER GET TO GO OUTSIDE
. WELL UM MR BUDNICK IS THERE I
CAN TESTIFY. HE'S THERE ALL THE
TIME. HE CAN TELL YOU SOMETIMES
THEY CAN'T GO OUTSIDE. BECAUSE
IT'S PROHIBITED WHEN YOU CAN'T
HAVE ENOUGH STAFF ON SITE AND
THEN WE'VE TRIED TO CORRECT THE
PROBLEM. AND, UH, I, I CALL IT
THE INSTANT GRITS. YOU WANT TO
CURE THE PROBLEM RIGHT AWAY. AND
SO THE ONLY ALTERNATIVE YOU HAVE
THERE'S TWO ALTERNATIVES HIGHER
AND MASSIVE NUMBERS. ARE DEPLOY
FIELD STAFF THAT DON'T HAVE THE
EXPERTISE WITH DEALING WITH
JUVENILES, BUT THE FIELD STAFF
THEY FEEL BECAUSE THEY TAKE
PRIDE IN THEIR POSITION. EVERY
TIME YOU DEPLOY THEM, WHICH IS
NOW TWO DAYS OUT OF THE WEEK,
THEY FEEL THAT THEY ARE LEAVING
THEIR NICHE, THE COMMUNITY THAT
DEALS WITH THE ADULT, UH, LEVEL
OF, UH, CLIENTELE, UM OUT ON
THEIR OWN. IN OTHER WORDS, THEY
CAN'T SUPERVISE THEM PROPERLY.
SO YOU HAVE SOME DEMORALIZATION
AMONG STAFF WHEN THEY COME INTO
THE INSTITUTION FROM THE OUTSIDE
. UH, EVEN THOUGH WE ALL A PEACE
OFFICERS, THEY JUST THAT'S JUST
NOT THEIR EXPERTISE. AND
SOMETIMES THAT'S VERY DIFFICULT.
SO UH, WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
MEET THE STAFFING CRISIS. UH I
DO GIVE THE BOARD SOME CREDIT.
THEY HAVE REMOVED A FREEZE FOR
YEARS WE'VE HAD TO FREEZE. I
TALKED ABOUT THAT IN TERMS OF
ATTRITION. I'LL JUST GIVE YOU
THIS EXAMPLE THEY HAD 251
EMPLOYEES IN THE LAST 24 MONTHS.
487 EXITED. AND SO WHEN YOU HAVE
THAT TYPE OF ATTRITION VERSUS
HIRING AND THEN YOU HAVING TO GO
, GO, GO GET THOSE WHO ARE
INEXPERIENCED. SOMETIMES IT'S
VERY CHAOTIC. WHEN IT COMES TO
DEALING WITH JUVENILES. IT'S A
SPECIALTY. THESE ARE THE REASON
WE ARE HAVING THESE DISCUSSIONS
BECAUSE YOUTH ARE A SPECIALTY.
THEY TAKE A SPECIAL MENTALITY A
SPECIAL TRAINING IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE THEM THE THINGS THAT YOU
WANT TO PROVIDE THEM. AND SO
THAT CRITICAL STAFFING SHORTAGE
IS, I WOULD SAY THE NUMBER ONE
IF YOU LOOK AT ANY B S¼ èC èC
REPORT IN THE LAST THREE YEARS,
UH, THE FIRST LINE WILL SAY
STAFFING CRISIS, A STAFFING
SHORTAGE AND THEN THEY GET INTO
ALL OF THE OTHER THINGS, BUT YOU
CAN'T COMPLETE NECESSARILY THE
OTHER THINGS BECAUSE IT IS AT A
COOL LEVEL. NOT JUST THE WE
MISSING ONE OR TWO TODAY, IT'S
CRITICAL. AND THEN, UH, LASTLY,
I'LL SAY, BECAUSE WE I DON'T
WANT TO SAY FAIL, BUT BECAUSE OF
THE DEFICIENCY OF HAVING
EXPERIENCED STAFF, UH, THE
VOLATILITY IN THE INSTITUTION
HAS LED TO ASSAULT ON ASSAULTS.
AS THESE YOUNG MEN HAVE HAVE
SAID, UH, IT IS. IT HAS ALLOWED
ASSAULT ON STAFF. STAFF HAVE
BEEN INJURED AND MASS NUMBERS
AND SO THEY ARE OUT. WHEN I
HEARD SOMEONE SAY 11% OF THE
WORKFORCE. I DON'T THINK IT'S
QUITE THAT LOW, BUT THOSE MAY BE
THE NUMBER STATISTICS WILL BEAR
OUT. BUT I WILL SAY THERE'S A
HIGH LEVEL OF STAFF THAT HAVE
BEEN INJURED. SOME OF THOSE ARE
NEW, AND SOME OF THOSE ARE
VETERANS. AND SO WHEN YOU TAKE
THEM OUT OF THE INSTITUTIONAL
SETTING THOSE WHO ARE USED TO
WORKING WITH IT, UH, QUITE
NATURALLY, YOU MAY HAVE SOME
TIME WHAT WE CALL AN
UNCONTROLLABLE SITUATION AND
THEREFORE, UH, AGAIN, WE HAVE
THE BOARD. WE FINALLY GOT THEM
TO SAY HØI. UH AND I GIVE THEM
CREDIT. THEY HAVE ALLOWED THE
CHIEF TO GET A NEW MARKETING
FUND FUND. UH, FOR A FIRM.
EXCUSE ME. UH, BECAUSE THAT'S
CRITICAL. PROBATION IS IN THE
PAPER. LIKE YOU SAID ALL THE
TIME WE WE'VE ALLEGED TO BE
DOING A LOT OF THINGS. SO WHO
WANNA COME WORK FOR YOU? WHEN
YOU'RE BEING PUBLICIZED AS THE
DEMON, SO TO SPEAK, AND SO
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT, UH
HINDER US FROM GETTING TO THAT
POINT. I DO BELIEVE, UH, THE
MANAGEMENT IS BETTER. I BELIEVE
THEY'RE WORKING BETTER WITH THE
P Ó èC, UH, WORKING BETTER
WITH THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. WE'VE BEEN USING
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
SINCE I CAME INTO THE DEPARTMENT
32 YEARS AGO. THERE'S NÓ
HINDRANCE ON THAT. UH, MR
BUDNICK HAS HAS TESTIFIED THAT
HE'S BEEN THERE 20 YEARS SO
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN AROUND WE HAVE
INCORPORATED THEM, BUT SURELY A
CRISIS WHEN IT COMES TO STAFFING
, WHICH MAKES ALL THINGS WORK.
THANK YOU, SIR. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. IF NÓ FURTHER QUESTIONS FOR
THESE PANELISTS, WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO THE OH, GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. SO I MAKE
SURE IT'S ALL. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. CHAIR UM MENJIVAR, UM,
ONE OF THE THINGS YOU MENTIONED
WAS LIKE THE FUNDING AND WHERE
THE FUNDING SHOULD GO. SO ONE OF
THE THINGS I'VE BEEN LIKE
INSINUATING TO DIFFERENT
CREDIBLE MESSENGERS IS THE IDEA
OF LIKE HAVING YOUTH. CREDIBLE
MESSENGERS. I MEAN, YOU HAVE TWO
WONDERFUL PEOPLE SITTING IN
FRONT OF YOU, YOU KNOW, AND
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE THE POSTER
CHILD OF YOU KNOW, LOS ANGELES
COUNTY PROBATION, ET CETERA, ET
CETERA. UM AND JUST THE IDEA
THAT WE'RE SO CLOSE IN AGE AND
EXPERIENCE AND OF COURSE, ARE
GOING TO COLLEGE. WE'RE SEEING
DIFFERENT THINGS BEING EXPOSED
TO DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES. I
BELIEVE THAT WE WOULD PROVIDE SO
MUCH AND THAT WE WILL BE VERY
BENEFICIAL TO THEIR SUCCESS AS
WELL. YOU KNOW, THEY WOULD
THEREFORE SEE US AS BIG BROTHERS
. YOU KNOW, AS THOSE LIKE, OK,
WE CAN ACTUALLY LOOK UP TO THEM
OTHER THAN SOMEBODY IN
DIFFERENTIAL AGE OF LIKE 20
YEARS. YOU KNOW, IT'S LIKE
YOU'VE BEEN THROUGH THIS PROCESS
SO LONG AGO. YOU DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT S¼ Y Tð F IS.
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS
NEW YOUTH JUSTICE REIMAGINED
ENTAILS, YOU KNOW, BUT BOTH ME
AND MONTE MCKAY BOTH UNDERSTAND
THAT SITUATION, SO I FEEL LIKE
IF THERE'S A WAY THAT WE CAN
IMPLEMENT FUNDING FOR BOTH.
YOUTH AND ADULT CREDIBLE
MESSENGERS TO COEXIST WITH THIS,
YOU KNOW, BECAUSE THESE THESE
OLDER PEOPLE THAT CAN'T GET OUT
THERE AND PLAY BASKETBALL WITH
THE YOUNG PEOPLE LIKE THAT. YOU
KNOW, THEY OUT THERE BREAKING
THEIR BACK. SO UM YOU DON'T KNOW
SENATOR GERA. I DON'T WANT NÓ
SMOKE ALL THE Dð. SO I SMOKE BUT
ALSO LIKE LIKE THE IDEAS LIKE I
FEEL LIKE I ALSO HAVE SO MUCH TO
OFFER BECAUSE I'M NOW TRAVELING
TO GO SEE DIFFERENT PRISONS AND
JUVENILE HALLS IN DIFFERENT
STATES AND COUNTRIES. LIKE I
SAID, I'M ABOUT TO GO TO LONDON
MARCH 27TH TO GO SPEAK IN POPE
OTTAWA PRISON, YOU KNOW, AND
THEN ALSO HOPEFULLY GO TO JAPAN
IN JUNE, UM, BUT I ALSO HAVE A
BACKGROUND OF BEING A CERTIFIED
DOG TRAINER BEHAVIORIST SO WE
CAN IMPLEMENT DIFFERENT ASPECTS
OF THIS. YOU KNOW, YOU CAN BRING
IN THE DOGS, BUT YOU CAN ALSO
BRING IN WHAT LIFE ALSO ENTAILS.
LIKE I SAID, DIFFERENT EXPO. SO
MANY PEOPLE ONLY KNOW A CERTAIN
BLOCK OF A RADIUS. YOU KNOW,
IT'S LIKE SO MUCH MORE OUT THERE
IN THE WORLD. THE WORLD IS
YOURS, BUT IT'S YOURS FOR YOU TO
TAKE. SO WHEN ARE YOU GONNA TAKE
IT? SO THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY.
JUST MAKE THE FUNDING WORTH IT.
THANK YOU, MR BROWN. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, BOTH OF YOU FOR COMING
AND THE REST OF THE PANEL. I
APPRECIATE YOUR REMARKS. UM
WHERE I LIKE TO INVITE, UM THE
LAST THREE PANELISTS FOR PANEL
THREE. JOINING US THIS AFTERNOON
IS GONNA BE ALYSSA HARTZ, OUR
NEW OMBUDSPERSON FROM Ó CR.
VANESSA. HOW DO YOU SAY VANESSA?
WHO'S A FEW FEW. FUCHS FROM
SONOMA COUNTY PROBATION OFFICE
AND THEN ANNALISA ZAMORA, POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR YOUNG WOMEN'S
FREEDOM CENTER. ALYSSA. FOR
INVITING ME TO ADDRESS THIS
ESTEEMED BODY. GOOD MORNING OR
GOOD AFTERNOON NOW. THANK YOU
FOR INVITING ME TO ADDRESS THIS
ESTEEMED BODY. MY NAME IS ALISA
HARTS AND I'VE BEEN THE Ó Y èC
R OMBUDSPERSON SINCE JANUARY
15TH OF THIS YEAR. I APPRECIATE
THE PRIOR TESTIMONY, ESPECIALLY
HEARING FROM MR BROWN AND MR
MCKAY. THE OMBUDSPERSON IS AN
IMPARTIAL ENTITY THAT RECEIVES
COMPLAINTS RELATING TO YOUTH AND
JUVENILE FACILITIES,
INVESTIGATES THESE COMPLAINTS
AND SEEKS TO RESOLVE THEM WHERE
POSSIBLE IN COLLABORATION WITH
FACILITY STAFF. THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME THAT THE STATE HAS
HAD AN OMBUDSPERSON ABLE TO
ADDRESS COMPLAINTS WITHIN THE
LOCAL FACILITIES. WE ALSO
PROVIDE EDUCATION ON THE YOUTH
BILL OF RIGHTS. OUR YOUTH
FRIENDLY POSTERS ARE BEING
PRINTED BY THE OFFICE OF STATE
PUBLISHING. UH, AS WE SPEAK. A B
505 PASSED LAST YEAR REQUIRES US
TO VISIT EACH JUVENILE FACILITY.
EVERY YEAR. WE CONDUCTED OUR
FIRST THE FIRST OF OUR SITE
VISITS, UH, LAST WEEK AND WE'LL
CONTINUE THROUGHOUT THE YEAR. BY
MARCH, 1ST. ALL SIX OF OUR
CURRENT POSITIONS WILL BE FILLED
, INCLUDING THREE STAFF PEOPLE
WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND ONE
FORMER PROBATION OFFICER. WE ARE
WORKING ON DEVELOPING A REGULAR
REPORT ON COMPLAINT THEMES
RESOLUTION AND THE OTHER DATA
THAT WE WILL BE REPORTING FOR
STATUTE. IN BRIEF AS OF FEBRUARY
, 1ST. WE HèA WE HAD 36 OPEN
CASES AND 205 CASES CLOSED. WE
ARE CURRENTLY RECEIVING ABOUT
TWO TO THREE COMPLAINTS A WEEK
AND WE EXPECT THIS NUMBER TO
RISE WHEN THE YOUTH BILL OF
RIGHTS MATERIALS ARE POSTED. IN
THEIR COMPLAINTS. YOU RAISE
ISSUES THAT RANGE FROM THE
CONDITIONS OF THEIR DAILY LIVES
TO SPECIFIC MAJOR INCIDENTS THAT
HARMED OR TRAUMATIZED THEM. AT
THIS TIME, I CAN SHARE SOME
THEMES THAT HAVE COME UP THROUGH
COMPLAINTS OR OTHER CONTACTS
WITH YOUTH. UH, THESE THEMES
DERIVE FROM COMPLAINTS, MANY OF
WHICH WE ARE STILL IN THE
PROCESS OF INVESTIGATING. SO AT
THIS TIME, THERE ARE ANECDOTAL
FIRST FOOD IS A CENTRAL CONCERN.
UH, FOOD, UH, IS A LOVE LANGUAGE
AS AS YOU SAID, SENATOR AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE HEARING WE'RE
TALKING ON TODAY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT, UM LOVE AND HOW TO CARE
FOR OUR YOUTH AND ESPECIALLY FOR
GROWING TEENAGERS. FOOD IS, UH,
CRITICAL YOUTH FREQUENTLY
COMPLAIN ABOUT THE QUANTITY AND
QUALITY OF FOOD, THE VARIETY,
THE TEMPERATURE AND ACCESS TO
SNACKS. A SECOND THEME IS LACK
OF PROGRAMMING OR EDUCATIONAL
OPTIONS. THIS IS OF PARTICULAR
CONCERN TO OLDER YOUTH WHO ARE
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES WITH LONG
COMMITMENTS. A THIRD THEME IS
THE OVERUSE OF PEPPER SPRAY.
WHILE IT IS SOMETIMES CLEAR TO
YOUTH. WHY PEPPER SPRAY IS BEING
USED, FOR EXAMPLE, TO BREAK UP A
FIGHT. MANY YOUTH HAVE DESCRIBED
BEING SUBJECT TO PEPPER SPRAY
WHEN THEY ARE ALREADY COMPLYING
WITH STAFF DIRECTIVES. YOUTH
ALSO OFTEN DESCRIBE DELAYED
DECONTAMINATION. A B FIVE. Ó
FIVE HAS SUBSTANTIALLY
FACILITATED OUR ACCESS TO
RECORDS AND IS HELPING US
INVESTIGATE COMPLAINTS MORE
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY. OUR
ABILITY TO RESOLVE COMPLAINTS
DEPENDS ON EFFECTIVE
COLLABORATION WITH PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS. WE HAVE ALREADY HAD
SUCCESSES IN COLLABORATIVE
COMPLAINT RESOLUTIONS A FEW
EXAMPLES, ADDING A SECOND
SANDWICH TO LUNCH IN RESPONSE TO
A COMPLAINT ABOUT FOOD.
INTRODUCING A COLLEGE PREP
PROGRAM IN RESPONSE TO A
COMPLAINT ABOUT EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES, COMMITTING TO
FORMALLY MODIFY A POLICY ON
YOUTH ACCESS TO LEGAL DOCUMENTS
IN THEIR CELLS SUPPORTING A
YOUNG PERSON IN GETTING OUT OF
FACILITY EMPLOYMENT DURING THEIR
S¼ Y Tð F COMMITMENT. THESE
RESOLUTIONS HAVE BEEN ACHIEVED
THROUGH COLLABORATION WITH
RECEPTIVE AND DEDICATED
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE
OPEN TO OUR FEEDBACK AND OFTEN
WITH SUPPORT FROM THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ARM OF Ó èC R. A
CORE CHALLENGE IS THAT OFTEN A
TRUE COMPLAINT RESOLUTION WOULD
REQUIRE RESOURCES THAT ARE NOT
READILY AVAILABLE, SUCH AS MORE
PROBATION STAFFING, WHICH WE
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT AS A
CHALLENGE AROUND THE STATE AND
MORE COMMUNITY BASED RESOURCES.
BASED ON MY PRIOR EXPERIENCE AND
WHAT I AM SEEING SO FAR IN THE
COMPLAINTS, A FEW PRELIMINARY
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE TOP OF MIND.
FIRST WE WILL BE MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO HELP YOUTH WITH
LONG COMMITMENTS, UNDERSTAND
THEIR PATH BACK TO THE COMMUNITY
THROUGH LESS RESTRICTIVE
PROGRAMS AND TIME REDUCTIONS,
THE PATH SHOULD BE DEMONSTRATED
AND TRANSPARENT TO GIVE YOUNG
PEOPLE HOPE AND DIRECTION FOR
THEIR FUTURES. SECOND CALIFORNIA
SHOULD WORK TOWARD DECREASING
THE USE OF PEPPER SPRAY IN
FACILITIES. THIS CANNOT HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT, BUT COULD BE A NEAR
TERM GOAL. WE WILL MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO REDUCE THE
OVERUSE OF PEPPER SPRAY WHEN
SUCH INSTANCES ARE SUBSTANTIATED
AND TO PROMOTE POSITIVE
INTERACTIONS WITH YOUTH THAT
WILL REDUCE THE PERCEIVED NEED
FOR PEPPER SPRAY. THIRD WE ARE
EXPLORING WAYS TO TRACK YOUTH
COMMITTED TO JUVENILE FACILITIES
WHO COMMIT A NEW OFFENSE AND END
UP IN AN ADULT FACILITY AND TO
IDENTIFY THE PATHWAYS THAT LEAD
TO THESE NEW ADULT OFFENSES. IF
SUCH TRENDS EXIST, THEY WILL
UNDERMINE CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT TO TREATING YOUTH AS
YOUTH AND CARING FOR THEM WITHIN
YOUTH FACILITIES. AND WILL
CREATE THE FUNCTIONAL EQUIVALENT
OF TRANSFERS TO ADULT COURT THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS WORKED SO
HARD AND SUCCESSFULLY TO
DRAMATICALLY REDUCE THANK YOU. A
LOT OF GREAT INFORMATION TRYING
TO TRACK EVERYTHING DOWN. OK,
WE'RE GONNA NOW MOVE ON TO
VANESSA. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME
IS VANESSA FUCHS AND I'M, THE
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICER IN
SONOMA COUNTY. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
SUBCOMMITTEES REGARDING JUVENILE
JUSTICE REALIGNMENT. I'LL BEGIN
BY HIGHLIGHTING THAT PRIOR TO
JUVENILE REALIGNMENT. SONOMA
COUNTY PROBATION ALREADY HAD
ROBUST PROGRAMMING FOR YOUTH IN
OUR DETENTION, HOWEVER, WITH
JUVENILE REALIGNMENT, WE WERE
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND
OUR PROGRAMMING FROM
APPROXIMATELY 20 PROGRAMS TO
2817 OF THOSE ARE DELIVERED BY
NON PROBATION STAFF. OUR
PROGRAMS RANGE FROM SKILLS BASED
TRAINING TO SELF HELP. TO
CREATIVE EXPRESSION AND BUILDING
PROSOCIAL INTERESTS TO CAREER
TECHNICAL TRAINING AND HIGHER
EDUCATION. IN ADDITION TO THE
STRUCTURED PROGRAMS, WE ALSO
ADDED CHILD AND FAMILY TEAM
MEETINGS FOR ALL S¼ Y Tð F YOUTH
. THESE MEETINGS PROVIDE FOR
REGULAR CHECK INS FOR YOUTH AND
FAMILIES TO OFFER THEIR VOICE
AND CHOICE IN THE PLANNING
PROCESS. WORTH HIGHLIGHTING IS
OUR WORK WITH SANTA ROSA JUNIOR
COLLEGE AND THEIR SECOND CHANCE
IS RISING SCHOLAR SCHOLARS
PROGRAM ONE OF OUR NEWER
PROGRAMS. SO FAR, WE HAVE
GRADUATED THREE YOUTH WITH A
DEGREES AND ONE WITH AN A, AN A
S¼. STUDENTS SELECT THEIR
COURSEWORK BUT TRADITIONALLY
START WITH GENERAL EDUCATION. WE
HAVE ONE DEDICATED STAFF TO HELP
THEM WITH SIGNING UP FOR A
COLLEGE CLASSES. DUE TO THE
QUICK IMPLEMENTATION TIME NEEDED
AS A RESULT OF S¼ B A 20 THREE
PROGRAMMING THAT WE STILL WE ARE
STILL BUILDING AS MORE CAREER
TECHNICAL TRAINING AND FURTHER
DEVELOPING OUR LESS RESTRICTIVE
PROGRAMMING OPPORTUNITIES. ON
THE PLUS SIDE. WE RECENTLY WERE
AWARDED A GRANT OF $1.4 MILLION
FROM Ó IR TO HELP US
SUCCESSFULLY TRANSITION YOUTH
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY WITH
INDIVIDUALIZED REHABILITATIVE
PLANS. CHALLENGES THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY STRUGGLING WITH ARE
KEEPING THE PROGRAM CURRICULUM
FRESH AS SOME YOUTH HAVE ALREADY
COMPLETED OUR PROGRAMS EARLIER
IN THEIR COMMITMENTS. ALSO AS
YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD, STAFFING
THE FACILITY IS A PROBLEM. WE
WENT FROM AN ALL TIME LOW OF 17
DURING COVID, UH, TO THE HIGH
SIXTIES IN A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME AFTER YEARS OF CUTTING OR
NOT FILLING POSITIONS. THAT'S A
POPULATION OF 17 NOT STAFFING.
SO NOAH COUNTY PROBATION IS
PRESENTING HERE TODAY BECAUSE WE
WERE ONE OF THE FIRST COUNTIES
TO COMMIT TO BEING A REGIONAL
HUB TO SERVE YOUTH IN NEED FROM
BAY AREA IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES. OUR JUVENILE JUSTICE
REALIGNMENT SUBCOMITTEE AGREED
TO THIS ON THE PREMISE THAT BY
HELPING OTHERS, OUR OWN YOUTH
WOULD BENEFIT AS THERE WOULD BE
MORE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
GROUP PROGRAMMING WITH FIDELITY.
INITIALLY OUR JUVENILE HALL WAS
SET TO HOUSE NÓ MORE THAN 2020
S¼ Y Tð F YOUTH, BUT A YEAR INTO
REALIGNMENT WITH THE PENDING
CLOSURE OF Dð JJ RE RAISED IT.
IN 2021 WE APPLIED FOR AND WERE
AWARDED A $1 MILLION GRANT FROM
THE BS TO HELP US STAND UP OUR
REGIONAL HUB AND UNANTICIPATED
CHALLENGE IS THAT SINCE APRIL OF
2023 WE HAD TO STOP ACCEPTING
OUT OF COUNTY YOUTH DUE TO A
SPIKE IN OUR OWN JUVENILE
DELINQUENCY POPULATION. THAT
MORATORIUM ON ACCEPTING OUT OF
COUNTY YOUTH REMAINS IN EFFECT.
AT OUR HEIGHT. WE HAD 11 OUT OF
COUNTY YOUTH. AND TODAY WE HAVE
EIGHT. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
CONTRACTS WITH 10 COUNTIES AND
FIVE DIFFERENT COUNTIES
CURRENTLY HAVE YOUTH IN OUR
FACILITY, THE OVERALL POPULATION
IN OUR JUVENILE HALL TODAY,
INCLUDING S¼ Y Tð F YOUTH IS 66
WITH NINE FEMALES. THE SF
POPULATION IS 24 IS 21 WITH FOUR
BEING FEMALES. AT OUR HEIGHT. WE
HAD 29 SO TF YOUTH I'LL OFFER
HERE SINCE TRAINING KEEPS BEING
BROUGHT UP THAT, UH, THE
MINIMUMS TRAINING HOURS IS 24
HOURS. AND OUR OUR TRAINING PLAN
FOR THIS CURRENT YEAR IS 72
HOURS FOR OUR LINE STAFF IN 96
FOR OUR SUPERVISORS. REGARDING
ANY RECOMMENDATIONS. I'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S
THE SUBCOMMITTEES THAT MORE TIME
IS STILL NEEDED FOR COUNTIES TO
FULLY STAND UP AND STAFF UP
THEIR SECURE YOUTH TREATMENT
FACILITIES AND LESS RESTRICTIVE
PROGRAMS. ALSO MORE FUNDING IS
NEEDED TO TRULY RE ENVISION HOW
YOUTH ARE HOUSED FOR LONG TERM
COMMITMENTS. THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
JUST SIMPLY IS NOT ENOUGH FOR
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS. FOR
EXAMPLE, THOUGH, OUR FACILITY IS
CONSIDER MORE MODERN THAN MANY.
IT WAS DESIGNED IN THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS WITH ONE TYPE OF
POPULATION IN MIND AS A RESULT
OF JUVENILE REALIGNMENT, THAT
POPULATION HAS CHANGED
TREMENDOUSLY AND THE FACILITY
DESIGN NÓ LONGER MEETS THE NEEDS
OF THE OLDER POPULATION. ALSO
THERE NEEDS TO BE THERE NEEDS TO
CONTINUE TO BE FLEXIBILITY IN
HOW THE MONEY IS UTILIZED,
PUTTING ANY TIME LIMITS OR OTHER
RESTRICTIONS ON FUNDING CAN BE
CHALLENGING FOR COUNTIES THAT
ARE UNDERSTAFFED AND UNDER,
RESTORES RESOURCED AND STILL
RECOVERING FROM VARIOUS
DISASTERS. LIKE MANY OTHER
COUNTIES, SONOMA COUNTY HAS HAD
ITS FAIR SHARE OF DISASTERS IN
THE PAST FEW YEARS. PROBATION IS
ONLY ONE DEPARTMENT THAT HAS
MANY NEEDS TO BE MET BY OUR
COUNTY DEPARTMENT, PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE. THEY SIMPLY DO
NOT HAVE THE BANDWIDTH TO START
OUR PROJECTS ON THE TIMELINE. WE
WOULD LIKE THEM TO BEGIN. OUR
COUNTY'S RESOURCES ARE PULLED
AND A LOT OF DIRECTIONS AS WE
RECOVER FROM THE MANY FIRES,
FLOODS AND COVID WHILE COPING
WITH CURRENT WEATHER, WEATHER
RELATED ISSUES. ADDITIONALLY
FUNDING TO PAY STAFF MORE IS
ALSO NEEDED. IT IS NOT LOST ON
OUR STAFF THAT Dð JJ STAFF WERE
PAID MORE TO WORK WITH THIS
POPULATION THAN THEY ARE. WE
CURRENTLY ARE STRUGGLING TO HIRE
AND RETAIN JUVENILE CORRECTIONAL
COUNSELORS IN A MARKET WITH LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT. WE ARE ALSO
COMPETING AGAINST OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THAT HAVE
HIGHER THAT ARE HIRING WITH HIGH
CALORIES AND HIGHER HIRING
INCENTIVES. AGAIN. I WANNA THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY THAT
CONCLUDES MY PRESENTATION AND
I'LL WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS WHEN
THE TIME COMES. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. OUR FINAL PANEL IS HERE,
ANALISA. GOOD. GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS ANALISA ZAMORA. THANK
YOU. SUBCOMITTEE FOR HOLDING THE
SPACE HAVE A COLLECTIVE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE NEEDS OF
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE. IS IT LOUD
ENOUGH? OK, THANK YOU, UM, ON
THE POLICY DIRECTOR OF YOUNG
WOMEN'S FREEDOM CENTER, A
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION WORKING
IN COMMUNITIES AND FACILITIES IN
THE BAY AREA AND LOS ANGELES. IN
AN EFFORT TO DECARCERATE AND
DECRIMINALIZE YOUNG WOMEN AND
GENDER EXPANSIVE FOLKS. WE
PROVIDE SUPPORT, MENTORSHIP AND
EMPLOYMENT TO THOSE WHO HAVE
GROWN UP IN POVERTY EXPERIENCE.
A JUVENILE, LEGAL AND FOSTER
CARE SYSTEMS HAVE SURVIVED THE
UNDERGROUND STREET ECONOMY AND
HAVE EXPERIENCED SIGNIFICANT
VIOLENCE IN THEIR LIVES. PRIOR
TO THIS ROLE. I SPENT THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS SUPPORTING
INCARCERATED YOUTH IN THEIR
REENTRY TO THE COMMUNITY IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY. UM OVER TIME
, I REALIZED THERE WAS A PATTERN
THAT I WASN'T UNFAMILIAR WITH
NOT ONLY BECAUSE OF MY OWN
EXPERIENCE GROWING UP IN
POVERTY. BUT THE EXPERIENCES I
WAS SUPPORTING PEOPLE THROUGH
OVER AND OVER AGAIN. BETWEEN
HOUSING, INSTABILITY,
HOMELESSNESS, INVOLVEMENT,
HOMELESSNESS, INVOLVEMENT IN THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. PARENTAL
INCARCERATION SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE OR A SCHOOL PUSH OUT IN
POVERTY, VIOLENCE AND TRAUMA. IT
BECAME CLEAR THIS IS A SYSTEMIC
ISSUE THAT FOLKS HERE AS LEADERS
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE THE ABILITY
AND RESPONSIBILITY TO ADDRESS IN
A WAY THAT PUTS AN END TO THE
CYCLES OF TRAUMA AND ABUSE OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE EXPERIENCING IN
CALIFORNIA. GIRLS AND GENDER
EXPANSIVE USE, SPECIFICALLY
EXPERIENCE HIGH RATES OF CHILD
WELFARE INVOLVEMENT AND SEXUAL
ABUSE WHILE IN THE LEGAL SYSTEM
MANY OF THESE YOUTH REMAIN STUCK
IN THE CYCLES OF INCARCERATION
DUE TO TECHNICAL VIOLATIONS AND
STATUS OFFENSES RELATED TO THE
LACK OF STABILITY AND INABILITY
TO COPE. KEEPING THEM IN THE
CYCLE HAS A DIRECT CORRELATION
TO UNHEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS
INVOLVING SEXUAL AND PHYSICAL
ABUSE DUE TO LEARNED POWER
DYNAMICS IN THE SYSTEM. WHERE
THEY EXPRESS HAVING VERY LITTLE
ACCESS TO BODILY AUTONOMY. THE
REALITY IS NONE OF THIS WILL END
UNTIL WE REIMAGINE WHAT
ACCOUNTABILITY LOOKS LIKE AND
HOW YOUTH ARE SUPPORTED IN
LEADING, SELF DETERMINED LIVES.
INCARCERATION IS NOT A SAFETY
NET AND SHOULD NEVER BE
CONSIDERED THE SOLUTION BY
FOCUSING ON INCARCERATION AND
FACILITIES AND THE IDEA OF
PLACEMENTS DETERMINED BY THE
GOVERNMENT SYSTEM. WE ARE
SETTING YOUTH UP TO ONLY KNOW
HOW TO THRIVE IN AN INSTITUTION.
COMMITMENT TO A REALIGNMENT OF
THE USE SYSTEM MEANS CREATING
ALTERNATIVES THAT CULTIVATE THE
LEADERSHIP AND BRILLIANCE THAT
ALREADY EXISTS IN YOUNG PEOPLE.
WHEN YOUTH ARE PLACED IN SAFE
ENVIRONMENTS WHERE RELATIONSHIPS
ARE HEALTHY, THEY THRIVE IN
RECENT EVALUATIONS OF OUR
PROGRAMMING. YOUNG PEOPLE
REPORTED THAT PRIOR TO HAVING A
SAFE SPACE WITH COMPASSIONATE
AND RELATABLE ADULTS, THEY
DIDN'T FEEL SAFE AND THEREFORE
THEY DON'T REALIZE THEY WERE
LIVING IN CONSTANT SURVIVAL,
UNABLE TO ADDRESS THEIR HEALING.
A SAFE SPACE MEANS THAT YOUTH
ARE PROVIDED COMMUNITY BASED
CARE WHERE THEY ARE SEEN AS
EXPERTS OF THEIR OWN LIVES, AND
THEY'RE LISTENED TO AND EMBRACED
IN ALL THE STRENGTHS THAT THEY
CARRY AS INDIVIDUALS TO CARE FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE. IT'S CRITICAL.
THEY'RE MET WITH CURIOSITY TO
UNDERSTAND THE COMPLETE CONTEXT
OF THEIR LIVES IN THE HISTORICAL
, ECONOMIC, SOCIAL AND SPIRITUAL
ASPECTS TO SUPPORT THEM IN THEIR
JOURNEY TO WHOLENESS, COMMITMENT
TO A CARE FIRST MODEL MEANS
INNOVATIVE, INNOVATIVE
INVESTMENT IN COMMUNITIES AND
FAMILIES. WE MUST PUT AN END TO
CRIMINALIZATION OF POVERTY AND
BEGIN INVESTMENT IN PERMANENT,
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE. FOR WHOLE
FAMILIES THAT DOES NOT REPLICATE
THE SYSTEM SO THAT TRUE FAMILY
REUNIFICATION CAN BE POSSIBLE.
WITHOUT INVESTMENT. WHOLE
FAMILIES, IT'S IMPOSSIBLE FOR
FAMILIES TO BUILD AND CREATE
SUSTAINABILITY. WHILE RESOURCES
LIKE BELOVED COMMUNITY HOUSING
ARE READILY AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT
IN THIS PROCESS. THE BARRIERS TO
THIS IS THAT CURRENT FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES ONLY SEEK TO
RESOURCE. THOSE REPLICATING A
MODEL WE KNOW DOES NOT WORK.
COUNTIES LIKE SANTA CLARA HAVE
FOUND WAYS TO PROVIDE DIRECT
FUNDING IN THE FORM OF
GUARANTEED INCOME TO SURVIVORS
AND THOSE AT RISK OF
EXPLOITATION VIOLATION. I MEAN
AND VIOLENCE. I. I APOLOGIZE.
BUT ALLOCATED FUNDING TO YOUNG
PARENTS AND TO THOSE REENTERING
THE COMMUNITY. WE CAN DO IT
ACROSS THE STATE, TOO. WE NEED
TO INVEST IN CULTURAL, HOLISTIC
AND PROFESSIONAL METHODS OF
HEALING TO ADDRESS A TRAUMA
YOUTH ARE EXPOSED TO WHEN
INVOLVED IN THE SYSTEMS AND WHEN
THEY LEAVE THEM. AND OF COURSE,
WE NEED TO ENSURE THE AGENCY
TRUSTED TO SUPPORT REALIGNMENT
IS WELL RESOURCED. A WELL FUNDED
Ó Y èC R WOULD FILL MANY OF
THE OVERWHELMING NEEDS FOR
OVERSIGHT, TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND GRANT ADMINISTRATION
HIGHLIGHTED BY FELLOW PANELISTS
HERE TODAY. LEGISLATORS SHOULD
PRIORITIZE FUNDING Ó IR, AN
AGENCY THAT WAS VIEWED IN 2020
AS A LINCHPIN TO SUCCESSFUL
REALIGNMENT. Ó IR NEEDS MORE
STAFF. CURRENTLY THE OMBUDS
OFFICE ONLY HAS SIX STAFF
MEMBERS TO RECEIVE, INVESTIGATE
AND RESOLVE CONCERNS FROM
INCARCERATED YOUTH, FAMILY AND
STAFF ACROSS CALIFORNIA'S 58
COUNTIES. FOR PERSPECTIVE IN
2022, NEARLY 9000 YOUTH WERE
SECURELY DETAINED IN AROUND 90
FACILITIES STAFFED BY THOUSANDS
OF EMPLOYEES. SIX STAFF TO
ENSURE ALL THESE PEOPLE ARE SAFE
AND SUPPORTED. ALSO IN LESS THAN
ONE YEAR BY LAW. OH I èC R WILL
BE IN CHARGE OF ADMINISTERING
ALL JUVENILE JUSTICE GRANTS
FEDERAL AND STATE. THE CURRENT
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL FOR Ó
èC R IS INSUFFICIENT BECAUSE IT
ONLY ACCOUNTS FOR THE TRANSFER
OF FEDERAL GRANTS FROM THE B. I
èC èC TO Ó I èC R AND
EXCLUDE STATE FUNDS. Ó Y èC R
IS A FUNNEL IS FUNDAMENTAL IN
ENSURING THAT HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF STATE
INVESTS ANNUALLY IS PRODUCING
POSITIVE OUTCOMES. A MAY 2020
CALIFORNIA STATE AUTO REPORT
CONCLUDED THAT THE B I èC èC
IS MINIMAL OVERSIGHT OF THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE. PREVENTION
ACT. JJ èC P, A FAILED TO HOLD
COUNTIES ACCOUNTABLE FOR POOR
GRANT SPENDING AND
NON-COMPLIANCE WITH MANDATED
ADMINISTRATION. WITH APPROPRIATE
FUNDING. ICR CAN SUCCESSFULLY
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES AND ENSURE
CALIFORNIA SUCCESSFUL
REALIGNMENT. AND BUDGETING FOR
STAFF IS IMPORTANT THAT SALARIES
ARE SET HIGH ENOUGH TO ATTRACT
THE MOST QUALIFIED CANDIDATES
FOR KEY POSITIONS AT Ó. I èC R
. IT IS ABSURD THAT LAST YEAR
THE POSTED SALARY RANGE OF Ó
IRS OMBUDSPERSON WAS LOWER THAN
THE RANGE FOR BS. FIELD
REPRESENTATIVES. LEGISLATORS
MUST ALSO PROVIDE ENOUGH
OPERATING EXPENSES TO EQUIP
STAFF TO PROPERLY PERFORM THEIR
JOBS. THIS INCLUDES WRITING
ENOUGH TRAVEL FUNDS FOR OMBUD
STAFF AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS. FINALLY Ó I èC R
ALSO NEEDS FUNDS TO INVEST IN
DEVELOPING AND MAINTAINING NEW
SYSTEMS AND INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED FOR PROPER DATA COLLECT.
IN REPORTING AND EVALUATIONS.
REALIGNING TO A YOUTH FIRST CARE
FIRST MODEL IS NECESSARY AND
IT'S POSSIBLE IT WILL TAKE TIME
AND OUR COLLECTIVE EFFORT. THE
CENTER IS HERE TO DO OUR PART,
AND WE ASK THAT YOU AS LEADERS
ALSO DO YOURS BY ALLOCATING
FUNDS INNOVATIVELY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR REMARKS. UM, I'M
GONNA START MY FIRST QUESTION
WITH VANESSA. UH, CORRECT ME.
DID I HEAR THAT 17 OF YOUR
PROGRAMS ARE LED BY NON P Ó
PERSONNEL. THAT'S CORRECT. COULD
YOU SHARE WITH ME? HOW UM WERE
THERE ANY HESITANCY? HOW DO THE
PROBATION OFFICER FEEL INCLUDED
IS A COLLABORATION OR IS IT JUST
BEING COMPLETELY LED BY OTHER
ENTITIES? IT DEPENDS FOR THE
MOST PART. UM OUR JUVENILE
CORRECTIONAL STAFF WILL DO
CERTAIN PROGRAMMING WHILE
OUTSIDE ENTITIES WILL DO OTHER
PROGRAMMING. BUT OUR OUR STAFF
ARE CLEARLY PRESENT THERE. UM
OUR STAFF WELCOME THAT IT'S A
IT'S A RELIEF FOR THEM TO HAVE
OUTSIDE ENTITIES BEING BROUGHT
IN. AND WE ALSO REALIZED LONG
AGO THAT WE CAN'T DO THIS WORK
ALONE. AND IF WE WANT SUCCESSFUL
TRANSITION, WE NEED TO BE MAKING
THOSE CONNECTIONS TO COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS WHILE
THEY'RE IN CUSTODY AND HELP THEM
TRANSITION INTO THE COMMUNITY.
PERFECT. THANK YOU SO MUCH, UM
OUR NEW OMBUDSPERSON. WELCOME I
MEAN, I KNOW YOU COME FROM CR.
THAT'S KIND OF MY FIRST QUESTION
. YOU KNOW, FOR TRANSPARENCY. I
HAD SOME UM, IT WAS A LITTLE
DIFFICULT FOR ME IN THE
BEGINNING TO FIND A WAY. HOW YOU
WERE GONNA BE AUTONOMOUS FROM CR
AS YOU WERE THE RIGHT HAND WOMAN
OF A DIRECTOR LUCERO, CAN YOU
TALK TO ME ABOUT YOUR ABILITY TO
STEP ASIDE FROM YOUR PREVIOUS
ROLE AND BE THIS AUTONOMOUS
INDIVIDUAL THAT'S GONNA HOLD A
LOT OF ENTITIES ACCOUNTABLE.
INCLUDING Y èC, R. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION. UM
I. I CERTAINLY I HAVE BEEN WITH
OSC R FOR SINCE I WAS THE FIRST
STAFF PERSON HIRED WITH Ó. I
èC R, SO I'M VERY WELL
ACQUAINTED WITH THE OFFICE AND,
UH, HAVE PARTICIPATED IN THE
SHAPING OF THE OFFICE, UM,
INCLUDING BEING COUNSEL TO THE
OMBUDSPERSON DIVISION. UM IN MY
PREVIOUS ROLE, ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT I WAS VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THE IDEA OF MOVING OVER TO
BE THE OMBUDSPERSON IS THAT IT
REALLY COMBINES MY PRIOR
EXPERIENCE AS A, UH, A LEGAL
ADVOCATE. I WAS A CIVIL RIGHTS
ATTORNEY FOR SIX YEARS IN LOS
ANGELES WITH PUBLIC COUNSEL AND
I FOUGHT FOR, UM, FIVE FOUGHT TO
HOLD SYSTEMS ACCOUNTABLE, FOUGHT
FOR THE RIGHTS OF YOUTH. AND,
UM, REALLY ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT I WANTED TO DO THIS WORK
WAS PRECISELY TO BE ABLE TO, UH,
SERVE THE YOUTH AND TO REALLY
HEAR THEIR CONCERNS TO ENGAGE
WITH THEM INDIVIDUALLY, TO KIND
OF GET BACK TO THAT KIND OF FACT
FINDING INVESTIGATION RESOLUTION
THAT I WAS ABLE TO DO IN MY
PRIOR CAREER WHEN I WHEN I DID
LITIGATION, SO I, UM I HAVE NÓ
PROBLEM. UM I HAVE DEEP, DEEP
RESPECT FOR THE LEADERSHIP OF Ó
Y èC R AND I HAVE NÓ PROBLEM IN
TAKING A DIFFERENT POSITION IF I
NEED TO. I HAVE NÓ PROBLEM IN,
UM, VOCIFEROUSLY ADVOCATING FOR
SOMETHING I BELIEVE IN WITH BOTH
THE LEADERSHIP OF Ó Y èC R,
THE LEADERSHIP OF AGENCY, UM, UP
TO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. THANK
YOU, RIGHT WHEN YOU CAME IN, YOU
KNOW, JANUARY 15. I THINK THE
FIGHT CLUB AT LOS BANOS HAD JUST
HAPPENED. HAVE YOU HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SOME PRIVATE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE YOUTH OR
OTHER PROBATION OFFICERS YET AT
LP? NOT SINCE NOT SINCE I
STARTED NÓ OK, UM AND THEN YOU
SHARED WITH US SOME COMMON
THEMES AROUND COMPLAINTS AND SO
FORTH. AND YOU, YOU STARTED
GOING INTO SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS. I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE. UM SOME OF THE
OVERARCHING RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
DECREASING THE OVERUSE OF PEPPER
SPRAY AND THE SECOND PART YOU'RE
LOOKING TO CREATE A PATH A PLAN.
YOU EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT MORE.
SEE IF I CAPTURE THAT CORRECTLY?
OH THE SO MY FIRST
RECOMMENDATION WAS, UM, HAD TO
DO WITH, UM, SANDWICHES. THE P A
MUNCH OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT,
RIGHT? THAT WAS A THEME. THE
FOOD FOOD ISSUE IS A THEME AND,
UM, IN TERMS OF RECOMMENDATIONS,
I DON'T I HAVE NOT DEVELOPED ANY
LIKE LEGISLATIVE RECOMMENDATIONS
AROUND FOOD. THE UM, THE FIRST
KIND OF, UM, RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT I WAS, UM SUGGESTING WERE
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE TO KNOW HOW THEY'RE GOING
TO GET OUT OF THE JUVENILE
FACILITY BECAUSE WHAT I'M SEEING
IN CONVERSATIONS WITH YOUTH IS
THAT THEY SOMETIMES HAVE THIS
SENSE. DESPAIR THAT THEY DON'T
KNOW HOW THEY ARE GOING TO GET
FROM WHERE THEY GET OUT FROM
WHERE THEY ARE TO SOME BETTER
PLACE, AND THERE'S A LOT OF
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW
THAT ARE NEW WITH S¼ B 820 THREE
THAT COULD BE REALLY
TRANSFORMATIVE FOR THEM LESS
RESTRICTIVE PROGRAMS REDUCTION
IN SENTENCES THINGS THAT THEY
DON'T KNOW. UH THEY'RE NOT AWARE
OF THEM, AND THEY'RE NOT BEING
TOLD HOW THEY CAN GET THEM. WE
HEARD THIS IN THE PRIOR PANEL.
THEY DON'T KNOW THAT THEY DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE PROCESS IS FOR
THEM TO GET A TIME REDUCTION OR
TO GET INTO A LESS RESTRICTIVE
PROGRAM. WHAT WHAT ARE THE
CRITERIA? WHAT AND THAT'S GOING
TO BE DIFFERENT IN EVERY
FACILITY, BUT WE HAVE SOME
COMPLAINTS RELATED TO THAT KIND
OF, UM WHAT I WOULD CALL DESPAIR
AND LACK OF, UM, LIKE THEY THEY
WANT. THEY WANT TO GET OUT IN
WHATEVER WAY THAT THEY CAN. AND
I THINK THAT THIS THIS IS A
RECOMMENDATION FOR, UM,
PROMOTING BETTER CULTURE WHILE
THEY'RE INCARCERATED. THAT I
THINK COULD BE IMPACTFUL FOR
PEOPLE IN MANY FACILITIES. MY
FINAL QUESTION HERE IS STICKING
TO THIS TOPIC. AND HOW DO WE
ANTICIPATE GETTING SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM YOU
REGARDING THESE COMMON THEMES?
UM YOU KNOW, WE DON'T WE SAW THE
NUMBERS BACK IN AUGUST, SO I SAW
THE NUMBERS BACK IN AUGUST FROM
A BRIEFING FROM Ó Y èC R
REGARDING THE CASES THAT WERE
FILED AND THE ONES A ROOSTER
OPEN AND SO FORTH. AND WHAT WE
DON'T WANNA SEE AND I SHARED
THIS BEFORE IS THAT WE'LL CLOSE
THE CASES TWO MONTHS LATER, WE
HAVE THE SAME AMOUNT OF CASES.
HOW ARE WE LOOKING? TO DECREASE
THE COMMON THEMES AND CREATE
SUSTAINABLE SUSTAINABLE CHANGES.
AND HOW WHEN SHOULD WE
ANTICIPATE OR SHOULD I
ANTICIPATE SOME OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE REPORT
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER
TODAY? THAT WILL BE COMING UP
NEXT YEAR? OR THE, UH OR THE
ANNUAL REPORT THAT YOU'LL BE
SHARING WITH US, PERHAPS AT THE
END OF THIS YEAR? YES UM SO YOU
WILL. YOU WILL BE GETTING A
REPORT FROM US THIS YEAR. UM
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER, I HOPE
, UM Ó IR. THE OMBUDSPERSON
DIVISION. UM, IS REACHING SOME
REALLY IMPORTANT MILESTONES. AS
I SAID ON MARCH. FIRST WE WILL
HAVE ALL OF OUR SIX POSITIONS
STAFFED. IN ADDITION, WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
GETTING OUR CASE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM UP AND RUNNING. THAT
SYSTEM IS GOING TO ALLOW US TO
GENERATE REPORTS LIKE THAT. UM,
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE, UM,
COMPLAINT THE ISSUE AREAS
TRACKED. WE'RE HAVE FIGURE OUT
HOW HOW WE'RE HOW WE'RE
CAPTURING HOW THE COMPLAINTS ARE
RESOLVED BECAUSE THERE'S A
MULTIPLE, THERE'S MULTIPLE WAYS
THAT COMPLAINTS CAN BE RESOLVED.
NOT EVERY COMPLAINT IS GOING TO
BE SUBSTANTIATED. NOT EVERY
COMPLAINT IS GOING TO BE
RESOLVED THROUGH ACTION OF THE
OMBUDSPERSON. BUT MANY WILL AND
WE NEED SO WE'RE THE SYSTEM IS
GOING TO ALLOW US TO CAPTURE. UM
IN A MUCH MORE DETAILED LEVEL,
NOT JUST THE DATA SPECIFIED BY
THE STATUTE, BUT ALSO HOW THE
COMPLAINTS ARE BEING RESOLVED
AND WHAT THE THEMES ARE AND I
THINK THAT WILL BE THE CORE OF
THE REPORT. AND UM THE, UM. BUT
CERTAINLY THE THEMES THAT WILL
BE EMERGING FROM THE COMPLAINTS.
UM I VIEW THAT AS REALLY CENTRAL
TO THE REPORTS THAT WE WILL BE
SUBMITTING TO YOU ON AT LEAST AN
ANNUAL BASIS. UM BUT THERE'S A
LOT MORE THAT WE CAN SAY, UM,
THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO SAY
ABOUT WHAT WE ARE SEEING ACROSS
ACROSS DIFFERENT COUNTIES WHERE
WHERE AND IT WILL LET US
IDENTIFY WHERE THERE ARE STATE
WIDE ISSUES AND WHERE THERE ARE
KIND OF POCKETS OF LOCALIZED
ISSUES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, UM. HOW? HOW? I JUST
WANNA GET A BETTER IDEA OF HOW
YOU DO YOUR WORK. UM IN TERMS OF
ACCESS, YOU KNOW THE YOUTH
HAVING ACCESS TO YOU? DO THEY
DIRECTLY CALL YOU? HOW DO THEY?
WHERE IS THE CONFIDENTIALITY
THEY MIGHT NEED IN ORDER TO
REACH OUT TO YOU. DO YOU DIRECT?
DO YOU PERSONALLY DIRECTLY TALK
TO THEM ABOUT THE COMPLAINTS AND
WHAT TO DO ABOUT THEM? UM AND
TAKING SOMETHING LIKE, UM, LET'S
SAY INDIVIDUAL PLANS. ARE THERE
THINGS THAT MUST BE REQUIRED. SO
IF YOU GET A COMPLAINT YOU'RE
YOU'RE TRYING TO FIX SOMETHING
THAT'S ALREADY REQUIRED LIKE AN
INDIVIDUAL IS AN INDIVIDUAL PLAN
ALREADY REQUIRED. AND SO
SOMEBODY COMPLAINS, UH, YOUTH
BRINGS THAT TO YOUR ATTENTION
THAT THERE'S THEY DON'T HAVE A
YOUTH PLAN. DO YOU DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT TO FIX THAT, OR IT'S
JUST SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW.
YOU SORT OF SAVE AND. UNTIL IT
GETS. IF IT'S A SYSTEMIC PROBLEM
, THEN YOU TRY TO FIX IT AT AT
THAT LEVEL, SO I'M TRYING TO GET
A SENSE OF THE PRACTICAL SIDE,
THE DAILY SIDE OF ADDRESSING
ISSUES THAT THE YOUTH HAVE. UH,
THOSE ARE THOSE ARE REALLY GOOD
QUESTIONS. SO FIRST IN TERMS OF
YOUTH ACCESS TO US, WE HAVE A
HOTLINE THAT IS STAFFED BETWEEN
8 A.M. AND 5 P.M. EVERY DAY, AND
THEN THERE'S VOICEMAIL FOR AFTER
HOURS. AND SO IF A YOUTH OR
ANYBODY WHO'S MAKING A COMPLAINT
RELATED TO THE TREATMENT OF
YOUTH IN JUVENILE FACILITIES, IT
COULD BE A LAWYER. IT COULD BE A
FAMILY MEMBER. IT COULD BE
STAFF. IT COULD BE. UH UH,
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDER. ANYBODY
CAN MAKE A COMPLAINT. THEY CAN
CALL THAT HOTLINE AND THEY WITH
ONE OF OUR STAFF, UM DURING
BUSINESS HOURS, OR, UM OR WE
FIND A WAY TO GET BACK TO THEM.
UM IF IT IF WE GET A VOICEMAIL
AFTER HOURS, SO THAT'S THAT'S
ONE WAY THAT WE'RE GETTING
COMPLAINTS. UM THAT'S THE MAIN
WAY THAT WE ARE GETTING
COMPLAINTS FROM YOUTH. UM YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT CONFIDENTIALITY
IS REALLY IMPORTANT, AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE WORKING
WITH PROBATION DEPARTMENTS IN
TERMS OF ENSURING THAT YOUTH
HAVE A CONFIDENTIAL PLACE TO
MAKE THOSE CALLS. UM AND THE, UM
, THE YOUTH BILL OF RIGHTS
MATERIALS. UM THE POSTERS, UM,
INDICATE OF THE YOUTH RIGHTS AND
ALSO INDICATE THAT THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO MAKE THESE CONFIDENTIAL
CALLS TO THE, UH TO THE
OMBUDSPERSON. UM SOMETIMES, UH,
THE PLACEMENT OF THE PHONES IS
AN ISSUE. UM THE YOU KNOW, THE
FOAM WILL JUST BE IN THE DAY
ROOM AND EVERYBODY CAN HEAR THEM
MAKING THE CALL. AND UM, YOU
KNOW, THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE CONFRONTING, BUT THAT'S
WHERE THE PHONE IS. UM AND WE'RE
YOU KNOW, WE'RE WORKING ON
DEVELOPING STRATEGIES AROUND
THAT AND MAKING SURE THAT, UM,
THAT THAT THEY DO FEEL THAT THAT
THEY ARE CON THAT YOUTH ARE
COMFORTABLE MAKING THOSE CALLS
TO US. UH, I KNOW THAT IN SOME
FACILITIES, THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO NOT RECORD THE CALLS
TO THE OMBUDSPERSON. UM WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT WILL BE, YOU
KNOW, TRYING TO SEE IF THAT'S
LOGISTICALLY FEASIBLE IN THE
NEAR TERM IN ACROSS THE STATE.
UM. WITH RESPECT TO YOUR SECOND
QUESTION RELATED TO, UM, LIKE,
HOW DO WE DEAL WITH AN
INDIVIDUAL ISSUE VERSUS A
SYSTEMIC ISSUE? WHAT LIKE HOW DO
WE DECIDE HOW TO DEAL WITH A
CERTAIN COMPLAINT? SO IT REALLY
IT REALLY DOES AND ALSO HOW TO
HELP RESOLVE IT. HOW TO HELP
RESOLVE IT? YES SO, UM, JUST
JUST TO KIND OF SET THE BASELINE
. WE CAN'T ORDER WE HAVE NÓ
AUTHORITY TO DIRECT PROBATION TO
DO ANYTHING. WE CAN MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND WE CAN WORK
WITH THEM COLLABORATIVELY TO
RESOLVE SOMETHING SO THERE MAY
BE THERE MAY BE ISSUE THAT WE
BELIEVE AFTER INVESTIGATION
VIOLATES TITLE 15 AND WILL LET B
S¼ èC KNOW. UM UM AND WE'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH PROBATION
TO TRY TO RESOLVE IT, BUT BUT
ULTIMATELY, WE CAN JUST MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS. SO UM, BUT THE
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS THAT A LOT OF
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS ARE HAVE
BEEN WILLING TO WORK WITH US TO
RESOLVE COMPLAINTS AFTER WE'VE
INVESTIGATED THEM. SO, UM
SOMETIMES THERE WILL BE A LIKE
THE EXAMPLE THAT YOU RAISED
AROUND THE INDIVIDUAL, UM, PLAN.
UM I THINK THAT THE WE HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER, UM, HARMFUL
CONDITIONS WITHIN THE FACILITY.
AND SO THE MORE COMMON COMPLAINT
IN THAT AREA WOULD BE, UH, MY
IRP SAYS THAT I'M SUPPOSED TO
GET, YOU KNOW, VOCATIONAL
TRAINING, BUT I'M NOT GETTING
ANYTHING. AND SO WHAT WE'LL DO
IS WE WILL, UM USUALLY WE WILL
SPEAK WITH THE YOUTH FIRST. THEN
WE'LL SET A MEETING WITH
PROBATION AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE LIKE.
GET A COPY OF THE IRP FIND OUT.
WHAT UM LIKE W. WELL WHY HAVEN'T
YOU PROVIDED THIS PROGRAM? WHAT
IS YOUR PLAN? OR OR IS IT
CORRECT THAT YOU HAVEN'T
PROVIDED THIS PROGRAM? WHAT IS
YOUR PLAN TO PROVIDE THE PROGRAM
? IS THERE AN ALTERNATIVE? UM
AND THEN? AND SO WE HAVE THESE
CONVERSATION. WE GET OUR
EVIDENCE. WE HAVE THE
CONVERSATIONS, AND THEN WE TRY
TO WORK TO FIND A THAT IS THE
DESIRED OUTCOME OF THE
COMPLAINANT. SO THEY IF THE
YOUTH WANTS VOCATIONAL TRAINING
THAN THAT, THEN THAT'S WHAT WE
WOULD REALLY BE FOCUSED ON
ADDRESSING. SOMETIMES THERE ARE
COMPLAINTS THAT ARE TRULY, UM,
SYSTEMIC ISSUES THAT WE, UM THAT
WE DO KIND OF PUT IN AAA BUCKET
FOR A, UM FOR A SYSTEMIC
RECOMMENDATION OR A POTENTIALLY
A SPECIAL REPORT. AND UM, I AM
LOOKING AT, UM, CONSIDERING A
NUMBER OF SPECIAL, UH, REPORTS
AND INVESTIGATIONS. UM, YOU KNOW
WHEN WE LIKE FULLY STAFFED AND
HAVE OUR SYSTEMS. UH SYSTEMS IN
PLACE THAT WILL ALLOW US TO
REALLY DIG INTO ISSUES THAT WE
ARE SEEING AROUND THE STATE. I
JUST SORRY. JUST ONE MORE, UH,
WITH UM ANNALISA, COULD YOU, UH,
TALK ABOUT YOUR EXPERIENCE? UH
WITH GIRLS IN THE JUVENILE
SYSTEM AND ANY. ANY INSIGHT AS
TO THE EXPERIENCE AND WHAT GIRLS
ARE GOING THROUGH. YES. UM SO I
WORKED WITH YOUNG WOMEN THROUGH
COVID AND I STARTED WORKING. WE
GOT ACCESS TO YOUNG FOLKS INSIDE
, UM, A FEW MONTHS PRIOR TO
COVID. AND SO WHEN I FIRST
ENTERED INTO FACILITIES I WOULD
SEE AT ANY POINT BETWEEN 12 AND
15 YOUNG WOMEN WHO WOULD COME TO
PROGRAM AND WORK WITH ME AND DO
WORKSHOPS AND WHEN I MET WITH
THEM ONE ON ONE TO TALK ABOUT
THEIR REENTRY AND THEIR PLANNING
FOR THEIR NEXT HEARING. MOST OF
THEM WERE TELLING ME I DON'T
HAVE ANYWHERE TO GO. I DON'T
HAVE A GOOD RELATIONSHIP WITH MY
MOM. I DON'T MY YOUR MY MOM
DOESN'T EVEN HAVE A STABLE PLACE
TO TAKE ME INTO. AND THERE WERE
NÓ SOLUTIONS. WE WOULD GO TO
COURT AND, UM, JUDGES THERE WAS
GREAT AT YOU KNOW, CONNECTING
THE ENTIRE TEAM TO AND HOLDING
PROBATION, ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
THINGS THAT THEY NEED TO BE, UM,
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO BE
SEEKING FOR THIS YOUNG PERSON.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY,
THERE'S SUCH A LACK OF
RESOURCES. UM THAT EVEN THEN
THERE WAS STILL NOWHERE TO GO.
AND SO THESE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
JUST SITTING HERE UNTIL THEIR
NEXT COURT DATE, HOPING THAT
SOMETHING'S GOING TO HAPPEN,
HOPING THAT YOU KNOW PROBATION
IS GOING TO FIND SOMEONE THAT
THEY A FAMILY MEMBER. THEY DON'T
EVEN KNOW SUITABLE, RIGHT, UM,
TO BE SENT HOME TO AND THAT'S
NOT THAT STORY WAS NEVER UNIQUE.
THAT WAS ALWAYS A SITUATION OR
THAT YOUNG WOMEN WERE BEING TOLD
YOU'RE BEING PLACED HERE IN
JUVENILE HALL, AND YOU'RE BEING
KEPT HERE FOR YOUR OWN SAFETY
BECAUSE YOU HAVE ADDICTION
ISSUES OR BECAUSE YOU'RE
INVOLVED IN THE UNDERGROUND
STREET ECONOMY AND TIME AND TIME
AGAIN. YOUNG PEOPLE WERE TELLING
ME THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT WHAT I
NEED. THIS IS WHAT'S HURTING ME.
I'M GOING HOME AND I HAVE
NOTHING TO COPE WITH, AND THAT'S
WHY I'M USING BECAUSE I'M SELF
MEDICATING. AND, UM, YEAH, SO I
THINK YOUNG. PEOPLE ARE JUST
THEY'RE BEING INCARCERATED FOR
SITUATIONS THAT ARE TRULY OUT OF
THEIR CONTROL, AND THEY NEED
SUPPORT AND NOT TO JUST BE MET
WITH MORE YOU KNOW, AS AS
ANOTHER PANELIST HAD SAID.
INCARCERATION WERE THE DOOR
SHUTS BEHIND YOU AND YOU HAVE NÓ
IT? IT'S NOT. IT'S NOT A
CONDUCIVE TO OUR YOUNG PEOPLE'S
HEALTH IT IT'S VERY DETRIMENTAL.
AND, UM WE CAN'T KEEP PLACING
THEM IN CONDITIONS THAT'S
CAUSING THEIR ISSUES IN THE
FIRST PLACE. AND SO WHEN I THINK
ABOUT SOLUTIONS, UM I SPOKE
ABOUT BELOVED HOUSING COMMUNITY
HOUSING, BUT MODELS LIKE THAT
WHERE IF A YOUNG PERSON IS
TELLING YOU THAT THEY HAVE
SOMEONE YOU KNOW A FAMILY MEMBER
? MAYBE THEY'RE WORKING ON THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH MOM. BUT MOM
DOESN'T HAVE A PLACE TO GO. WE
SHOULD BE INVESTING IN MOM AS
WELL. NOT JUST THE YOUNG PERSON
BECAUSE THAT AT THE END OF THE
DAY, THE MOM WILL NEVER BE FOUND
SUITABLE IF SHE DOESN'T HAVE
ANYWHERE, BUT SHE WANTS TO TAKE
HER CHILD BACK IN. UM OR IF
WE'RE ONLY RELYING ON FAMILY TO
FIND A PROBATION TO FIND SOMEONE
SUITABLE FOR ALL THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT COME WITH
THAT, AND WE'RE NOT LISTENING TO
YOUNG PERSON WHO'S SAYING NÓ? I
DO FEEL SAFE WITH THAT WITH THAT
FAMILY MEMBER OR WITH THAT
FRIEND OR WITH THAT COUSIN OR
WITH MY FRIEND'S PARENTS. IF
THEY'RE TELLING YOU, THEY FEEL
SAFE, AND THAT'S AN ENVIRONMENT
THAT THEY FEEL THEY'LL BE ABLE
TO THRIVE IN. THEN WE SHOULD BE
LISTENING TO OUR YOUNG PEOPLE.
UM, I ALSO WANTED TO SPEAK ABOUT
UH, INNOVATIVE FUNDING AND SO
PART OF, UH, MY WORK WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE DURING COVID. WE ALL KNOW
THE ISSUES THAT ARE THAT, YOU
KNOW, CAME UP AS FAR AS HOUSING
AND, UM SO MANY BUT. SOME OF THE
FUNDING BARRIERS THAT WE HAD
WERE THAT THERE WERE TIMES THAT
I NEEDED TO GET A YOUNG PERSON
SOMEWHERE TO STAY TONIGHT, OR I
NEEDED TO PAY SOMEONE'S PHONE
BILL BECAUSE THEY'RE COMING OUT
OF INCARCERATION, AND THE
SCHOOLS HAVEN'T FIGURED OUT
LAPTOPS. THE SCHOOLS HAVEN'T
FIGURED OUT INTERNET AT THAT
POINT, RIGHT, BUT I WAS BEING
TOLD WE CAN'T SPEND ON THAT
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MANY
RESTRICTIONS ON FUNDING AND
UNLESS YOU'RE USING IT ON AN
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM OR TO BUY
THEM A SNACK. SORRY, BUT I CAN'T
APPROVE THIS AND THE ISSUE IS
THAT YEAH, THAT'S BUT AT THE END
OF THE DAY, THE YOUNG PERSON IS
STILL GOING HOME TO NÓ HOME OR
NOTHING TO EAT UNTIL THE NEXT
TIME THEY CAN COME INTO THE
CENTER. WE CAN SUPPORT THEM WITH
THEIR IMMEDIATE NEED RIGHT THEN
AND THERE. UM SO THOSE ARE JUST
SOME OF THE SOLUTIONS THAT I
HAVE, AND I'D LOVE TO CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. IT'S JUST A QUICK
QUESTION. I THINK OF THE
OMBUDSPERSON I. I WAS BOTHERED
BY THE, UM INFORMATION ABOUT THE
APPARENT INAPPROPRIATE USE OF
PEPPER SPRAY ON THOSE WHO WERE
DETAINED OR IN CUSTODY. HOW
EFFECTIVE IS YOUR WAS YOUR
INVESTIGATIVE EFFORT IN TERMS OF
RESOLVING THE COMPLAINTS? THE
PEPPER SPRAY INVESTIGATIONS ARE
STILL ONGOING. HAS IT BEEN
DIFFICULT FOR YOU TO SECURE THE
APPROPRIATE REPORTS AND FILES
NECESSARY TO RESOLVE?
INAPPROPRIATE USE OF PEPPER
SPRAY COMPLAINTS. SO WE'VE ONLY
RECENTLY GOTTEN, UH, EXPLICIT
ACCESS TO, UH TO RECORDS, UM,
WITHOUT A COURT ORDER. SO FOR
INSTANCE, VIDEO RECORDS, WHICH
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT FOR PEPPER
SPRAY INVESTIGATIONS. I MEAN,
THAT'S REALLY THE ONLY WAY THAT
YOU CAN SEE, UM LIKE, AT LEAST
START TO SEE WHETHER IN WHAT WAY
THE PEPPER SPRAY WAS USED AND
HOW IT STARTED. AND SO THAT AS
OF JANUARY 1ST, WE'RE HAVING
MUCH BETTER SUCCESS AT GETTING
VIDEO. UM AND SO I THINK THAT'S
UM THAT THAT'S GOING TO BE KEY.
SO COMBINING THE VIDEO WITH THE
INCIDENT REPORTS SHOULD LET US
UNDERSTAND. UM UNDERSTAND WHAT.
LIKE WHAT DOES THE DEPARTMENT
BELIEVE WAS THE, UM REASON FOR
USING THE PEPPER SPRAY? WHAT
DOES THE VIDEO SHOW? WHAT DID
THE YOUTH SAY AND REALLY GETTING
A BETTER IDEA OF HOW THAT HOW
IT'S BEING, UM, EXPERIENCED AND
PRESENTED FROM ALL THOSE SIDES.
WELL, CERTAINLY, I THINK
IMPORTANT FOR US TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU HAVE THE INFORMATION
AND IMPORTANT TO THE CHAIRS FOR
YOU TO HAVE THE INFORMATION
NECESSARY FOR YOU TO DO YOUR JOB
. DO YOU KNOW? IS THERE A
STANDARD PROTOCOL OF WITH
RESPECT TO PROBATION OFFICERS
FOR WITH RESPECT TO THE USE OF
PEPPER SPRAY AND A CUSTODIAL
SETTING? IT'S COVERED IN TITLE
15. SO THE B S¼ èC èC
REGULATIONS DO COVER, UH, THE
STEPS THAT HAVE TO BE TAKEN, UM
PRIOR TO PEPPER SPRAY BEING
USED, UM IT'S FAIRLY. DONE
FAIRLY HIGH LEVEL IN TERMS OF,
YOU KNOW, TRYING TO USE A, UM, A
TRYING TO, UM RESOLVE THE
SITUATION BEFORE USING PEPPER
SPRAY, AND I THINK YOU KNOW
THERE ARE THAT CAN BE
INTERPRETED AND IN PRACTICE IS
OCCURRING IN DIFFERENT WAYS TO
BE IN COMPLIANCE WITH TITLE 15.
SO THERE THERE ARE SOME THAT
THERE IS LIKE A FRAMEWORK WITHIN
TITLE 15 AROUND PEPPER SPRAY.
WELL I THINK WE'D PROBABLY LIKE
TO SEE A CERTAINLY A
STANDARDIZED TRAINING APPROACH.
OBVIOUSLY YOU DON'T WANT TO BE
TOO RESTRICTIVE BECAUSE IT IS A
LEFT LET LETHAL FORM LESS LETHAL
FORM OF DEALING WITH SITUATIONS.
BUT YOU. YOU MENTIONED YOU'RE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE USE
LESS PEPPER SPRAY. I THINK WE
PROBABLY NEED TO BE MORE
SPECIFIC THAN THAT. IN TERMS OF
GIVING GUIDANCE, SO BE
INTERESTED TO SEE WHAT YOU COME
UP WITH THERE. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIRS. JUST LAST, UM. QUESTIONS
HERE. UM, OMBUDS PERSON. YOU
MENTIONED THAT YOU STUDY YOUR
VISITS LAST WEEK AND YOU'LL
CONTINUE THIS YEAR. ARE YOU
GONNA BE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
YOUR ABILITY TO DO ON? UM WHAT
THEY CALL UNANNOUNCED VISITS, OR
ARE YOU PLANNING ON ANNOUNCING
SO THE VISITS THAT WE STARTED
LAST WEEK ARE THE ANNUAL THE
MANDATORY ANNUAL SITE VISITS.
UM, FOR THOSE VISITS, WE DECIDED
TO ANNOUNCE ALL OF THE, UM
ANNUAL VISITS BECAUSE WE WANT TO
BE ABLE TO ENGAGE WITH THE
APPROPRIATE LEADERSHIP OF THE
FACILITIES. UM WITH RESPECT TO
OUR VISITS THAT ARE CONNECTED TO
INVESTIGATIONS. I THINK OUR
STANDARD PRACTICE WILL NOT BE TO
ANNOUNCE THOSE VISITS. AND SO WE
HAVE ALREADY CONDUCTED. WE HAVE
ALREADY GONE TO FACILITIES
WITHOUT ANNOUNCING IN ADVANCE
THAT WE WERE GOING TO BE
ARRIVING, AND SO I THINK THE
MOST OF OUR INVESTIGATIVE VISITS
WILL NOT BE ANNOUNCED. THANK
YOU. AND THE LAST QUESTION IS,
UM, FOR INSTANCES WHERE A GREAT
INCIDENT HAPPENED LIKE THE FIGHT
CLUB OR THE OVERDOSE. WILL WE BE
MAKING IT A PRACTICE TO GO AND
VISIT THAT JUVENILE HALL TO
CONDUCT OUR OWN INVESTIGATION?
ON TOP OF WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
THAT PROBATION? UM DEPARTMENT.
THAT'S AN INTERESTING QUESTION.
I THINK THAT, UM, SPECIFICALLY
IN L A AS WAS DISCUSSED IN THE
LAST PANEL. THERE ARE MANY
DIFFERENT LAYERS OF OVERSIGHT.
UM SO THE THAT HAVE VERY DIRECT
ACCESS TO THE, UH, INFORMATION
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE
FACILITIES. UM SO THERE'S THE,
UM, CONSENT DECREE WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE. THERE
IS THE OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL. THERE'S THE, UM UH,
INTERNAL PROBATION. UM.
INVESTIGATION SO THERE IS ALL OF
THAT GOING ON. UM AND ONE OF THE
PRINCIPLES OF THE OF
OMBUDSPERSON. UM, INVESTIGATIONS
IS TO TRY TO RESOLVE ISSUES AT
THE LOWEST LEVEL POSSIBLE, SO
WHEN THERE ARE PROCESSES THAT WE
THINK ARE EFFECTIVE, UM
HAPPENING. UM, WE WON'T
NECESSARILY GO IN THAT SAID, I
DO THINK THAT MAJOR INCIDENTS
LIKE THAT, UM, THAT, UM THERE.
THAT I YEAH, I DON'T. UH, WE
HAVEN'T MADE A DECISION ON
WHETHER WE WILL HAVE A POLICY TO
AUTOMATICALLY LIKE TO BASICALLY
HAVE THAT TRIGGER AN Ó. I èC R
OMBUDSPERSON INVESTIGATION, BUT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE WILL
CERTAINLY CONSIDER. THANK YOU.
IF COLLEAGUES I THINK THOSE WERE
ONLY COMMENTS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
PER YEAR PRESENTATION AND
REMARKS TODAY. THAT CONCLUDES
ALL OUR PANELISTS. I THINK YOU
KNOW LIKE SENATOR ROCKY
SUMMARIZED IT A LOT OF
DISTURBING THINGS THAT WE HAVE.
GOT YOU A LOT OF DISTURBING
THINGS THAT WE HEARD TODAY. UM,
AND OUR GOAL HERE IS JUST TO
FIND WHERE WE FIT TO HELP BE
PART OF THE SOLUTION THERE SO
NOW WE WANNA MOVE ON OVER TO
PUBLIC COMMENT, AND I WANNA
THANK MY COLLEAGUES. MY CO-CHAIR
HERE FOR, UM, JOINING US AND
PUTTING THIS UM, PANEL TOGETHER.
SO IF ANYONE HAS ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT, YOU CAN COME FORWARD.
IF YOU COULD RESTRICT YOUR
COMMENTS TO TWO MINUTES ALRIGHT.
EVERYTHING HAS BEEN SAID. OH, WE
GOT A COUPLE. AFTERNOON THANK
YOU, UM LENA MALLET WITH THE
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND AND A
COORDINATOR OF THE LOS ANGELES
YOUTH UPRISING COALITION. S¼ B
820 THREE AIM OF BUILDING
MOVEMENT TOWARDS A MORE
CONSCIOUS, DEVELOPMENTALLY
APPROPRIATE PUBLIC HEALTH
APPROACH CLEARLY IS FLOPPED.
AFTER THE INITIAL 400 MILLION
WAS ALLOCATED FOR FACILITY
RENOVATIONS ALONE PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS COLLECTIVELY ACROSS
THE STATE HAVE CONTINUED TO
DRAIN OVER 900 MILLION YEARLY
AND ARE STILL YIELDING RESULTS
THAT ARE DISASTROUS AND DEEPLY
TRAUMATIZING FOR OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE. THE CONDITIONS. IF YOU
HAVE HEARD, AS YOU'VE HEARD
TODAY ARE UNBEARABLE FOR ALL AND
DEADLY FOR SOME THIS PLAN AND
ITS SUBSEQUENT COMMITMENT ITS
FISCAL INVESTMENT IN COUNTY RUN
YOUTH. CARR FACILITIES HAS ONLY
SERVED TO REINFORCE CALIFORNIA'S
ANTIQUATED RELIANCE ON
PUNISHMENT AND CRIMINALIZATION.
YOUNG PEOPLE LIKE EVERYONE ELSE
NEED TO BE SEEN. THEY NEED TO BE
HELD TIGHT IN THE GRIP OF A
COMMUNITY THAT LOVES INSPIRES
AND FIERCELY PROTECTS THEM. THEY
NEED THEIR BASIC NEEDS MET. THEY
NEED ACCESS AND OPPORTUNITY TO
BLOSSOM THEIR POTENTIAL. ALL
THINGS THAT ARE DEEPLY
INCOMPATIBLE WITH ANY PROBATION
DEPARTMENT IN CALIFORNIA. THERE
ARE OPPORTUNITIES TO SHIFT
RESTORATIVE AND REHABILITATIVE
CARE. DIVERSIONARY CARE AS
MANDATED BY STATE LAW THAT YOU
HAVE NOT. JUSTICE CRIME
PREVENTION ACT PASSED OVER 20
YEARS AGO, WAS INTENDED TO
PROVIDE COUNTY AGENCIES AND èC
B Ó S¼, WITH THE FUNDING NEEDED
TO ENACT THESE PROACTIVE
INTERVENTIONS. HOWEVER THIS GRAN
INSTEAD GETS SPENT LARGELY ON
PROBATION, SALARIES AND BENEFITS
. YOU HAVE THE POWER TO CLARIFY
HOW THIS GRANT CAN BE SPENT. YOU
CAN SUPPORT LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS
TO ADD COMMUNITY REPRESENTATION
ON THE COUNTY. THAT OVERSEE THIS
GRANT. THIS ISN'T A CATCH ALL
FIX IN ANY WAY BUT A BEGINNING
TO SHIFTING POWER TO BUILDING
RESOURCES AND COLLECTIVE
COMMUNITY CARE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS
LATI SHAAR. I'M FROM CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND, CALIFORNIA AND
ALSO FROM THE LOS ANGELES YOUTH
UPRISING COALITION. YOU'VE HEARD
A LOT TODAY ABOUT LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. AND I WANNA HIGHLIGHT
AGAIN THAT L A PROBATION WAS
ASKED TO BE HERE TODAY AND
REFUSED. AND THIS IS THIS IS IN
LINE WITH THEIR TRACK RECORD. L.
A PROBATION IS A DEPARTMENT THAT
HAS REPEATEDLY REFUSED ANY KIND
OF CALL FOR ACCOUNTABILITY,
INTROSPECTION, TRANSPARENCY.
WE'VE HEARD HERE TODAY ABOUT THE
CONDITIONS IN THESE FACILITIES,
AND IT IS CLEAR THAT THIS IS A
DEPARTMENT THAT IS BEYOND REFORM
. THERE IS NÓ TRAINING. THERE IS
NÓ FUNDING. THERE IS NÓ TRAINING
CENTER UPGRADES THAT CAN CHANGE.
A CULTURE THAT IS SO DEEP ROOTED
RIGHT NOW IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
IF THIS IS HOW THEY TREAT YOU
IMAGINE HOW THEY TREAT THE YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO THEY WIELD COMPLETE
CONTROL OVER THEY CONTROL AND
SURVEIL ON A DAILY BASIS. THIS
IS A DEPARTMENT THAT HAS NOT
HUNDREDS, BUT OVER THREE 1000
ALLEGATIONS OF CHILDHOOD SEXUAL
ASSAULT LEVIED AGAINST THEM. AND
LOCAL 685. THE UNION THAT DOES
REPRESENT THEIR RANK AND FILE
HAS GONE A NATIONAL TELEVISION
AND FLATLY DENIED THAT THERE IS
ANY WRONGDOING WITHIN THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT. THIS IS
ALSO A UNION THAT HAS ASKED YOU
FOR A BILLION DOLLARS OVER FOUR
YEARS IN THIS YEAR ALONE FOR AN
UPGRADED FOR UPGRADED FACILITIES
WHERE THEY CAN CONTINUE TO
CONTROL AND SURVEIL AND ABUSE
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE AND EMBED
THEMSELVES AS THE ONLY ANSWER TO
WHAT HAPPENS AFTER HARM IS
COMMITTED. BUT YOU HAVE THE
POWER TO DENY THAT REQUEST. YOU
HAVE THE POWER TO INSTEAD USE
THAT FUNDING FOR ALTERNATIVES
THAT ARE NOT JUST SHINY NEW
PAINT ON FACILITIES THAT WE KNOW
CAUSE SO MUCH ABUSE AND DAMAGE.
YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO INVEST
THAT ELSEWHERE, AS MY COLLEAGUE
MÀ. MELINDA STATED EARLIER. YOU
CAN DIVERSIFY THE PORTFOLIO HERE
INSTEAD OF GRANTING THIS REQUEST
FOR A BILLION DOLLARS FOR SHINY
NEW CHILD PRISONS. YOU CAN USE
THAT MONEY TO FUND ALTERNATIVES.
YOU CAN USE THAT MONEY TO ENSURE
THAT THERE IS A OPTION OTHER
THAN BARRY, J, NEIDORF OR
CENTRAL JUVENILE HALL OR EVEN
KILPATRICK BECAUSE AT THE END OF
THE DAY, AS WAS STATED EARLIER,
YOU CAN'T GET WELL IN AND IF YOU
CONTINUE TO FUND SIMPLE UPGRADES
TO THESE FACILITIES, YOU ARE
MISSING OUT ON ALL THE OP
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP YOUNG PEOPLE
IN THE COMMUNITY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HELLO UH, MY NAME IS
AARON PALACIOS. AND I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH THE YOUTH LAW
CENTER. UM I'VE APPRECIATED
LISTENING TO THE QUESTIONS TODAY
, AND I WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT WHAT
I THINK IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
QUESTION WHICH WAS I THINK,
WHERE DOES THE BUCK STOP? AND I
JUST WANNA POINT OUT THERE'S
BILLIONS OF BUCKS AND MANY OF
THEM STOP WITH YOU. AND IN SOME
OF THOSE WAYS, I HEARD SENATOR
MANJAR MENTION THE UPCOMING WORK
TO REDO THE ALLOCATION FOR THE
JJ RBG FUNDING, WHICH IS ABOUT A
QUARTER BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
TO COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENTS
AND JUST ONE FUND. WE NEED MORE
THAN AN ALLOCATION FORMULA. WE
ACTUALLY NEED REQUIREMENTS TIED
TO THAT MONEY. BECAUSE IF WE
DON'T HAVE REQUIREMENTS FOR THAT
MONEY, WHAT WE HAVE IS
CONTINUOUS FUNDING FOLLOWING
CONTINUOUS FAILURE. SO WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED THAT CORRECTED
AND THAT'S IN YOUR POWER TO
CORRECT WE NEED A STRONG,
INDEPENDENT STATE OVERSIGHT BODY
. THERE IS NÓ INDEPENDENT STATE
OVERSIGHT BODY RIGHT NOW. THERE
IS VERY LIMITED OVERSIGHT. THESE
FACILITIES, WHICH HOUSE SOME OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN IN
SOME OF THE MOST DANGEROUS
FACILITIES THAT THIS STATE HAS
HAVE A REQUIREMENT TO BE
INSPECTED ONCE EVERY TWO YEARS,
AND THERE IS NÓ REQUIREMENT THAT
THAT BE UNANNOUNCED. THAT MEANS
YOU ACTUALLY HAVE NÓ IDEA ON A
DAY TO DAY BASIS. WHAT HAPPENS
IN THESE FACILITIES AND WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN L? A IS NOT UNIQUE.
IT IS SIMPLY THE BIGGEST, MOST
OBVIOUS FAILURE THAT CANNOT
CURRENTLY BE IGNORED. WHEN I SAY
THAT WE NEED OVERSIGHT RIGHT NOW
. I WOULD ALSO ENCOURAGE YOU TO
LOOK BACK AT THE 2019 REPORT
FROM THE L A Ó ON THE BOARD OF
STATE AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS.
WHICH QUESTIONS WHY DOES THE
MAJORITY MADE UP OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT? WHY IT HAS NÓ
MISSION. WHY IT IS THAT THE
AUTHORITY THAT YOU ALL HAVE TO
DRIVE POLICY ON MINIMUM
STANDARDS, SAYS ONLY THAT
JUVENILE HALLS SHOULD HAVE
MINIMUM STANDARDS FOR THE
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATION OF THE
FACILITIES. ABSENT IN THERE IS
THE SAFETY HAIR, WELL BEING
EDUCATION, HEALTH TREATMENT OF
YOUNG PEOPLE, AND THAT NEEDS TO
BE ADDED YOU ARE. I THINK,
GETTING THE MINIMUM STANDARDS
THAT YOU ARE REQUIRING AND THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED. AND THE
OTHER THING I WOULD SAY REALLY
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED IS HOW
INSPECTIONS ARE SUPPOSED TO TAKE
PLACE WHEN THEY TAKE PLACE IN
THESE FACILITIES, AND WHETHER OR
NOT THESE FACILITIES SHOULD BE
LICENSED, LIKE OTHER CHILDREN'S
FACILITIES OPERATED BY COUNTIES
RATHER THAN JUST OVERSEEN ON
EVERY OTHER YEAR BASIS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS. I MEAN, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT ELSE I THINK I'VE I'VE SAID
IT ALL. UH, IN THIS HEARING, UM.
HONESTLY JUST NOTHING ELSE TO
SAY. I DO APPRECIATE SO MANY
PEOPLE COMING UP HERE FROM
VARIOUS BACKGROUNDS EXPERTISE
FROM ACROSS THE STATE. I LOVE
HEARING EXAMPLES OF WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE WHEN, UM THE 5% OF
PROBATION OFFICERS. THAT'S
ANOTHER THING. I WAS GIVEN A
CARE, YOU KNOW, FROM THOSE TWO
GENTLEMEN THAT SHARE THEIR
STORIES. UM, I'D LOVE TO HEAR. I
LOVED HEARING THE STORIES FROM
SONOMA COUNTY PROBATION OFFICER
AND WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND HOW
IT IS POSSIBLE TO HAVE A
PROBATION DEPARTMENT. UM, UM, DO
THE GREAT WORK IN COLLABORATION
WITH ANOTHER ENTITY. WHAT SHE
SAID WAS KEY IS THAT THEY KNOW
THAT THEY NEED THE SUPPORT AND I
THINK THAT'S WHERE I'M LEADING
WITH THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
ANOTHER ENTITY THAT COMES AND
SUPPORTS THIS. I THINK WE NEED
TO LOOK AT THIS THE WAY WE LOOK
AT LAW ENFORCEMENT OVERALL,
RIGHT, SO MANY OF OUR
PROGRESSIVE MEMBERS WERE TALKING
ABOUT HOW WE NEED SOCIAL WORKERS
WITH EVERY LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER OUT IN THE STREET. I
THINK THAT'S HOW WE SHOULD LOOK
AT PROBATION OFFICERS. WE NEED
SOMEONE WHO IS TRAINED IN THIS
ATTACHED WITH SOMEONE WHO, UM,
IS THERE FOR THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY OF EVERYONE ELSE. UM,
LOOKING FOR A PARTNER IN FURTHER
WITH MY, UM UH COCHA HERE, UM,
ON THIS TYPE OF WORK, SEEING
WHAT WE CAN DO AS BOTH L A
MEMBERS, UM OUR BACKYARDS AND
PROTECTING THE YOUTH IN L A AND
THEN CONTINUE TO LEARN FROM
OTHER FACILITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE DOING SOME
GOOD WORK. UM AND FINDING A WAY
TO GET MORE KIDS TO PINE GROVE
AS WELL. I KNOW THERE'S ISSUES
ON MEDICAL COVERAGE AT PINE
GROVES. THERE'S IS PAY RATE, UH,
AT PINE GROVE AND, YOU KNOW,
FINDING A WAY TO INCENTIVIZE
MORE YOUTH TO GO THERE AND
BECOME FIREFIGHTERS. AFTER THAT,
UM WITH THAT, I JUST, UH, LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE HAVING THESE
CONVERSATIONS, BUT NOT FOR A
LONG TIME. I LOOK FORWARD TO
ENDING THESE CONVERSATIONS. MORE
THAN THAT, UM, BECAUSE I THINK I
SAID THIS LAST YEAR, I WAS LIKE,
I DON'T WANNA COME BACK NEXT
YEAR AND HAVE THE SAME
CONVERSATIONS RIGHT? I THINK
IT'S ABOUT SEEING EACH TIME
PROGRESS AND I DON'T KNOW IF I'M
SEEING PROGRESS SINCE LAST YEAR
TO BE HONEST, BUT I DO KNOW THAT
WE HAVE DEDICATED MEMBERS HERE
TO ADDRESS A LOT OF THESE
ISSUES. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR
AND, UH, I ONLY WANT TO ADD. I
UH AGREE WITH YOU. I JUST WANNA
ADD. THERE'S SO MANY, UM THE
TESTIMONIES THAT WERE GIVEN HERE
HEREBY, UM EVERYONE WHO IS IN IN
SOME WAY TOUCHED OR TOUCHING OUR
JUVENILE. UM JUST JUSTICE SYSTEM
. UM I APPRECIATE THAT. YOU
TRYING AND YOU'RE WORKING HARD
TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT ARE
THE SYSTEMIC CHANGES THAT WE
NEED BECAUSE WE DO NEED SYSTEMIC
CHANGES. THERE'S NÓ DOUBT ABOUT
IT. UM, I APPRECIATE. EVERYONE
WHO, UH, TESTIFIED TOLD THEIR
PERSONAL STORIES TOLD US ABOUT,
UM WHAT YOU RECOMMENDATIONS ARE,
UH, I THINK STAFFING LEVELS AT
AT EVERY, UM, PART OF THE
DEPARTMENT NEEDS TO BE NEEDS TO
BE ACKNOWLEDGED FOR TRYING. UM
AND I WANNA DO A SPECIAL SHOUT
OUT FOR ALSO FOR THE PUBLIC
DEFENDERS AND JUVENILE, UH,
DIVISION, UH, FOR THE WORK THAT
THEY DO ALONGSIDE OF ALL OF
THOSE IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
GIVE OF THEIR TIME. UH UH, TO
RAISE THE VOICES OF OUR YOUTH.
SO UM, SOMEWHERE ALL OF THESE
VOICES THAT CAME TOGETHER TODAY
NEED TO DO IT ON A MUCH MORE
CONSTANT BASIS, SO THAT WE DON'T
FORGET OUR ONE VOICE OR DEMONIZE
ANOTHER VOICE, BUT RATHER THAT
WE INCLUDE EVERYBODY'S VOICES IN
THIS FINAL, UM, SOLUTION, SO
THANK YOU ALL. I APPRECIATE YOU
ALL VERY MUCH. I GUESS THERE WAS
A PARTICULAR PUBLIC DEFENDER M
BROWNSTEIN, WHOSE NAME WAS
BROUGHT UP SEVERAL TIMES. WHERE
ARE YOU HERE? OH WELL, THANK
YOU. YOUR NAME WAS BROUGHT UP
SEVERAL TIMES IN A JUST WANNA
ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR THE WORK THAT
YOU DO. BUT THAT THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED.